ALL RIGHT. THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE WILL NOW COME
TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
HERE IN THE Þ STREET BUILDING.
AND I ASK THAT ALL MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMITTEE COME PRESENT, COME
BE PRESENTED IN ROOM 22,200 SO
THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM
AND BEGIN OUR HEARING. WE HAVE
27 BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA, AND
NINE OF THOSE ARE ON PROPOSED
CONSENT. I KNOW OUR AUTHORS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO
GET OUT OF HERE BY DINNERTIME,
SO WE WILL GET STARTED, WE WILL
START AT A SUBCOMMITTEE RIGHT
NOW, ABSENT OF A QUORUM, WE HAVE
THE VICE CHAIR AND MYSELF HERE.
SO YOU ARE IN GREAT COMPANY, I
DO SEE ONE OF OUR, AUTHORS HERE,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. SO WE'LL HEAR
ITEM NUMBER TWO, ASSEMBLY BILL
799 AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. HAVE YOU
COME UP TO THE PODIUM? AND IF
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES WITH YOU
TODAY, WE'LL INVITE THEM HERE TO
THE CONFERENCE TABLE. OKAY
GREAT. AND BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. OKAY. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. I WANT TO START BY
THANKING HEATHER FOR HER
THOUGHTFUL AND THOROUGH ANALYSIS
OF THIS BILL. AB 799 THE
HOMELESSNESS, ACCOUNTABILITY AND
RESULTS ACT REQUIRES STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
ADMINISTERING HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE THE
CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS OR CAL ICH WITH
FISCAL AND OUTCOME DATA FROM
GRANTEES AND THE INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES THEY SERVE, WHICH WILL
BE MADE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. THIS
BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE CREATION
AND MAINTENANCE OF A STRATEGIC
FUNDING GUIDE, A ONE STOP SHOP
FOR LOCAL GRANTEES TO NAVIGATE
NEW AND EXISTING FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE SURE ALL
POTENTIAL FUNDING SOURCES ARE
EFFECTIVELY UTILIZED TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS. FINALLY, AB 799
ADDS, THE GOVERNOR'S TRIBAL
ADVISOR TO THE INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL TO ENSURE THE UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVES OF OUR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES ARE CONSIDERED IN
HOMELESS INITIATIVES. AS WE ALL
KNOW, HOMELESSNESS IS AN
INCREASINGLY GROWING PROBLEM
PROBLEM IN OUR STATE. IN 2023,
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA ROSE TO NEARLY
185,000. TO ADDRESS THIS ONGOING
CRISIS, NINE STATE AGENCIES
COLLECTIVELY SPENT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDING OVER
THE PAST FIVE YEARS,
ADMINISTERING AT LEAST 30
PROGRAMS, TO PREVENT AND END
HOMELESSNESS. CAL ICH IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
COORDINATION, DEVELOPMENT AND
EVALUATION OF THE EFFORTS OF
THESE NINE AGENCIES. HOWEVER THE
2024 STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT ON
HOMELESSNESS FOUND THAT THE
STATE LACKS CURRENT INFORMATION
ON THE ONGOING COSTS AND
OUTCOMES OF ITS HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS BECAUSE CAL ISH HAS NOT
CONSISTENTLY TRACKED AND
EVALUATED THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
PREVENT AND END HOMELESSNESS,
THIS AUDIT RECOMMENDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE CAL ICH TO
MANDATE REPORTING BY STATE
AGENCIES OF COST AND OUTCOMES OF
STATE HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS,
DEVELOP SPECIFICS OF DATA
COLLECTION AND COMPILE AND
REPORT THIS COST AND OUTCOME
INFORMATION TO THE PUBLIC. AB
799 WAS DEVELOPED IN RESPONSE TO
THESE FINDINGS TO ENHANCE
ACCOUNTABILITY STANDARDS, ENSURE
OUR STATE DOLLARS ARE USED
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY, AND
THAT OUR LOCAL AGENCIES MAXIMIZE
THEIR IMPACT IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES, TODAY, TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT, I HAVE
LEWIS BROWN WITH THE CORPORATION
FOR SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. HELLO,
MR. BROWN, YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU, GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS STATED, MY NAME IS LEWIS
BROWN JR. I'M WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. WE'RE A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT AND CDFI WORKING TO
ADVANCE SOLUTIONS TO
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. I'M PLEASED
TO BE HERE WITH YOU TODAY TO
VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR AB 799,
THE HOMELESSNESS, ACCOUNTABILITY
AND RESULTS ACT, AB 799 INCLUDES
THREE CRITICAL COMPONENTS THAT
WE BELIEVE WILL STRENGTHEN THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO FINE TUNE
THIS HOMELESS SERVICE,
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS AND
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA,
FIRST AB 799 ADDS A TRIBAL
REPRESENTATIVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS, INDIGENOUS PEOPLE,
AS YOU KNOW, ARE FIVE TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO BE HOMELESS THAN THE
GENERAL CALIFORNIA POPULATION.
AS TRIBAL MEMBERS HAVE STATED
BEFORE, TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS FACE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES IN PREVENTING
AND SOLVING HOMELESSNESS AS
MEMBERS FACE WORSE HOUSING,
WORSENING HOUSING CONDITIONS,
HIGHER RATES OF HOMELESSNESS
RISK, AND LESS ACCESS TO
SHELTERS AND HOMELESS SERVICES
THAN PEOPLE LIVING IN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS. AB 799 WILL HELP
TO ADVANCE EQUITY BY ENSURING
THAT THE TRIBAL VOICE AND THE
PARTICULAR CHALLENGES OF TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES ARE REPRESENTED IN
THE IN THE COUNCIL. SECOND, THE
BILL WILL FOSTER COLLABORATION
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE
STATE BY MAKING IT EASIER FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO IDENTIFY
NEW AND EXISTING STATE PROGRAMS,
AND BY PROMOTING THE STRATEGIC
USE AND LEVERAGING OF THESE
FUNDS, FINALLY, WITHOUT CREATING
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS, TO
ADDITIONAL BURDENS TO FRONTLINE
STAFF. CAL ACH AB 799 WILL
PROVIDE GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND
HOW GRANTEES USE FUNDS BY
REQUIRING THAT THE COUNCIL
ANNUALLY PUBLISH, HOW, STATE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE BEING USED
IN THE OUTCOMES THAT THOSE
EXPENDITURES ARE ACHIEVING, FOR
THE REASONS STATED ON BEHALF OF
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING, I'D LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR. AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, MR. BROWN,
BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD, WE WANT
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALVARADO. GIL, PRESENT. ALVARADO
GILL. PRESENT. AKOBO ACHO BèC.
PRESENT. BLAKE SPEER. LIMÓN
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. HERE.
EXCELLENT. SO WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM, AND WE WILL PROCEED.
OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. DO WE
HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT? PLEASE COME FORWARD TO
THE MICROPHONE AND STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION ONLY.
PLEASE. AND YOUR POSITION. SORRY
HI THERE. RACHEL BHAGWAT, ACLU,
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HELLO, GRACE COPLAND
ON BEHALF OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL? PLEASE
COME FORWARD. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION? OKAY. SEEING NONE,
WE'LL BRING THE, BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS OKAY. WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR SENATOR
MENGIBAR ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S.
RIVAS. I WANTED TO CHECK IN WITH
YOU ABOUT THE STATUS OF YOUR
BILL. SO, THIS ONE WAS ENACTED
FOR QUITE SOME TIME, AND YOU
BROUGHT IT BACK RECENTLY, I DID
NOTE THAT WE HAVE A VERY SIMILAR
BILL IN FRONT OF US HERE TODAY,
CAN YOU TELL US WHAT WORK YOU
DID WITH YOUR COLLEAGUE OR THE
OTHER AUTHOR TO ENSURE THAT YOUR
BILLS, WERE CONGRUENT, NOT
COMPETITIVE? WELL, THIS BILL, AB
799, INCLUDES THE ADDITION OF
THE GOVERNOR'S TRIBAL
REPRESENTATIVE TO THE ISKAL.
ICH, IT ALSO CREATES A STRATEGIC
FUNDING GUIDE FOR NEW AND
EXISTING FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES,
IT'S ALSO MORE TARGETED. AND
WHAT PROGRAMS KALISH WILL
COLLECT DATA FROM. OKAY. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. OKAY. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS? ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR MENGIBAR
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHILE ITEM TWO, AB 799, MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ALVARADO GIL, A
ALVARADO GIL A AQUEBOGUE AYE.
AQUEBOGUE AYE. BLAKE SPEAR.
LIMÓN MENGIBAR A MENGIBAR. AYE.
SO WE HAVE THREE EYES, WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR OUR
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU. I'M SORRY I DIDN'T GIVE YOU
A CHANCE TO CLOSE. IS THAT ALL
RIGHT? OKAY WE CLOSED FOR YOU?
YES. ALL RIGHT. SEEING FORWARD.
AND WE HAVE OUR AUTHOR, SENATOR,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN.
WELCOME. ALL RIGHT. AND IF YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES WITH YOU
TODAY, WE'LL INVITE THEM TO THE
CONFERENCE TABLE. YES, I DO HAVE
ONE WITH ME TODAY. GREAT,
WONDERFUL. ALL RIGHT. SO THANK
YOU, CHAIR AND SENATORS,
CHILDREN AND YOUTH NAVIGATING
CALIFORNIA'S CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM ENCOUNTER DISTINCT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES. AND THE SYSTEM'S
INVOLVEMENT IN SELF. UP TO 80%
OF CHILDREN NAVIGATING CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEMS DISPLAY
SIGNIFICANT MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES, A STARK CONTRAST TO 18
TO 20% 22% AMONG THE GENERAL
POPULATION. ADDITIONALLY, 45%
REPORTED USING ALCOHOL OR DRUGS
WITHIN THE LAST SIX MONTHS, AND
35% MET THE CRITERIA FOR A
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. THE LACK
OF COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DATA IMPAIRS
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO CREATE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THAT MEET
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF THESE
VULNERABLE YOUTH, THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM IMPROVEMENT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT, AB 636.
STEINBERG OF 2001 AIMED TO
IMPROVE DATA COLLECTION,
REPORTING ON THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. THE ACT'S GOALS WERE MET
BY THE CHILD WELFARE INDICATORS
PROJECT, A RESEARCH PROJECT
BETWEEN UC BERKELEY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES,
WHICH HAS DRIVEN CONTINUOUS
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM SINCE ITS
INCEPTION. WHILE THE CHILD
WELFARE INDICATORS PROJECT
COLLECTS HOLISTIC DATA ON
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE, CAREGIVER
RESOURCES AND SUPPORTIVE CARE
ENVIRONMENTS, A CRITICAL GAP IS
THAT THE CHILD WELFARE
INDICATORS PROJECT DOES NOT
INCLUDE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
OUTCOMES. BY AMENDING THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICE REVIEW SYSTEM TO
INCORPORATE EXISTING CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT NEEDS AND STRENGTHS.
KANSEN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DATA AB
1907 WILL ENSURE HOLISTIC
TRACKING, ENABLE A NUANCED
ASSESSMENT OF NEEDS AND
STRENGTHS AND PROMOTE TARGETED
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH
NAVIGATING THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT TODAY IS KAREN
LARSEN, CEO OF THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE. WELCOME, MISS LARSEN.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS KAREN
LARSEN. I'M THE CEO FOR THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE. WE'RE AN
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT DEDICATED
TO REDUCING SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT
FOR CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
BEFORE JOINING THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE, I WAS THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES DIRECTOR IN YOLO
COUNTY, WHERE I OVERSAW PUBLIC
HEALTH, BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICES, INCLUDING CHILD
WELFARE. I SERVED YOLO COUNTY
FOR OVER 20 YEARS, FIRST IN THE
COMMUNITY CLINIC SETTING AND
THEN AT THE COUNTY LEVEL. AND
OVER THE COURSE OF THOSE YEARS,
I SAW CHILDREN IN MY CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM GROW UP AND ENTER
OUR JUVENILE AND ADULT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEMS, AND THEN GROW
UP A LITTLE MORE AND HAVE
CHILDREN OF THEIR OWN WHO
ENTERED MY CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM.
AND SO THESE MULTIGENERATIONAL
PATTERNS OF SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT
PLAY OUT THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
AND THROUGHOUT OUR NATION. AND
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO
INTERVENE. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN MENTIONED IN 2001, OUR
FOUNDER, MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG, AUTHORED AB 636.
SINCE THAT BILL WAS PASSED, IT'S
PROVIDED A GREAT CONTINUOUS
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT FRAMEWORK
FOR OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEMS IN
CALIFORNIA. UNFORTUNATELY,
DESPITE THE BILL'S INTENT TO
INCLUDE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DATA,
TO DATE, IT DOESN'T INCLUDE THAT
TYPE OF DATA. AND SO THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR AB 1907, A BILL THAT
INCORPORATES THIS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DATA INTO THE CHILD
WELFARE INDICATORS PROJECT. AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN
MENTIONED, THESE YOUTH FACE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES DUE TO THE
TRAUMA THAT GOT THEM INTO THE
SYSTEM AND THE SYSTEM
INVOLVEMENT ITSELF, AND WITH
MORE THAN 50% OF THEM NEEDING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
ANOTHER 30% MEETING THEIR
CRITERIA FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS, IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
HAVE LOCAL LEVEL DATA TO MEET
THEIR NEEDS AND ENSURE THAT THE
OUTCOMES IMPROVE FOR THEM OVER
TIME, I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MISS
LARSEN. ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT? PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE WITH YOUR NAME, YOUR
AFFILIATION, YOUR PURPOSE.
CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF ADOLESCENT
AND CHILD PSYCHOLOGY, OR
PSYCHIATRY. SORRY. IN SUPPORT.
VERY DIFFERENT. THANK YOU.
SORRY. ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE TODAY THAT WOULD
LIKE TO BE HEARD. OKAY. SEEING
NONE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL MOVE THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS FOR OUR
AUTHOR. NÓ, DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
OKAY, WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? YES. THANK YOU. THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR ASSISTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE. ITEM
THREE, AB 1907. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ALVARADO GIL A
ALVARADO GIL, A AKOBO. AKABOGU.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. LIMÓN
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE OKAY.
THE EYES ARE THREE NO NO'S. WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OUR
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN US. OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND I SEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES PRESENT.
YOU HAVE THE BENEFIT OF HAVING A
BILL ON CONSENT, BUT WE WILL
HEAR ITEM NUMBER SIX, WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 2033. OKAY ALL
RIGHT. AND THEN DO YOU HAVE SOME
WITNESSES WITH YOU TODAY? YES.
GREAT. WE'LL INVITE THEM OVER TO
OUR CONFERENCE TABLE. AND PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I
PRESENT TO YOU AB 2033, THE ET
ACCESS FOR STUDENT EMPOWERMENT
ACT, AB 2033 DOES TWO THINGS.
FIRST, IT ENSURES THAT COLLEGE
COLLEGE STUDENTS CAN USE THEIR
FOOD BENEFITS OR EBT CARDS. AND
WE DO THIS BY MAKING SURE THAT
EVERY CAMPUS HAS OR IDENTIFIES A
VENDOR WHO TAKES EBT CARDS, AND
IF THEY DON'T HAVE ONE THAT THEY
DO IDENTIFY, THEY DO APPLY TO
BECOME AN AUTHORIZED EBT VENDOR.
THE SECOND IS THAT THIS CAMPUS
WILL ALSO, PROVIDE TO THE
STUDENTS EASILY ACCESSIBLE
INFORMATION ON EBT VENDORS ON
AND OFF CAMPUS, BY REQUIRING THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND CSAS AND
REQUESTING THE UCS TO PROVIDE
THE USDA SNAP RETAILER LOCATOR
LINK, WHICH PROVIDES UP TO A 25
MILE RADIUS MAP OF EBT VENDORS,
A CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION, CSAC REPORT NOTES
THAT ONLY 127,000 STUDENTS
RECEIVE CALFRESH BENEFITS, AND
THAT ONE THIRD OF ALL
POST-SECONDARY STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA DO EXPERIENCE FOOD
INSECURITY. WHILE MANY CSU AND
UC CAMPUSES HAVE BASIC NEEDS
CENTERS AND BASIC NEEDS
COORDINATORS, THIS BILL REQUIRES
THE CSU AND REQUEST THE UC TO
ESTABLISH THESE CENTERS AND
COORDINATORS. DATA DEMONSTRATES
THAT STUDENTS WHO EXPERIENCE
FOOD AND HOUSING CHALLENGES HAVE
LOWER GPAS AND GRADUATION RATES
COMPARED TO STUDENTS WHO HAVE
THEIR BASIC NEEDS MET. CALFRESH
BENEFITS ARE CRITICAL IN HELPING
ADDRESS STUDENT HUNGER, AND IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR STUDENTS TO USE
THESE BENEFITS ON CAMPUS, WHERE
POSSIBLE. AB 2033 WILL MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR STUDENTS TO FOCUS
ON THEIR EDUCATION WHILE HAVING
THEIR BASIC NEEDS MET. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ARE JACOB ROWE, A STUDENT AT
SIERRA COLLEGE, AND ANNA
MATTHEWS, GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
DIRECTOR WITH THE FAMILY. WITH
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WELCOME TO YOU BOTH. WE'LL GIVE
YOU TWO MINUTES EACH TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ANNA
MATTHEWS, GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
DIRECTOR OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2033. ACCORDING
TO REAL COLLEGE CALIFORNIA'S
BASIC NEEDS REPORT, 47% OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE FOOD
INSECURITY. HALF OF THE
POPULATION IS A SIGNIFICANT
PERCENTAGE, AND THE STATISTIC IS
EVEN MORE STAGGERING WHEN YOU
KNOW THE GRAVITY OF FOOD
INSECURITY. HUNGER IS
DETRIMENTAL TO COGNITIVE
CAPACITY, THE ABILITY TO
CONCENTRATE MEMORY, AND IT
ULTIMATELY UNDERMINES STUDENTS
ABILITY TO LEARN. SO LONG AS
THEY EXPERIENCE DEFICIENCIES IN
HAVING THEIR BASIC PHYSIOLOGICAL
NEEDS MET, ALL OTHER PRIORITIES
BECOME SECONDARY, INCLUDING
THEIR EDUCATION. WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT EDUCATION AS A MEANS OF
SOCIOECONOMIC MOBILITY AND THE
DESIRE FOR EQUITABLE STUDENT
OUTCOMES. BUT THIS CANNOT BE
ACHIEVED WITHOUT ADDRESSING THE
DEVASTATING REALITIES OF THE
POVERTY THAT MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS FACE, INCLUDING FOOD
INSECURITY. AB 2033 ADDRESSES
THE TRUTH THAT FOOD INSECURITY
IS A SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO MANY
STUDENTS PURSUIT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION AND IMPEDES THEIR
PROGRESS TOWARDS THEIR GOALS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES
DISPROPORTIONATELY SERVE
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY GROUPS
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS,
STUDENT PARENTS, AND OTHER
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS, WHILE
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
EXIST, A LACK OF AWARENESS AND
ACCESSIBILITY ON CAMPUSES
REDUCES STUDENT UTILIZATION OF
THESE RESOURCES BY MANDATING EBT
ACCESS POINTS AND INCREASING
STUDENTS KNOWLEDGE OF LOCAL
RESOURCES. THIS BILL AIMS TO
INCREASE PARTICIPATION IN
CALFRESH AND ULTIMATELY IMPROVE
STUDENTS ABILITY TO MEET THEIR
BASIC NEEDS, ADDRESSING HUNGER,
POVERTY, AND ELIMINATING
ELIMINATING OBSTACLES TO STUDENT
SUCCESS. THIS BILL IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO PROMOTE
AN INCLUSIVE AND ACCESSIBLE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL
STUDENTS, AND BRIDGING EQUITY
GAPS IN ACCESS TO RESOURCES
CRITICAL TO THEIR HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS JACOB
BROUGH, A SECOND YEAR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT AND PRESIDENT OF
THE NATIVE AMERICANS OF SIERRA
COLLEGE CLUB. TODAY, I TESTIFY
BEFORE YOU TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
PASSING OF AB 2033. THIS BILL
ADDRESSES A PRESSING ISSUE THAT
AFFECTS THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING
MYSELF. FOOD INSECURITY. AS YOU
KNOW, PROGRAMS SUCH AS CALFRESH
ARE ESSENTIAL TO SUPPORTING LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS DESPITE
ELIGIBILITY, MANY POST-SECONDARY
STUDENTS ARE UNABLE TO ACCESS
THESE BENEFITS, RESULTING IN
WIDESPREAD FOOD INSECURITY
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THAT IS PREVENTABLE, AB 2033
AIMS TO CHANGE THIS BY MANDATING
THAT EACH PUBLIC INSTITUTION OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA
HAS AT LEAST ONE EBT ACCEPTING
VENDOR ON CAMPUS. STUDENTS WILL
HAVE INCREASED ACCESS TO
NUTRITIONAL RESOURCES AT THEIR
PLACE OF STUDY. ADDITIONALLY, IT
CALLS FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
BASIC NEED CENTERS AND
COORDINATORS WITHIN OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS, ENSURING
THAT STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES AND SUPPORTS
THEY NEED. AS A
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
STUDENT, I HAVE FACED VARIOUS
BARRIERS WITHIN MY EDUCATION AT
TIMES STRUGGLING TO MEET EVEN MY
MOST BASIC NEEDS. SOME DAYS I
HAVE QUESTIONED IF I WAS GOING
TO HAVE FOOD TO EAT, AND AT
TIMES HAVE HAD TO ACCEPT THAT
GOING HUNGRY WAS MY ONLY OPTION.
THE BASIC NEEDS CENTER AT MY
SCHOOL HAS BEEN AN INVALUABLE
RESOURCE THROUGHOUT MY ACADEMIC
JOURNEY, AND HAS MADE IT
POSSIBLE FOR MY NEEDS TO BE MET,
LET ALONE SIT HERE TODAY HAVING
ACCESS TO RESOURCES. THIS YEAR,
COLLEGE BASIC NEEDS CENTER HAS
PROVIDED IS SOMETHING EVERY
STUDENT DESERVES, REGARDLESS OF
THEIR STUDENT, REGARDLESS OF
THEIR FOOD SECURITY STATUS. AB
2033 IS ESSENTIAL FOR STUDENTS
LIKE ME TO HAVE A CHANCE IN
ACHIEVING THEIR GOALS IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. PLEASE STAND WITH US
IN ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO YOU BOTH
FOR BEING HERE. ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT? PLEASE COME
FORWARD. REBECCA GONZALEZ,
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN, ON BEHALF OF
THE STUDENT SENATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE, IS
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. JOHNNY VU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. SAM WILKINSON WITH GRAYSON
AND CHILD POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
DO YOU HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THAT
LIKE TO COME FORWARD AND BE
HEARD? OKAY. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. OKAY. SEEING NONE,
WE'LL BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS A
QUESTION FOR YOU. AUTHOR, I KNOW
WITH THE UCS WE ARE ENCOURAGING
AND RECOMMENDING THEM ACCORDING
TO THIS BILL, CAN YOU TELL ME A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT YOUR
CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN WITH THE
UC OFFICIALS ABOUT YOUR BILL?
IT'S BEEN VERY POSITIVE. IT'S
JUST THAT UNDER THE WAY, THE WAY
THE LAW IS WRITTEN, WE CANNOT
REQUIRE IT OF THEM. BUT IT'S
BEEN VERY POSITIVE. VERY
POSITIVE. OKAY. AND THEN ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT I HAD, BUT I
THINK I FOUND IT IN SOME OF THE
SUPPORT LETTERS WAS HOW ARE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES GOING TO
IMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM WITH
MULTIPLE SITES? AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE THEY'RE EXCITED ABOUT YOUR
BILL AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
ROLLING IT OUT IN A UNIFORM WAY
SO THAT STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS AT
ALL CAMPUSES. RIGHT. WE REALLY
ARE EXCITED ABOUT THAT. THE
SUPPORT FROM OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, ACTUALLY, ALL OF THE
CAMPUSES, THEY RECOGNIZE HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS FOR OUR
STUDENTS. ABSOLUTELY,
ABSOLUTELY. AND I REMEMBER, YOU
KNOW, IN MY COLLEGE YEARS, THE
WHOLE NOTION OF A STARVING
STUDENT. AND WE TOOK LIGHT OF
THAT. BUT THE REALITY IS TO THE
POINTS THAT YOU MADE TODAY IN
YOUR PRESENTATIONS IS THAT IS
THE FUNDAMENTAL NEED IN ORDER
FOR US TO BE SUCCESSFUL. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM THE COMMITTEE?
MOTION FROM SENATOR MENGIBAR.
OKAY. ASSISTANT Ó, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I'D LIKE TO TAKE
THE COMMENTS, AND I WANT TO
THANK OUR TWO WITNESSES. THIS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO HAVE
SOMEBODY FROM THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND ALSO OUR STUDENT
TO BRING THE STUDENT'S
PERSPECTIVE. AND I WANT TO THANK
THEM BOTH FOR BEING HERE
TESTIFYING. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT, ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL BILL WAS MOVED BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR FILE ITEM
6AB2033. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO GIL A ALVARADO GIL A
OCHOA. BOGUE I AKABOGU. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. LIMÓN MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. AYE. OKAY WE HAVE
THREE EYES AND NO NO'S. WE WILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OUR
COLLEAGUES TO COME IN AND VOTE
AS WELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE. THANK YOU. OKAY DO I
SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS? I
DON'T RIGHT OKAY. WE WILL MOVE
FORWARD TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1993. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA, IF YOU COULD
INVITE YOUR WITNESSES, IF YOU
HAVE WITNESSES TO COME FORWARD,
WE'LL GET SITUATED. AND WHEN
YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN, PLEASE DO
. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR. AB 1993 WOULD HELP
ADDRESS THE HOUSING NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S GROWING AGING
POPULATION BY EXPANDING THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS IN
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY OR ARCHIVES CAN
SERVE BY REPLACING THE SIX BED
CAP WITH A EIGHT OR FEWER CAP.
RCF ARE COMMUNITY BASED HOMES
THAT OFFER HOUSING ARRANGEMENTS
FOR VARIOUS LEVELS OF
NON-MEDICAL CARE AND
SUPERVISION. ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING POPULATIONS OF UNHOUSED
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA IS OUR
OLDER ADULTS, WHO ARE AT GREATER
RISK OF BECOMING HOMELESS THAN
EVER BEFORE. BY ALLOWING RCF TO
EXPAND AND SERVE MORE PEOPLE, AB
1993 CAN HELP ENSURE THERE ARE
MORE AVAILABLE SPACES FOR OLDER
ADULTS WHO CHOOSE AN ASSISTED
LIVING HOME CAN REMAIN IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES WHILE ALSO RECEIVING
THE 24 HOUR NON-MEDICAL CARE
THEY NEED. THE RCF MUST MEET THE
SAFETY AND BUILDING STANDARDS
AND LICENSING REGULATIONS, FOR
INSTANCE, UNDER TITLE 22 OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES, COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING, NO MORE THAN TWO
RESIDENTS SHALL SLEEP IN A
BEDROOM. TITLE 22 PROVIDES A SET
OF OPERATIONAL STANDARDS FOR RCF
FEES AND CDSS. LICENSING
DEPARTMENT WOULD STILL NEED TO
EVALUATE THE HOME TO DETERMINE
HOW MANY THEY CAN OCCUPY AND IF
THEY CAN BE LICENSED TO SERVE
RESIDENTS. ENSURING THESE HOMES
MEET THE SAFETY AND BUILDING
STANDARDS TO EXPAND IS A
PRIORITY. SO UNDER THIS BILL,
RCF WOULD STILL BE REQUIRED TO
BE CONSISTENT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS MIA KANG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION
ON AGING AND GEORGE MARION,
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT WITH SIX
BEDS. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE,
PLEASE MAINTAIN TWO MINUTES FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. GOOD AFTERNOON,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I AM MIA
KANG, FORMER TWO TERM
COMMISSIONER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING. AND WE'RE
THE BILL'S PROUD SPONSOR AS A
HOUSING DEVELOPER WITH DECADES
OF EXPERIENCE BUILDING SENIOR
COMMUNITIES, I CAN ATTEST TO THE
GROWING POPULATION OF OLDER
CALIFORNIANS THAT NEED MEDICAL
DAILY. EXCUSE ME? THAT NEED
NON-MEDICAL ASSISTANCE EVERY
DAY. MANY OLDER ADULTS HAVE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES THAT DON'T
QUALIFY THEM FOR IN-HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. OTHERS
REQUIRE MORE CARE THAN WHAT
IN-HOME SUPPORT SERVICES CAN
PROVIDE. OTHERS HAVE
INSUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO AFFORD
THE EXTRAORDINARY COST OF 24
HOUR IN-HOME CARE FOR MANY OLDER
ADULTS WHO NEED ASSISTANCE WITH
DAILY LIVING, A RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITY, RCF, IS THEIR FRANKLY
ONLY OPTION IN MANY CASES. IN
CALIFORNIA, THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES CCL INSPECTS,
REGULATES AND DETERMINES THE
NUMBER OF RESIDENTS THE RCF IS
APPROVED FOR. THIS DETERMINATION
IS BASED ON THE LICENSING
SKILLS, STAFF AVAILABILITY AND
BUILDING FEATURES AMONG MANY
OTHER THINGS, AND THE
REGULATIONS. THE STATE
REGULATIONS REQUIRE THAT NO MORE
THAN TWO PERSONS MAY OCCUPY ONE
BEDROOM. CURRENTLY IN MOST
CITIES AND COUNTIES, PRIVATE RCF
OPERATORS ARE LIMITED BY LOCAL
PLANNING AND ZONING LAWS, AND
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS, AND
THIS SETS UP THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT RVS CAN SERVE.
CURRENTLY, SIX BEDS IS WHAT IS
ALLOWED FOR RVS TO MAINTAIN ITS
RESIDENTIAL CAPACITY. THIS BILL
WILL TAKE IT TO EIGHT BEDS, AND
THE EIGHT BEDS IS A IS A CAP
THAT MEETS THE CURRENT HOUSING
DEMAND, AS WELL AS THE CURRENT
HOUSING PRODUCT THAT'S OUT
THERE. THIS INCREASED CAPACITY
WILL ALLOW FOR MORE OLDER ADULTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES TO ACCESS 24
HOUR, NON-MEDICAL, DAILY
ASSISTANCE CARE. I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA FOR
AUTHORING AB 1993, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THIS
COMMITTEE'S FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS GEORGE CæA AND I SERVE AS
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF PUBLIC
POLICY AND LEGISLATION FOR SIX
BEDS, WHICH IS A STATEWIDE TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE
SMALL RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY OR
RVS THAT SERVE SIX OR FEWER
RESIDENTS, WE'RE THRILLED TO BE
CO-SPONSORING THIS BILL AND
WOULD LIKE TO START BY THANKING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA FOR
CHAMPIONING THIS IMPORTANT
PUBLIC POLICY ISSUE, THE
ORIGINAL STATUTE THAT THIS BILL
SEEKS TO AMEND WAS ENACTED
ALMOST 40 YEARS AGO. WHAT WAS
ONCE A GROUNDBREAKING PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT SPAWNED THE
CREATION OF A SIX BED RCF
ECOSYSTEM COMPRISING
APPROXIMATELY 5500 FACILITIES,
HAS FALLEN BEHIND THE TIMES AS
OUR POPULATION HAS CHANGED. BY
2030, THERE WILL BE 10.8 MILLION
OLDER ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA
COMPARED TO ONLY 3,000,000 IN
1990. 1.8 MILLION CALIFORNIANS
60 AND OVER LIVE ALONE, AND
OLDER CALIFORNIANS ARE LIVING
LONGER WITH MORE CHRONIC
ILLNESSES. NOT ONLY IS
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION CHANGED,
SO HAVE THE ECONOMICS OF AGING.
WITH OVER 2 MILLION CALIFORNIANS
AGE 60 PLUS BEING ECONOMICALLY
INSECURE WITH FIXED INCOMES,
UNABLE TO KEEP UP WITH THE
RISING COSTS OF HOUSING, HEALTH
AND CARE. IN FACT, AMONG THE
UNHOUSED, OLDER CALIFORNIANS ARE
THE FASTEST GROWING AGE GROUP.
CALIFORNIA'S SMALL CITIES, LIKE
THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS THEY SEEK
TO SERVE, ARE FACING SOME OF THE
SAME CHALLENGES, SUCH AS HIGHER
THAN EVER HOUSING COSTS. JUST
RECENTLY, THE MEDIAN SALES PRICE
FOR A HOME IN CALIFORNIA PASSED
$900,000 FOR THE FIRST TIME. AB
1993 CAN HELP ADDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES BY ALLOWING RVS THE
OPTION TO GO UP TO EIGHT BEDS
WITHOUT BEING SUBJECTED TO THE
COMPLICATED, TIME CONSUMING AND
HIGHLY DISCRETIONARY CONDITIONAL
USE PERMITTING PROCESSES THAT
ARE OFTEN FRAUGHT WITH NIMBYISM
THAT HAS THE EFFECT OF LIMITING
HOUSING AND CARE ACCESS FOR
OLDER CALIFORNIANS. LEVERAGING
AN EXISTING SUPPLY OF SIX
SPECIES, MANY OF WHICH ALREADY
HAVE THREE OR MORE BEDROOMS AND
CAN CURRENTLY HOUSE MORE THAN
SIX RESIDENTS, AB 1993 COULD
RESULT IN THOUSANDS OF
ADDITIONAL BEDS IN A SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME. TODAY, THIS
COMMITTEE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TAKE A STEP TOWARDS ADVANCING
INNOVATIVE LEGISLATION THAT
FURTHERS CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
POLICY GOAL OF IMPROVING ACCESS
TO HOUSING FOR ALL AGES AND
STAGES. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTES AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OF THE COMMITTEE'S
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT? PLEASE COME FORWARD
WITH YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON LISA COLEMAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
AGING PROUD SPONSORS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AMBER KING WITH
LEADING EDGE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HEATHER
HARRISON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSISTED LIVING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD?
OKAY. SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE I'LL BRING
THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
, COLLEAGUES. SENATOR OKOBO,
PLEASE. HI. WELCOME AND THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD, I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL, BUT I DO WANT TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS AND ASK
SOME CLARIFICATION QUESTIONS
WITH REGARDS TO, THE CONCERNS
THAT THE REALTORS, POSED. NOW,
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I WOULD,
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE CONCERNS
THAT THEY HAD WAS THE FACT THAT
IT WOULD REMOVE MORE INVENTORY
AWAY FROM FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS
COMING INTO THE MARKET. IF I, IF
I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY, IS
BASICALLY, ONE OF THE, ONE OF
THE CONCERNS THAT THEY HAVE, ON
THAT I WOULD PROBABLY MENTION
THAT, AS WE HAVE OR PLACE MORE
SENIORS OR TWO ADDITIONAL
SENIORS PER, HOUSEHOLD, THOSE
SENIORS AS HOME WILL NOW BECOME
AVAILABLE TO THE MARKET, EITHER
TO THEIR CURRENT FAMILY MEMBERS
OR TO NEW, NEW HOME BUYERS IN
THE MARKET. THAT'S THE WAY THAT
I SEE IT. SO THAT'S TWO
ADDITIONAL HOMES THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE, PER RESIDENTIAL UNIT.
SO THAT'S THE WAY THAT I'M
ACTUALLY REASONING THE SUPPORT
FOR THIS PARTICULAR BILL, THE
ONLY OTHER CONCERN, THAT THEY
HAD, WHICH I CAN'T I WANT A
LITTLE MORE CLARIFICATION ON, IS
THE FACT THAT, IN THE BILL, IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT WE THERE'S
NO LANGUAGE WITH REGARDS TO HOW
MANY, SENIORS ARE ALLOWED TO
OCCUPY PER BEDROOM. AND I KNOW
THAT IN OTHER SPACES, SUCH AS
IN, IN, IN, IN FACILITATING
HOUSING FOR FOSTER YOUTH,
THERE'S A LIMIT. NORMALLY
THERE'S, THERE'S USUALLY A
COMPONENT THAT ADDRESSES THAT.
BUT I DO WANT WITH THAT IN MIND
THOUGH I DO WANT TO STATE THAT I
DO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
SOME, RESIDENTIAL HOMES WHOSE
BEDROOMS ARE LARGER SO THEY
COULD ACCOMMODATE, YOU KNOW, 3
OR 4 BEDS, RATHER THAN JUST TWO.
SOME ARE REALLY, REALLY SMALL,
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE ONE. IS
THERE ANY CONVERSATION AS TO HOW
TO ADDRESS THAT PARTICULAR
CONCERN? BECAUSE IT IS, IT WOULD
BE A CONCERN. WELL, THANK YOU,
SENATOR, ON YOUR FIRST POINT, I
AGREE 100. THIS BILL IS REALLY
ABOUT LEVERAGING EXISTING
HOUSING. SO THOSE THAT HAVE
CURRENTLY SIX BEDS COULD
POTENTIALLY APPLY TO HAVE AS
MANY AS EIGHT. AND SO AND YOUR
OTHER POINT WAS VERY WELL TAKEN
IN THAT IT'S REALLY ALLOWING
FOLKS TO LEAVE THEIR CURRENT
HOME TO GO INTO A LIVING
ENVIRONMENT WITH A LITTLE BIT
MORE ASSISTANCE OPENING THAT
HOME UP TO THE MARKET OR TO
THEIR KIDS AND WHAT HAVE YOU.
BUT THE CONCERN YOU JUST RAISED
I IN FACT, IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
REALTORS, WE ACTUALLY DID HAVE
AN AMENDMENT IN THERE THAT WOULD
HAVE CAPPED IT TO. SO I AGREE
WITH THE GENERAL, SENTIMENT OF
THE REALTORS. WE REMOVED THAT
COMPONENT FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS. ONE IS UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA CODE OF REGULATIONS,
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING. THERE
ALREADY IS A REGULATION THAT
WOULD BE NO MORE THAN TWO
RESIDENTS PER ROOM. AND SO IT
WOULD BE DUPLICATIVE TO ADD IT,
HOWEVER. AND SO YOU WOULD THINK,
WELL, WHY WHAT'S THE BIG DEAL OF
ADDING IT THEN. WELL, THE CDSS
MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT THEY DID
NOT WANT THAT IN THERE, BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO LOSE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW FOR
CREATIVE SLEEPING SPACE FOR
FACILITIES DURING EMERGENCIES.
AND SO THE CURRENT REGULATIONS
ALREADY CAPS IT TO. I AGREE WITH
THAT. TWO, I AGREE WITH THE
REALTORS THAT IT SHOULD BE JUST
TWO. YOU WANT A QUALITY LIVING
ENVIRONMENT FOR FOLKS IN THESE
HOMES, BUT BECAUSE CDSS DID NOT
WANT THAT CODIFIED BECAUSE THEY
WANTED A LITTLE MORE FLEXIBILITY
IN EMERGENCY TYPE SITUATIONS,
AND THEY FELT IT WAS UNNECESSARY
BECAUSE IT ALREADY THE
REGULATIONS ALREADY HAVE A CAP
OF TWO. THAT'S WHY WE DIDN'T
HAVE THAT IN THERE. EVEN THOUGH
I AGREE WITH THE REALTORS
SENTIMENT. SO GENERALLY
SPEAKING, IT'S STILL GOING TO BE
A CAP OF TWO, IN CDSS. AGAIN,
JUST DID NOT WANT THAT CODIFIED
IN THERE IN THE CASE OF AN
EMERGENCY. AND THEY HAD TO HAVE
A LITTLE BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY IN
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS. QUESTIONS.
SENATOR MENGIBAR, I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY. SO CDSS GENERALLY WILL,
THE LICENSING DEPARTMENT WILL GO
IN AND LICENSE A HOME AND ENSURE
THERE'S ONLY TWO ADULTS PER ROOM
. AND THAT'S THE GENERAL
UNWRITTEN RULE. THEY DON'T WANT
IT CODIFIED BECAUSE, SAY THERE'S
AN EMERGENCY. YOU THEY WANT TO
BE ABLE TO PUT IN MORE PEOPLE IN
IT. IT'S NOT ONLY AN UNWRITTEN
RULE, IT'S A WRITTEN RULE. THE
REGULATION ALREADY STATES THAT
IT BE NO MORE THAN TWO RESIDENTS
PER BEDROOM. THERE IS A WRITTEN
RULE, IF I CAN JUST ADD, IT'S IN
THE CALIFORNIA CODE OF
REGULATIONS, TITLE 22. WHAT
HAPPENS, THOUGH, IF IT GOES INTO
STATUTE, THEN THE DEPARTMENT
LOSES ITS FLEXIBILITY TO KIND OF
WORK AROUND THAT DURING TIMES OF
EMERGENCY. IF IT'S IN
REGULATION, THE DEPARTMENT HAS
THE FLEXIBILITY TO WORK AROUND
THE REGULATIONS IN TIMES OF
EMERGENCY. BUT ONCE YOU PUT IT
IN STATUTE, THEY THE DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY LOSES THAT FLEXIBILITY.
CAN THESE HOMES, WHAT IF THEY
VIOLATE IT NOW? WHAT HAPPENS IF
IT'S NOT A STATUE. RIGHT. SO IF
IT'S VIOLATED SOMEONE FILES A
COMPLAINT, FOR EXAMPLE, IT'S
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING
RESPONSIBILITY TO INVESTIGATE IT
BECAUSE IT IS IN REGULATION. AND
IF A LICENSEE HAS VIOLATED IT,
THEN THEY CAN BE CITED FOR IT.
IT WOULD BE A VIOLATION. IT
WOULD BE A VIOLATION. YEAH. JUST
BECAUSE IT'S NOT IN STATUTE
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S NOT A
VIOLATION. YEP ALL RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA, I DO HAVE
CONCERNS AND QUESTIONS AROUND
THE QUALITY OF LIVING
ENVIRONMENT AS PERTAINS TO
RESTROOMS. BATHROOM, LAVATORIES,
SHOWER FACILITIES. SO CURRENTLY
IN A HOME THAT WOULD HAVE SIX
RESIDENTS NOW HAVING EIGHT. HOW
DO YOU BALANCE THAT? BY NOT
MAKING A AMENDMENT OR A CHANGE
FOR BATHROOM SERVICES. WELL, AS
IT GOES TO THE LICENSING
PROCESS, WE STILL HAVE TO BE
APPROVED AND SO IF IT'S A HOME
WHERE THEY, YOU KNOW, WHERE THEY
ONLY HAVE ONE FULL BATH AND THE
DEPARTMENT CAN SAY, YOU KNOW
WHAT, THIS IS NOT SUITABLE FOR
ANY HOME. MORE THAN SIX
RESIDENTS. SO IT'S STILL THE
HOME IS STILL GOING TO BE
INSPECTED FOR THE QUALITY OF
CARE AND THE QUALITY OF THE
ENVIRONMENT, BASED UPON HOW MANY
RESIDENTS THE RCF WOULD LIKE TO
LIVE THERE. SO THERE'S STILL
THAT CHECK AND BALANCE IN THERE.
IT'S NOT LIKE AS SOON AS SOMEONE
APPLIES TO HAVE EIGHT RESIDENTS,
IT JUST GETS. GRANTED, IT'S
QUITE THE OPPOSITE. THE
LICENSING AUTHORITY WILL HAVE TO
GO IN THERE, INSPECT THE
PREMISES AND SEE WHAT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THE SIZE OF THAT
PREMISES. YOU KNOW, A THREE OR A
FOUR BEDROOM HOME CAN MEAN A LOT
OF DIFFERENT THINGS, DEPENDING
ON HOW MUCH SQUARE FOOTAGE IT
HAS AND DEPENDING ON HOW MANY
FULL BATHROOMS IT HAS AS WELL.
SO THEY COULD ALSO SAY, YOU KNOW
WHAT? WE CAN APPROVE EIGHT IF
YOU MAKE THIS HALF BATH INTO A
FULL BATH. SO NOW YOU HAVE TWO
FULL BATHS. AND SO THEY'RE STILL
GOING TO BE THAT OVERSIGHT IN
TERMS OF THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF THE RESIDENTS. AND IF I CAN
JUST ADD THAT ADD TO THAT TOO,
AS PART OF THE PROCESS, THE
LICENSEE HAS TO SUBMIT A
FACILITY SKETCH, WHICH INCLUDES
THE FLOOR PLAN. SO LICENSING IS
GOING TO REVIEW THE FLOOR PLAN,
WHICH INCLUDES NOT JUST THE, NOT
JUST THE BEDROOMS, BUT ALSO THE
BATHROOM SITUATION TO DETERMINE
THAT THAT'S A SUITABLE SITUATION
. SO CURRENTLY IT'S A SUITABLE
SITUATION. SIX SENIORS AND ONE
WORKING BATHROOM IN A HOME. IS
THAT A SUITABLE SITUATION? I
DON'T I DON'T RECALL OFF THE TOP
OF MY HEAD WHAT IS THE CURRENT,
REGULATION FOR THE BATHROOM
SITUATION. BUT THERE IS A THERE
IS A IT IS PRESCRIBED IN
REGULATION. WHAT THE BATHROOM
SITUATION HAS TO BE. SO IF
LICENSING DETERMINES THAT THE
LICENSEE HAD EIGHT OCCUPANTS
CANNOT SATISFY THE WHAT THE
REGULATIONS SAY FOR BATHROOMS,
THEN LICENSING CAN JUST DENY
THAT OR SAY YOU NEED TO, YOU
KNOW TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CLARA'S
POINT, YOU NEED TO CREATE MORE
BATHROOM SPACE IN THE HOME TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT. JUST A MOMENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA, I WANT TO
GIVE YOUR BILL A FAIR CHANCE.
WHICH MEANS I WANT TO SEE THE
LANGUAGE AROUND THIS BATHROOM. I
KNOW I HAVE REQUESTED IT, SOME
DAYS AGO, BUT IT HAS NOT BEEN
PUT IN FRONT OF ME YET. MY
CONCERN IS THAT, WE'RE LEAVING
THE DISCREPANCY TO CDSS TO MAKE
DECISIONS WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
SUITABLE. AND I'M CONCERNED THAT
THE QUALITY OF THE LIVING
ENVIRONMENT IS IMPORTANT. AND I
DON'T WANT US TO CREATE MORE
BEDS IN A HOME WHERE THERE'S
CLEARLY, NEEDS FOR OTHER
AMENITIES. AND SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE CLEAR
THERE. SO WE'RE GOING TO BE
LOOKING UP RIGHT NOW, THE CODE,
WOULD YOU LIKE US TO, WOULD YOU
LIKE US TO PUT YOUR BILL ON CALL
AND THEN BRING IT BACK UP? WE
CAN FINISH, CLOSING OUT. I'M
HAPPY. WHATEVER YOU'D LIKE TO
DO, MADAM CHAIR. IF YOU'D LIKE
ME TO CLOSE OUT. AND YOU CAN DO
FURTHER INVESTIGATION INTO IT, I
WOULD LIKE TO. IF THERE IS OUR
CONCERNS. CERTAINLY WANT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THEM,
BUT, YOU KNOW, HAPPY TO DO
WHATEVER YOU'D LIKE. OKAY, I
THINK I FOUND IT HERE. THANK YOU
FOR GETTING IT FOR ME. I'M
SORRY. OKAY SO I'M LOOKING RIGHT
HERE. TOILETS AND BATHROOMS
SHALL BE CONVENIENTLY LOCATED.
THE LICENSED CAPACITY SHALL BE
ESTABLISHED BASED ON SECTION 87
158 CAPACITY. THE FOLLOWING AT
LEAST ONE TOILET AND WASH BASIN
FOR EACH SIX PEOPLE. SO IF YOU
ARE ADDING, THEN EIGHT PEOPLE,
DOES THAT MEAN NOW THAT THE
BATHROOM OR THE HOME MUST HAVE
TWO TOILETS AND WASH BASINS?
THAT'S THE WAY I READ IT. THAT'S
THE WAY I INTERPRET WHAT YOU
JUST SAID. OKAY, BECAUSE IT'S
ONE PER SIX. AS SOON AS YOU HIT
SEVEN. TECHNICALLY, IF YOU DID
SEVEN INSTEAD OF EIGHT, IT WOULD
TRIGGER THE SECOND. AND MADAM
CHAIR, IF YOU'D LIKE
CLARIFICATION ON THAT. I'M HAPPY
IF YOU, YOUR STAFF, YOUR
WONDERFUL STAFF WHO DID A GREAT
JOB ON THE ANALYSIS, WOULD LIKE
TO, WORK ON LANGUAGE TO THAT
EFFECT. MORE THAN HAPPY TO
ACCEPT SUBSEQUENT AMENDMENTS TO
YOUR SATISFACTION. I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET TO A
PLACE WHERE YOUR BILL DOES THE
GOOD DEED OF GIVING US MORE,
MORE BEDS, BUT DOESN'T
INADVERTENTLY CAUSE I WOULDN'T
WANT TO HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER
LIVING IN A PLACE WITH ONE
BATHROOM TO EIGHT PEOPLE. I GET
THE ONLY CONCERN I WOULD RAISE
IS SIMILAR TO THE TWO BED THING.
IF IT'S IN STATUTE, THEN ONCE
AGAIN IT WILL LIMIT THE
DEPARTMENT'S FLEXIBILITY IN
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS. I
UNDERSTAND THAT, BUT THIS BILL
IS ASKING US TO CODIFY TWO
ADDITIONAL BEDS WITHOUT ANY
RELATION TO RESTROOMS. AND SO IF
WE ALREADY HAVE LANGUAGE AND LAW
THAT LIMITS ONE WORKING BATHROOM
AND BASIN FOR SIX PEOPLE, THEN
WE'RE OFFSETTING THAT LAW BY NOW
. INTRODUCING EIGHT. SO WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE IN
CONGRUENCE WITH WHAT'S CURRENTLY
WRITTEN. AND THAT'S MY CONCERN.
SO I DON'T THINK THERE SHOULD BE
FLEXIBILITY AROUND RESTROOMS. I
THINK THAT IF WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT QUALITY LIVING SITUATIONS
AND SAFE ENVIRONMENTS,
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THERE'S AN
EMERGENCY OR NOT, NO EMERGENCY
FOR ME WOULD SAY EIGHT PEOPLE TO
ONE RESTROOM, PARTICULARLY OUR
ELDERLY AND THOSE WHO NEED
EXTENSIVE CARE. SO OKAY, SO
THOSE WOULD BE MY CONCERNS, WE
WILL MOVE FORWARD AND TAKE A,
TAKE A VOTE, BUT I'M HOPING THAT
AS, AS YOUR BILL MOVES FORWARD,
WE CAN MAKE THAT VERY CLEAR.
SOUNDS GOOD. I, I AGREE WITH
YOU. I THINK I AGREE WITH YOUR
CONCERNS. LOOK I, I'M THE
PRIMARY CARETAKER FOR MY FATHER,
AND WE HAVE THE ABILITY WHEN I'M
UP HERE ON TUESDAY AND WEDNESDAY
TO HAVE SOMEONE THERE DURING THE
DAY TO CARE FOR HIM. NOT A LOT
OF PEOPLE HAVE THAT LUXURY. AND
SO REALLY, WE'RE LOOKING OUT FOR
THE THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS,
THAT DON'T HAVE THAT ABILITY TO
HAVE THEIR LOVED ONE CARED FOR
IN THE WAY THAT THEY WOULD LIKE.
AND SO I AGREE THAT HAVING A
SUFFICIENT RESTROOM CAPACITY IS
PART OF MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S
A RESPECTFUL, DIGNIFIED PLACE
FOR OUR LOVED ONES TO LIVE.
THANK YOU. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN IPO. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR CLOSING. ALL RIGHT. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THIS BILL? I
WILL BE HAPPY TO MAKE THE MOTION
OKAY. A MOTION BY SENATOR
OKOBOJI, ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. BILL MOVED BY SENATOR
OKOBOJI. BILE ITEM EIGHT, AB
1993. MOTION IS DUE. PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO, GIL A ALVARADO GIL A
OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI. LAKE. SPEER
LIMÓN. MENGIBAR OKAY, WE HAVE
TWO EYES AND WE WILL LEAVE THAT
ON CALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE. OKAY,
LET'S SEE WHERE WE ARE. DO WE
SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS? I
CAN'T SEE HER. OKAY ALL RIGHT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ, WELCOME
. WE'LL MOVE FORWARD WITH ITEM
NUMBER NINE. ASSEMBLY BILL 2075
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER, IF YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES WITH YOU TODAY,
PLEASE ASK THEM TO COME FORWARD.
HAVE THEM SEATED.
GREAT. PLEASE START WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
AND FELLOW SENATORS, THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB 2075, THE RESIDENT ACCESS
PROTECTION ACT. I WANT TO START
BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND THE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL. AND, GOING THROUGH
IT, I THINK I'D LIKE TO TAKE THE
MOMENT JUST TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
THIS BILL REALLY AT THE CORE IS
ABOUT, WHICH IS, WE'VE HAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS BILL,
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE RESIDENTS OF
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES WITH
THE ABILITY TO HAVE IN PERSON,
ON SITE ACCESS TO VISITORS
DURING A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY, AS LONG AS THEY
FOLLOW THE SAME SAFETY PROTOCOLS
AS ARE REQUIRED. STAFF IS
REQUIRED TO FOLLOW. I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT VISITATION IS
ONLY ALLOWED IF THE VISITOR
FOLLOWS THE SAME SAFETY
PROTOCOLS, AS STAFF IS REQUIRED
TO FOLLOW. AB 25 IS A RESULT OF
A WORKING GROUP, WHICH A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO, THE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHED AND ASKED TO REVIEW
PROTOCOLS DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND TO DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS
ON HOW TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
VISITATION AND VISITATION
POLICIES AND PRACTICES FOR LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES DURING
THESE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES,
LIKE THE ONE WE HAD RECENTLY,
WITH COVID, THIS WORKING GROUP
MET FIVE TIMES OVER THE COURSE
OF SIX MONTHS AND INCLUDED
PARTICIPANTS FROM ADVOCATES,
STATE AGENCIES, FACILITIES,
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS AND
MEDICAL GROUPS. THEY PUBLISH A
REPORT IN OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR,
AND THE WORK GROUP WAS CLEAR IN
ITS TAKEAWAY THAT IT IS
ESSENTIAL FOR A FAMILY AND FOR A
FRIEND TO HAVE ACCESS TO
RESIDENTS, THEIR LOVED ONES,
INCLUDING DURING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY. SO AT ITS CORE, AB
2075 RECOGNIZES THE
CONSEQUENTIAL ROLE THAT LOVED
ONES, THOSE OF US WHO HAVE CARED
FOR OUR LOVED ONES, PLAY IN
ENSURING THAT RESIDENTS OF
FACILITIES RECEIVE THE
ATTENTION, THE LOVE AND THE CARE
THAT THEY NEED, WHICH AUGMENTS
THE ROLE OF THE FACILITY STAFF.
WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH OPPOSITION TO FIND SOME
MIDDLE GROUND TO ENSURE THAT WE
BALANCE PUBLIC HEALTH, SAFETY
AND VISITATION RIGHTS. SO TO
THAT END, ON OUR OWN,
UNILATERALLY, WE ADDED
COMPROMISE PROVISIONS THAT SEEK
TO MEET THEM SOMEWHERE IN THE
MIDDLE. THE PROVISIONS INCLUDE
FLEXIBILITY FOR STATE AND LOCAL
AUTHORITIES WHEN HANDLING PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES, BY
AUTHORIZING THEM TO DEFINE HOW
VISITORS CAN DEMONSTRATE
PROFICIENCY IN FOLLOWING ALL
SAFETY PROTOCOLS, CAPPING THE
AMOUNT OF VISITORS THAT CAN
VISIT SIMULTANEOUSLY, AND THE
ABILITY TO INSTITUTE EVEN A
SEVEN DAY LOCKOUT PERIOD WHERE
VISITORS WOULD NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO THEIR LOVED ONES, AND THEN AN
ABILITY TO EXTEND THAT BY EVEN
SEVEN MORE DAYS. BEYOND THAT,
WE'VE ALSO CLARIFIED THAT STAFF
WILL BE PRIORITIZED AS IT
RELATES TO PPE USE AND LOVED
ONES CAN ONLY VISIT IF THEY
FOLLOW THE SAME SAFETY PROTOCOLS
, INCLUDING DONNING OF PPE
THROUGH COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THROUGH THIS PROCESS, WE HAVE
CLARIFIED THAT THE GOVERNOR CAN
SUPERSEDE THIS ACT THROUGH HIS
EMERGENCY POWERS AUTHORITY AND
THAT A PUBLIC HEALTH ORDER THAT
REQUIRES AN EVACUATION NOTICE
WOULD NOT BE SUBJECT TO THIS
BILL. PUT ANOTHER WAY, I HAVE
PROVIDED PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
WITH THE FLEXIBILITY TO
DETERMINE HOW VISITATION RIGHTS
SHOULD BE CONDUCTED AND HAVE
ESTABLISHED A PATHWAY FOR THEM
TO PROHIBIT VISITATION IF THEY
FEEL IT'S WARRANTED. REALLY,
TRULY, MORE THAN ANY BILL I'M
WORKING ON THIS SESSION THAT
I'VE AUTHORED SO FAR. WE'VE
TRIED TO FIND A WAY TO GO ABOVE
AND BEYOND TO FIND THAT MIDDLE
GROUND, AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT IF WE CAN GET THERE. WE
WANT TO OFFER SOLUTIONS THAT
WILL STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY, WE BELIEVE IT'S AS
IMPORTANT FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
LOVED ONES IN THESE FACILITIES
TO HAVE ACCESS TO THEM DURING
THESE EMERGENCIES. AND THAT IS
WHAT THIS BILL IS INTENDING TO
DO. SO I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
WITH THAT. I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
OUR TWO WITNESSES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'LL HEAR FROM EACH OF
YOU FOR TWO MINUTES EACH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS NATALIE
WISEMAN. I'M A FAMILY CAREGIVER
AND CO-FOUNDER OF ESSENTIAL
CAREGIVERS COALITION. THIS
THURSDAY, A STUDY FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SCIENCES AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO WAS
PUBLISHED IN WILEY. HEALTH
ECONOMICS. IT ADDS MORE EVIDENCE
TO THE GROWING BODY OF WORK THAT
SUPPORTS FAMILY CAREGIVER ACCESS
DURING HEALTH EMERGENCIES. THIS
STUDY REVEALED THAT MANDATORY
ACCESS FOR FAMILY CAREGIVERS IN
FACILITIES IN THE PANDEMIC WAS
ASSOCIATED WITH A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION IN LONG TERM CARE
DEATHS. PLEASE KEEP THIS IN MIND
WHEN HEARING SUCH ACCESS BEING
MARKETED AS DANGEROUS AND
UNPREDICTABLE. INDEPENDENT, PEER
REVIEWED STUDIES CONTINUOUSLY
POINT TO THE VERY OPPOSITE. MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE OFFERS
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES FOR WHY IT
WORKED TO HAVE FAMILY CAREGIVERS
INSIDE TO HELP THEIR LOVED ONES
DURING EVEN THE MOST UNCERTAIN
TIMES. IF A STAFF CAREGIVER CAN
ENTER WITH PPE, SO CAN A FAMILY
CAREGIVER. FOR I'VE PROVIDED
CARE FOR MY MOM, CELIA, FOR AS
LONG AS I CAN REMEMBER, SINCE
SHE WAS YOUNG, SHE'S NAVIGATED A
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY AND
COMPLETE QUADRIPLEGIA AND A
COMMUNICATION DISORDER. MY
CAREGIVING CONTINUED WHEN SHE
MOVED INTO A MEMORY CARE HOME IN
RCF. I AUGMENT STAFF CARE DAILY.
I BRING A SPOON OR A STRAW TO
HER LIPS. WITHOUT THAT ONE TYPE
OF SUPPORT, SHE CANNOT EAT OR
DRINK. I ALSO HELP HER TO BATHE,
DRESS, TOILET TRANSFER AND
COMMUNICATE. I KNOW HER
NONVERBAL CUES AND HELP OTHERS
LEARN THEM. PANDEMIC VISITOR
RESTRICTIONS ABRUPTLY STOPPED
ALL THAT SUPPORT THEY FAILED TO
RECOGNIZE FAMILY CAREGIVING AS
URGENT AND ESSENTIAL WORK. MY
MOM RAPIDLY LOST WEIGHT, BECAME
AGITATED, WITHDRAWN, DEPRESSED
AND SOMETIMES UNRESPONSIVE. HER
ALREADY LIMITED COMMUNICATION
SKILLS DWINDLED FURTHER WITH
HIGH STAFF TURNOVER. NO ONE
NOTED THESE CHANGES, NOR THE
BRUISES, RASHES, BAD HYGIENE,
LETHARGY, DEHYDRATION AND
DELIRIUM. INCREASED E.R. VISITS
REVEALED DANGEROUS LEVELS OF
DEHYDRATION, CONTUSIONS, A
BROKEN CLAVICLE, ASPIRATION
PNEUMONIA, AND RECURRENT C DIFF,
ALL IN THE FIRST SEVERAL MONTHS
OF LOCKDOWN THAT WERE SUPPOSED
TO PROTECT HER IN A VULNERABLE
PERSON UNCHECKED DEHYDRATION CAN
BE DEADLY IN A MATTER OF DAYS.
WE NOW WRAP UP YOUR
PRESENTATION. GOSH. OKAY OKAY.
WE KNOW IN A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY THAT STAFF DWINDLES.
THERE ARE WAIVERS THAT ALLOW
THEM TO NOT BE TRAINED TO NOT
HAVE BACKGROUND CHECKS. AND
MEANWHILE, FAMILY CAREGIVERS
HAVE YEARS AND YEARS MYSELF,
CLOSE TO 30 YEARS OF EXPERIENCE.
WE WERE LOCKED OUT AND MY MOM
COULD NOT DRINK. I DO HAVE TO
WRAP IT UP OR ELSE I WON'T BE
ABLE TO HEAR OUR NEXT WITNESS.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL MOVE
FORWARD. I'M SO SORRY. CAN I
JUST SAY IN HOSPITALS, THE
AMERICAN DISABILITIES ACT. THIS
IS THE LAST THING. I'M SORRY.
OKAY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
MOVE FORWARD. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS TONY CHICOTEL. I'M A
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY FOR
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM. WE'RE ONE OF THE
CO-SPONSORS OF THE BILL. FAMILY
CAREGIVERS LIKE NATALIE AND
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS, LONG
TERM CARE RESIDENTS WENT THROUGH
SO MUCH SUFFERING, PREVENTABLE
SUFFERING DURING THE PANDEMIC,
MOSTLY FROM ISOLATION AND
NEGLECT. THEY JUST WANT ONE
THING FOR THEIR EXPERIENCE TO
HAVE MEANT SOMETHING, TO ELICIT
SOME SORT OF CHANGE FOR THE
FUTURE. THEY WANT FAMILY
CAREGIVER SUPPORT TO BE TREATED
AS EVERY BIT AS IMPORTANT AS
FACILITY STAFF. SUPPORT FOR THE
HEALTH AND WELL-BEING OF LONG
TERM CARE RESIDENTS, PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICERS WANT THE LEEWAY
TO MAKE THE SAME EXACT MISTAKES,
AND THE LENIENCY TO HAVE NEVER
LEARNED THE LESSON. THEY WANT TO
BE ABLE TO TELL NATALIE THAT SHE
IS LESS ESSENTIAL FOR THE HEALTH
AND WELFARE OF HER MOM THAN A
STAFF PERSON, A STAFF PERSON WHO
MAY BE BRAND NEW AND NOT
CERTIFIED BECAUSE, OH YEAH,
ANOTHER PANDEMIC POLICY WAS TO
SUSPEND THE CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR NURSES AIDES.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
ENCOURAGES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND A BALANCE
BETWEEN RESIDENT ACCESS AND THE
REALITIES OF A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. THE STUDY THAT
NATALIE REFERENCED, FINDS THAT
ESSENTIAL CAREGIVER LAWS WERE
ASSOCIATED WITH A 15% REDUCTION
IN OVERALL NURSING HOME RESIDENT
DEATHS, AND THE EFFECTS WERE
GREATER IN STATES WHERE ACCESS
WAS MANDATORY AS OPPOSED TO JUST
PERMISSIBLE. INCREDIBLY, THERE
WERE EVEN FEWER RESIDENT COVID
DEATHS IN STATES THAT HAD
CAREGIVER ACCESS. PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS HAVE OFFERED NOTHING IN
THE WAY OF BALANCE. THEY WANT
EVERYTHING BUT HERE'S WHAT THE
NEW STUDY'S AUTHORS CONCLUDED IN
THEIR IN THEIR STUDY, GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS NEED TO CONSIDER THE
TRADE OFFS BETWEEN PROTECTING
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS FROM
INFECTIOUS DISEASE AND
MAINTAINING NECESSARY INFORMAL
CARE FOR NURSING HOME RESIDENTS.
THE USE AND EXPANSION OF
ESSENTIAL CAREGIVER LAWS IS A
SUCCESSFUL MODEL FOR FINDING
THAT BALANCE. AB 2075 IS THE
BALANCE. I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND WE WILL HAVE TIME FOR
QUESTIONS. SO WE'LL BE ABLE TO
COVER WHAT YOU NEED US TO COVER.
OKAY, MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC,
PLEASE COME FORWARD WITH YOUR
NAME, AFFILIATION AND YOUR
SUPPORT POSITION. DANITA
STROMGREN, MEMBER OF AARP
CALIFORNIA. ON BEHALF OF OUR 3.2
MILLION MEMBERS IN SUPPORT,
THANK YOU. LISA COLEMAN,
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI THERE,
JASON SULLIVAN HALPERN WITH THE
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HEATHER HARRISON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSISTED LIVING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. BLANCA
CASTRO, STATE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN IN SUPPORT AND ONE OF
THE CO-SPONSORS. THANK YOU.
AMBER KING WITH LEADINGAGE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
, TONY ANDERSON WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MUCH. ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE COME FORWARD
TO BE HEARD. WE'LL HAVE YOU JOIN
US RIGHT HERE AT THE TABLE.
PLEASE. AND YOU'LL EACH GET TWO
MINUTES TO PRESENT. OKAY. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
BETSY ARMSTRONG WITH THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION.
REGRETFULLY, HERE IN OPPOSITION,
WE ABSOLUTELY ACKNOWLEDGE THE
VALUE AND IMPORTANCE OF FAMILY
AND VISITORS TO RESIDENTS IN
THESE FACILITIES. AND I'D LIKE
TO MAKE SOMETHING EXCEEDINGLY
CLEAR. OUR OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE IS NOT BECAUSE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICIALS WANT TO
PROHIBIT VISITATION DURING
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES, NOR
DO LOCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS WANT
TO MAKE THE DECISION ABOUT
WHETHER TO ALLOW VISITATION
DURING EVERY PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. WE ARE OPPOSED
BECAUSE IN RARE CIRCUMSTANCES,
WHEN THE PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT IS
SO GRAVE TO VULNERABLE RESIDENTS
AND OUR COMMUNITY, IT IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY TO PROHIBIT
VISITATION. AND THE BILL DOES
THIS WITHOUT REGARD TO A HEALTH
OFFICER'S MEDICAL TRAINING,
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTISE AND ON
THE GROUND KNOWLEDGE ABOUT HOW
THE DISEASE IS RAVAGING THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITY. IN FACT, LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE TAKEN
STEPS TO PROTECT RESIDENTS EVEN
BEFORE THE NEXT BIG THREAT HITS
IMPROVING LINES OF
COMMUNICATION, HIRING, INFECTION
PREVENTIONISTS TO WORK WITH
THESE FACILITIES TO KEEP
RESIDENTS HEALTHY AND MINIMIZE
THE SPREAD OF DISEASE. THESE ARE
STEPS THAT SUPPORT ONGOING
VISITATION. HOWEVER, WE MUST BE
MINDFUL THAT FUTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH THREATS COULD ENDANGER
RESIDENTS, FACILITY STAFF AND
OUR COMMUNITIES. THOSE THREATS
COULD BE KNOWN, LIKE EBOLA OR
ANOTHER UNKNOWN NOVEL VIRUS THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH WILL HAVE TO LEARN
AND RESPOND TO. AB 275 ONLY
ALLOWS LOCAL VISITATION
SUSPENSION FOR UP TO 14 DAYS,
BUT THAT MAY NOT BE ENOUGH TIME
TO TRULY UNDERSTAND THE NATURE
OF THE THREAT, NOR ENSURE THAT
APPROPRIATE MEASURES ARE IN
PLACE TO PROTECT RESIDENTS,
WORKERS AND OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
I WANT TO REMIND US ALL THAT THE
VISITATION LIMITS LIMITATIONS
DURING THE PANDEMIC WERE
INITIALLY IMPOSED AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL, AND THOSE RESTRICTIONS
EVOLVED AS OUR KNOWLEDGE OF
COVID 19 EVOLVED. THEY ALSO
RECOGNIZED THAT LOCALITIES COULD
RESTRICT ACCESS WHERE THE SPREAD
OF DISEASE WAS STILL EXPANDING
RAPIDLY. USING VACCINATION AND
TEST POSITIVITY METRICS, AB 2075
ONLY LIMITS LOCAL AUTHORITY, NOT
FEDERAL. NOT STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE IS TAILORED TO THE
THREAT IT CONSIDERS WHO'S MOST
VULNERABLE. THE PPE, HOSPITAL
BEDS AND RESOURCES AVAILABLE,
AND INCLUDING WHETHER THERE'S A
VACCINE OR MEDICATION TO ADDRESS
THE DISEASE. AND THAT EVOLVES AS
THE SCIENCE EVOLVES. THIS BILL
WOULD LEAVE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
WITH LESS TOOLS TO PROTECT LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES. AND OUR
COMMUNITIES AT LARGE. WHEN THE
NEXT PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT COMES.
AND IT'S NOT A MATTER OF IF, IT
IS ONLY A MATTER OF WHEN, IT'S
FOR THOSE REASONS WE MUST OPPOSE
AB 2075 AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M DOCTOR KEN CUTLER
WITH THE HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
HEALTH OFFICERS ARE PHYSICIANS
DEDICATED TO PROTECTING THEIR
COMMUNITIES FROM HARM. HEALTH
OFFICER ORDERS, WHEN NEEDED, ARE
AN EFFECTIVE TOOL USED TOWARDS
THAT END. AND THOSE ORDERS
ALREADY HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONSTRAINTS. THEY NEED TO BE
CONSTITUTIONAL, REASONABLE,
JUSTIFIABLE, NARROWLY TAILORED
TO THEIR OBJECTIVE, AND HAVE DUE
PROCESS STILL, DURING THE
PANDEMIC, WHEN, ISSUING ORDERS
THAT PUT HEALTH OFFICERS IN
HARM'S WAY AS THEY FACED
HARASSMENT AND THREATS. AND
UNFORTUNATELY, I KNOW THIS FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE, AND I CAN
ASSURE YOU, HEALTH OFFICER
ORDERS WERE NEVER USED LIGHTLY.
THERE'S NO SECONDARY GAIN FROM
THEM UNDER THIS AS AND AS YOU
CAN SEE IN THE ANALYSIS, MUCH OF
THE TIME PERIOD WITH VISITOR
RESTRICTIONS OCCURRED UNDER
FEDERAL AND STATE GUIDANCE.
UNDER THIS BILL, FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN STILL CLOSE
FACILITIES TO VISITATION. UNDER
THIS BILL, THE GOVERNOR COULD
STILL CLOSE FACILITIES TO
VISITATION. THE ONLY LEVEL OF
AUTHORITY THE BILL PREVENTS FROM
CLOSING DUE TO LEGITIMATE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY CONCERNS IS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND THE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICER IS THE ONE MOST
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH. MOST KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY, AND MOST
ACCOUNTABLE TO THEIR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND CITY COUNCILS.
THE BILL DOES ALLOW FOR 7 TO 14
DAY CLOSURE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IT ISN'T ENOUGH TIME, ESPECIALLY
SINCE THE BILL WAS EXPANDED TO
ALLOW ON SITE IN-PERSON ACCESS
DURING A DECLARED EMERGENCY TO
ALL VISITORS, NOT JUST
DESIGNATED CLOSE FAMILY OR LOVED
ONES. IT WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
ENOUGH TIME IN MARCH OF 2020,
WHEN WE WERE FACING A NEW
DISEASE THAT WE HAD NO IMMUNITY,
NO VACCINE, VERY LITTLE
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND VERY
FEW TESTS. WE HOPE AND PRAY
NEVER TO SEE ANOTHER MARCH 2020,
BUT WE CAN'T PREDICT THE WHAT
THE FUTURE IS GOING TO BRING.
THIS IS WHY YOUR YOUR THE HEALTH
OFFICIALS OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION? PLEASE COME
FORWARD. YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION VICTORIA RODRIGUEZ
WITH NIELSEN MERKSAMER ON BEHALF
OF CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF
OF THE NAPA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION, AS WELL AS THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO WITH
THE POSITION OF OPPOSE, UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
JERILYN MCGOWAN, WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF SAN MATEO
COUNTY IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. OKAY,
WE'LL BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS? I GUESS I'M THE ONLY
ONE HERE. SO I'M LOOKING RIGHT
AT YOU, SENATOR. WELL, WE'LL
WE'LL DEFINITELY HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS, TO BE ADDRESSED. SO
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE I, I
UNDERSTAND BOTH PERSPECTIVES ON,
ON THE ISSUE. I THINK WE HAD A
PRETTY EXTENSIVE CONVERSATION IN
OUR OFFICE ABOUT THAT. SO, AFTER
OUR MEETING, I SAT DOWN WITH MY
WITH MY, MY, LEGISLATIVE AIDE
THAT WORKS IN THIS IN THIS SPACE
. AND SO WE WERE KIND OF GOING
IN AND CRAFTING SOME, SOME
QUESTIONS TO ASK ON THERE. I
THINK YOU ANSWERED ONE OF THEM
WITH, BECAUSE MY NUMBER ONE
QUESTION IS, WELL, HOW DO WE
COME UP WITH 7 OR 14 DAYS, WAS
THAT JUST KIND OF A, YOU KNOW,
LEGITIMATE SCIENTIFIC, DATE OR
WAS IT JUST A RANDOM DATE, AND
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING IT WAS
JUST A RANDOM DATE THAT WAS
THROWN OUT THERE IN HOPES THAT
THEY WOULD COME BACK WITH
SOMETHING MORE. MORE, DATA
DRIVEN, TIME FRAME. SO 14 DAY
NOT ENOUGH, AS YOU MENTIONED, IS
THERE A TIME FRAME WHICH YOU
WOULD PREFER IN, IN THIS
PARTICULAR WORK THAT YOU SAID
WOULD BE REASONABLE IN THAT
TIME? AND THEN I'LL, I'LL GO TO
MY FURTHER QUESTIONS AFTER THAT.
SURE. THANK YOU. THERE WE GO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION, SO
AS WE EXPLAINED TO THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE, UNDER EXISTING LAW,
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS CAN
DECLARE A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY AND WITHIN SEVEN DAYS,
IT HAS TO BE RATIFIED BY THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OR THEIR
CITY COUNCIL. AND THEN IT COMES
THAT EMERGENCY ORDER COMES UP
UNDER REVIEW FOR IN FRONT OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS EVERY 30
DAYS. AND SO THE BOARD CAN OPT
TO TERMINATE THAT EMERGENCY
AFTER 30 DAYS. IT ALSO GIVES
FOLKS AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO
BEFORE THEIR BOARD AND EXPRESS
CONCERNS ABOUT WHATEVER
RESTRICTIONS MAY BE IN PLACE
DURING THAT EMERGENCY. SO THAT'S
WHERE WE THOUGHT THERE'S ALREADY
STATUTE THAT SUPPORTS A TIME
FRAME FROM THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PERSPECTIVE. OKAY AND WITHIN
THOSE 7 OR 30 DAYS, SAY THERE'S
IT'S A GREAT EMERGENCY. THE
GOVERNOR CAN COME IN AND
ACTUALLY DECLARE SOMETHING
WITHIN THOSE 7 TO 30 DAYS.
CORRECT? OKAY OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
MAY I RESPOND, SENATOR? YES,
YES. SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THROUGH THE CHAIR. OH,
SORRY. IT'S THE CHAIR. KEEP
DECORUM. KEEP DECORUM, MAY I
PLEASE. THANK YOU. I JUST WANT
TO MAKE IT CLEAR THE DAYS THAT
WERE OFFERED WERE AMENDMENTS
THAT I BROUGHT FORWARD. THIS WAS
NOT ANYTHING THAT WAS OFFERED BY
THE OPPOSITION. I HEARD THEM IN
THEIR CONCERNS. AND I THINK
THEY'RE VALID, THAT YOU JUST
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE NEXT ONE
WILL BRING. AND IN RESPONSE TO
THAT, IN TRYING TO, BE, SOLVING
PROBLEMS INSTEAD OF CREATING
MORE PROBLEMS FOR ALL OF YOU IN
COMMITTEES AND FOR US, I SAID,
WELL, LET'S WAIT SOME PERIOD OF
TIME, SEVEN DAYS. AND YES, I, I
CAME UP WITH THOSE DAYS BECAUSE
I THOUGHT THAT WAS THAT WOULD
GIVE US SOME TIME. AND THEN WE
SAID NOT ONLY SEVEN DAYS, YOU
CAN ACTUALLY GET AN ADDITIONAL
EXTENSION OF SEVEN MORE DAYS
JUST BY YOUR OWN ORDER. IF YOU
WISH TO DO THAT. THE OTHER PART
THAT YOU ASKED ABOUT WAS ALSO,
IN ADDITION, THAT I MADE NOT AT
THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
OPPOSITION, BUT THAT WAS REALLY
THROUGH THE WORK THROUGH YOUR
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH,
WHICH WAS, ENSURING THAT THE
GOVERNOR COULD DECLARE AT ANY
POINT THAT THIS EMERGENCY, THIS
SITUATION RAISED TO A CERTAIN
LEVEL, THAT IT REALLY IS THAT
SIGNIFICANT, THAT IT WOULD
ELIMINATE THE ACCESS AS WE SEEK
TO ACCOMPLISH THROUGH THIS BILL.
SO THOSE WERE TWO THINGS THAT WE
THOUGHT WERE REASONABLE, THAT WE
THOUGHT MADE SENSE. AND THAT'S
WHY WE INTRODUCED THOSE INTO
THIS LEGISLATION AND MADE THOSE
AMENDMENTS OKAY. AND MAY I
FOLLOW PLEASE PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, OKAY. SO
THE NEXT QUESTION THAT I HAVE IS
DURING THE PANDEMIC, WE
EXPERIENCED A SHORTAGE OF
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT,
AND AS A RESULT, PPE COSTS
INCREASINGLY INCREASED RAPIDLY.
OUR STATE HAD TO PRIORITIZE PPE
UNTIL WE HAD ENOUGH SUPPLY
ACROSS OUR STATE, WHICH TOOK
WEEKS, IF NOT MONTHS. UNDER THIS
BILL, WHAT HAPPENS WITH
VISITATION IF PPE IS NOT READILY
AVAILABLE? DO WE HAVE THE WAY
THE LEGISLATION IS WRITTEN IS
THAT ALL PROTOCOLS MUST BE
FOLLOWED BY THE VISITORS, JUST
AS AS REQUIRED FOR STAFF. SO
STAFF IS REQUIRED TO HAVE OR DON
SPECIFIC TYPE OF EQUIPMENT.
VISITORS MUST DO THE SAME IF
THAT'S NOT AVAILABLE TO THEM,
THEN, I WOULD, I WOULD SAY THAT
THEN THE VISITORS, THE
VISITATION CANNOT OCCUR BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE PROPER AS
REQUIRED PROTECTION AS IS
REQUIRED FOR OTHERS WHO ARE ON
SITE. OKAY NOW GOING BACK TO MY
VERY FIRST QUESTION WITH REGARDS
TO THE GOVERNOR BEING ABLE TO
COME IN AND DECLARE AN EMERGENCY
, WHAT WOULD BE SOME EXAMPLES IN
WHICH THE GOVERNOR, I GUESS HE
COULD STILL COME IN AND DECLARE
A STATE OF EMERGENCY IF IT WAS
JUST A REGIONAL, EVENT, I'M
ASSUMING. IS THAT CORRECT?
THAT'S CORRECT. HE HAS AUTHORITY
TO DO THAT FOR JUST A REGIONAL
ONE. IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE,
SINGULAR COUNTY, A SINGULAR
CITY. OKAY, BECAUSE THE NEXT
THING IS, I WAS GOING TO ASK IF
YOU COULD GIVE SOME EXAMPLES OF
WHAT. WHAT ARE SOME, REGIONAL OR
LOCAL, HEALTH EMERGENCIES THAT
WOULD NOT TAKE IT TO THE LEVEL
OF, OF THE STATE. HOWEVER IF
NEED BE, THE COUNTY COULD ALWAYS
ASK THE GOVERNOR TO COME IN AND
DECLARE THE, THE, THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY IN THAT REGION. YES, I
AGREE, I THINK IF WE HAD THE
RIGHT GOVERNOR AT THE RIGHT TIME
WITH THE RIGHT PROBLEM, THAT
COULD WELL WORK. BUT I THINK WE
ARE BETTER PROTECTED WHEN WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO RESPOND BOTH
LOCALLY AND WITH THE GOVERNOR.
EMERGENCIES ARE CONSIDERED TO BE
LOCAL AT THE BEGINNING AND AT
THE END, AND THEY EVOLVE OVER
TIME. AND, CALIFORNIA IS A
LARGE, DIVERSE STATE. SO YOU CAN
HAVE THE SAME EPIDEMIC AND VERY
DISPARATE IMPACTS IN DIFFERENT
AREAS. AND SO A LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIAL MAY FEEL THE NEED WHEN
THE GOVERNOR DOESN'T SEE IT,
BECAUSE THE LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIAL KNOWS THE FACILITIES,
THE IMPACT ON THEIR HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES, THEIR WORKFORCE,
THEIR CAPABILITIES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. SO THAT'S ALL OKAY.
WHICH BRINGS ME TO MADAM CHAIR.
MY LAST QUESTION BRINGS ME TO MY
LAST QUESTION. SO IN READING THE
CONCERNS OF THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL, IT WAS NOTED THAT THE RATE
OF MALNUTRITION IN NURSING HOMES
ROSE FROM FIVE TO NEARLY 25%
BETWEEN 2020 AND 2022. ONE
REPORT FROM THE ASSOCIATED PRESS
ESTIMATED THAT THERE WERE AT
LEAST 40,000 EXCESS NURSING HOME
DEATHS NOT ATTRIBUTABLE TO COVID
19, IN JUST THE FIRST EIGHT
MONTHS OF THE LOCKOUT. SO
CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT YOU
HAVE 7 TO 14 DAYS WITH AN
EXTENSION OF UP TO 14 DAYS, NØ
NOTING THAT THE GOVERNOR CAN
COME IN AND EXPRESS A STATE OF
EMERGENCY IF NEED BE ONCE THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY HAS, DONE THAT,
THE NEXT PLAN OF QUESTION WOULD
BE WHAT SAFEGUARDS CAN WE PUT IN
PLACE TO ENSURE THAT ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT OF NURSING HOMES IF
THE GOVERNOR OR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SUSPENDS VISITATION
RIGHTS? CAN BE PUT IN PLACE SO
THAT WE DO NOT WITNESS THE SAME
ABUSES AND NEGLECT, THAT WE
EXPERIENCED DURING THE PANDEMIC.
SENATOR, IF THAT QUESTION IS FOR
ME, I WOULD SAY THAT GOES BEYOND
THE SCOPE OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS WITH THE BILL TODAY.
THIS IS ONLY DURING, DURING
EMERGENCIES THAT GET CALLED
WHERE CURRENTLY, PERHAPS LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICIAL MIGHT SAY YOU'RE
NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE VISITATION.
WHAT WE ARE SAYING WITH THIS
LEGISLATION IS THAT YOU WOULD BE
ALLOWED TO HAVE VISITATION WITH
THE SEVEN DAYS AND SEVEN DAYS OR
GOVERNOR SAYING, ABSOLUTELY, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS STILL AN
EMERGENCY. BUT IN TERMS OF
BEYOND THAT SITUATION, LIKE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, AS WAS
STATED CORRECTLY AND, IN THE
TESTIMONY, IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DECIDES THAT THIS
CASE MERITS LOCKDOWNS AS WE HAD
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND ORDERS
THAT WERE BEYOND JUST NOT EVEN
VISITATION, WE HAD ORDERS. IF
YOU ALL REMEMBER, WE COULDN'T
EVEN, I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M
FORGETTING THE NAME, BUT WE WERE
LOCKED IN WHERE WE COULDN'T
LEAVE OUR HOMES FOR SOME TIME
WITH THOSE ORDERS. SO THIS BILL
DOES NOT ADDRESS IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MAKES A DECISION ON
THIS, THEY THEY WOULD TRUMP OUR,
OUR, OUR BILL THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE YOU TODAY. OKAY SO NOT
JUST THE FEDERAL BUT ALSO THE
GOVERNOR. THE GOVERNOR COULD
COME IN AND SAY, YOU KNOW, THIS
IS A STATE OF EMERGENCY,
VISITATION RIGHTS ARE ARE NOT,
NOT GRANTED. NOT EXACTLY. SO. IF
THAT WERE THE CASE, THERE WERE
NO CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN YOU AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OR, ANY
PUBLIC HEALTH ENTITY TO SAY,
WELL, WHAT COULD WE ENSURE THAT
WE DO? WE ENSURE THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING IN PLACE SO IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN. DOES THAT ARE YOU ASKING
LIKE THAT? THERE IS SOME
VISITATION IN THOSE CASES OR.
WELL, NOT NECESSARILY VISITATION
, PERHAPS BY A FAMILY MEMBER,
BUT PERHAPS BY A THIRD ENTITY
THAT CAN COME IN TO CHECK TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS, NO
NEGLECT, THAT THERE IS NO ABUSE
WITHIN THOSE LOCKDOWNS. THAT'S
THE BIGGEST CONCERN THAT I HAVE
RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND
YOUR POINT OF VIEW, THAT YOU
THINK THAT THIS IS NOT,
REASONABLE. BUT, BUT THE OTHER
POINT IS THE FACT THAT WE DID
SEE THAT THERE WAS NEGLECT AND
ABUSE, AND THIS IS WHAT THE BILL
IS TRYING TO, ADDRESS. SO IF
THERE IS AN EMERGENCY BY, YOU
KNOW, STATED BY THE GOVERNOR,
THEN WHAT DO WE PUT IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE OVERSIGHT
OVER FACILITIES SO THAT WE DON'T
SEE WHAT HAS HAPPENED? SO I'M
NOT SURE. SO AGAIN, IN AN
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
FROM THE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
WHO BY THE WAY, I THINK I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE, YOU KNOW, THE
WORK AND RESPECT THE WORK THAT
THEY DO, BUT IN AN ATTEMPT TO
GET TO A PLACE OF HOPEFULLY
GETTING SUPPORT AND MOVING
FORWARD, WE ADDED THE, AUTHORITY
AND POWER OF THE GOVERNOR TO
COME IN AND DECLARE THAT
EMERGENCY AND NOT ALLOW THE
VISITATION TO TRY AND MAKE
PEOPLE FEEL A LITTLE BIT MORE
SURE THAT IF A LOCAL EMERGENCY
RAISED TO THAT LEVEL OF
SIGNIFICANCE, THERE WOULD BE A
BACKSTOP, AND IT WOULDN'T JUST
BE AN OPEN DOOR POLICY. THAT WAS
OUR ATTEMPT TO TRY TO CONTAIN
ANY POTENTIAL CONCERNS THAT WERE
HAD BY THEM. BUT TO YOUR
QUESTION, I DON'T KNOW IF MR.
TRICATEL, WHO WAS ON THE WORKING
GROUP THAT SPENT MONTHS HAVING
THESE CONVERSATIONS, WHETHER
THERE WAS ANY CONVERSATION ABOUT
THAT SPECIFIC ISSUE, HE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS IT. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO ADDRESS A QUESTION TO
HIM OR MADAM CHAIR, I WOULDN'T
MIND ALSO HEARING FROM A COUPLE
MORE MINUTES THE COUNTY. YEAH.
AND THEN WE'LL GO FROM THERE.
YEAH. THANK YOU, SO YOU'RE
GETTING TO THE HEART OF THE
BILL. NOT ONLY DID WE DEPRIVE
RESIDENTS OF THESE CAREGIVERS,
WE ALSO DEPRIVED THEM OF THEIR
VOICE TO SOME EXTENT, BECAUSE
FAMILY CAREGIVERS SERVE THIS
ROLE OF CHECKING THE QUALITY OF
THE CARE THAT'S BEING PROVIDED
AND MAKING COMPLAINTS TO THE
REGULATORY AUTHORITIES, MAKING
COMPLAINTS TO THE OMBUDSMAN
OFFICE, THIS BILL DOESN'T HAVE
THOSE GUARDRAILS THAT YOU SEEK.
I MEAN, WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT FAMILY CAREGIVERS HAVE
ACCESS DURING ANY PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY, IN PART TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE QUALITY OF CARE DOESN'T
SLIP TO THESE LEVELS THAT WE SAW
IN 2020. BUT WITH 14 DAY LOCK
OUTS AND A GOVERNOR OVERRIDE,
THERE'S NO WAY TO ASSURE THAT
THESE ARE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO TO STRIKE THIS BALANCE
BETWEEN SAFETY IN TERMS OF
INFECTION CONTROL VERSUS SAFETY
ON THE QUALITY OF CARE AND THE
QUANTITY OF CARE. TO A LARGE
EXTENT, I'M SURE I'M NOT SURE IF
YOU, DID YOU SAID YOU WANT TO
HEAR FROM THE COUNTY IF THEY
HAVE A DO YOU FOLKS HAVE AN IDEA
OF WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE SO
THAT WE DON'T COMMIT THIS? I
HAVE A COMMENT ON THAT. AND WE
SINCERELY SUPPORT VISITATION AND
NEVER WANT TO SEE IT CURTAILED
AGAIN. IT'S NOT OUR FIRST
CHOICE. IT'S NOT OUR SECOND
CHOICE. IT'S A LAST RESORT. AND
I AGREE WITH YOU THAT THERE ARE
STEPS THAT CAN BE TAKEN TO MORE
ASSURE THAT VISITATION, EVEN IN
AN EMERGENCY, COULD CONTINUE IN
A SUSTAINED WAY. AND SO WE HAVE
DEPLOYED INFECTION CONTROL
PREVENTIONISTS OUT TO FACILITIES
SO THAT PEOPLE CAN BE TRAINED
FASTER, THAT THEY CAN LOOK AT
THE VENTILATION THERE, THE BED
SITUATION, DO WORKFORCE TRAINING
. THERE ARE A NUMBER OF STEPS
YOU CAN TAKE SHORT OF REMOVING
THE AUTHORITY, WHERE YOU CAN
SUPPORT VISITATION, SO THAT
SHOULD IT EVER BE CURTAILED, IT
WOULD BE A LAST RESORT AND
HOPEFULLY FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME. SO THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
YOU'RE WELCOME. I MY QUESTIONS
MIGHT CAUSE SOME OTHER
QUESTIONS. SO WE'LL WE'LL MOVE
THROUGH THIS. SO I I'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THIS BILL AND I'M,
I'M WRESTLING WITH IT AND I'M
GLAD YOU THERE'S PLENTY OF
WITNESSES HERE TO TALK TO TALK
TO US ABOUT THIS, COVID WE
LEARNED SO MUCH IN COVID AND IN
WAYS THAT, YOU KNOW, WE WERE
FORCED TO. RIGHT. AND BECAUSE IT
WENT ON FOR SO LONG, WE SAW THE
LONG TERM IMPACTS OF DECISIONS
THAT WERE BEING MADE. BUT
ULTIMATELY, WHETHER IT WAS ABOUT
SAVING LIVES OR BUILDING
PROTOCOLS, I DID RELY ON MY
LOCAL HEALTH PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER FOR THAT INFORMATION.
AND AT THAT TIME, I WAS IN
SCHOOLS WORKING IN EDUCATION. SO
REALLY LOOKING AT THE HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF CHILDREN EVERY DAY
AND OUR TEACHERS AND OUR STAFF,
AND I UNDERSTOOD THAT THE, THE,
THE DURING THE PANDEMIC, THERE
WERE AREAS OF CALIFORNIA THAT
WERE MORE IMPACTED THAN OTHERS.
AND SO, THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
WERE WORKING, NOT ONLY WITH THE
STATE AND WITH OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES, BUT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, TO PROVIDE UP TO
DATE, COMMUNICATIONS PROTOCOLS,
PROCESSES, FOR ANYONE WHO WAS
LOOKING FOR THEM AND TO GIVE US
DIRECTION. NOW, ONE OF THE
GREATEST AREAS OF FAULT THAT I
THINK I STILL HOLD ON TO IS
THOSE WHO WERE, IN THOSE THEIR
ELDERLY AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THAT WERE IN, IN
RESIDENTIAL CARE THAT WE JUST
DID NOT HAVE A RESPONSE. WE DID
NOT KNOW HOW TO ENSURE THAT THAT
SOCIAL CONNECTION, THAT
CONNECTION TO THE OUTER WORLD,
THAT THAT WAS MAINTAINED, MY, MY
GRANDSON WAS ACTUALLY BORN
DURING THE PANDEMIC, AND WE WERE
RESTRICTED FROM BEING IN THE
HOSPITAL. AND BEING PART OF A
MOMENT IN, IN MY GRANDSON'S LIFE
THAT WILL NEVER BE REPEATED.
LIKE RIGHT. BUT I UNDERSTOOD
THAT THAT WAS NOT ONLY FOR HIS
HEALTH AND WELFARE, BUT IT WAS
ALSO FOR THE OTHER PATIENTS THAT
WERE IN, IN, THAT WERE IN THE
PROXIMITY. AND IT WAS DIFFICULT.
IT WAS HEART WRENCHING TO NOT BE
ABLE TO HAVE THAT CLOSENESS, BUT
HE WAS AN INFANT AND HE DID NOT
RECOGNIZE WHETHER OR NOT I WAS
THERE OR NOT. THE OTHER SPECTRUM
IS WITH OUR SENIORS AND WITH OUR
ELDERS. THEY DO RECOGNIZE THAT.
AND, THERE IS A TIME WHERE, YOU
KNOW, YOU REACH A MATURE LEVEL
OF AGE AND YOU LOOK AT WHETHER
OR NOT YOUR QUALITY OF LIFE
INCLUDES PEOPLE THAT LOVE YOU,
SUPPORT YOU, AND FILL YOU UP.
RIGHT, AND SO I AM REALLY
STRUGGLING WITH ANY TYPE OF
RESTRICTION. THAT PROHIBITS THAT
LEVEL OF INTERACTION, SO MY
QUESTION IS, IS THIS, SO ONE WHO
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR LICENSING
THE FACILITIES AND, AND,
MAINTAINING OVERSIGHT. IS THAT
LOCAL OR STATE THAT'S AT THE
STATE LEVEL? SENATOR. STATE
LEVEL. OKAY, AFTER THE
FACILITIES ARE LICENSED, IF
THERE WAS A COMPLAINT OR A
CONCERN, DOES THAT GO TO THE
STATE? DOES THAT GO TO THE LOCAL
STATE EVERY TIME THE STATE?
OKAY. ALL RIGHT, SO, YOU KNOW, I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'D
LIKE TO BUILD IN POLICY IS I'D
LIKE THAT CONNECTION BETWEEN
THOSE WHO ARE DOING THE
OVERSIGHT AND, AND, ENSURING THE
QUALITY OF OUR FACILITIES ARE
ALSO DOING THE REGULATION
BECAUSE IT KIND OF GOES HAND IN
HAND. SO MY QUESTION REALLY TO,
TO THE COUNTIES IS HOW DO YOU
SEE YOUR ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO
DO THE BEST JOB THAT YOU CAN DO
AS LOCAL PUBLIC OFFICERS, PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICERS, IN THE EVENT
THAT THIS BILL WERE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND THERE ARE SOME
RESTRICTIONS BEING DONE AT THE
STATE. I MEAN, THIS IS A HEAVY
HANDED APPROACH TO LOCAL
REGULATION. SO HOW CAN HOW WOULD
YOU BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO DO
YOUR GREAT WORK OR NOT? WE WOULD
DO THE BEST WE COULD WITH THE
SITUATION. WE HOPE THAT WE WOULD
STILL HAVE THE AUTHORITY IN THE
IN A SITUATION THAT WE CAN'T
PREDICT WHO'S GOING TO BE MOST
VULNERABLE, WHAT TYPE OF
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT IS GOING TO
BE NEEDED, WHAT TYPE OF TRAINING
IS GOING TO BE NEEDED, YOU COULD
MOVE TO, AN INFECTIOUS DISEASE
THAT HAS A MORTALITY RATE MUCH,
MUCH HIGHER THAN COVID. YOU
KNOW, WHERE A BREACH IN PROTOCOL
CAN MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE. AND
IT TAKES A TEAM APPROACH TO PUT
IT ON, TAKE IT OFF, MONITOR,
ETC. SO, WE WOULD, DO OUR BEST
TO GET THAT EDUCATION OUT THERE,
TO GET THE TRAINING TO THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED IT, TO GET
SUPPLIES OF EQUIPMENT. WE'VE
LEARNED A LOT FROM COVID, WE
HAVE MUCH BETTER LINES OF
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES AND OUR LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES. AND
COMMUNICATION MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE. WHEN, I WAS A COUNTY
HEALTH OFFICER AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC, MY HEALTH
DIRECTOR CAME TO ME AT THE VERY
BEGINNING AND SAID, WHAT DO YOU
NEED FIRST? AND I SAID, WE NEED
SOMEBODY TO HELP PROTECT OUR
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES. AND
WE HIRED A FORMER HEALTH OFFICER
WHO HAD BEEN RETIRED, WHO CAME
IN AND BECAME THAT LIAISON AND
WORKED WITH THEM CLOSELY. AND
THIS IS BEFORE VACCINE. THIS IS
BEFORE WE KNEW IT WAS
AEROSOLIZED, ETC. AND WE HAD ONE
OF THE LATEST ENTRIES OF COVID
INTO OUR FACILITIES BECAUSE WE
HAD THOSE COMMUNICATIONS. SO I
THINK WE WOULD LEVERAGE WHATEVER
TOOLS WE HAD AVAILABLE, BUT WE
WOULD MISS, THE HAVING THE TOOL
TO, TAKE MEASURES AS MAY BE
NECESSARY TO PROTECT HEALTH AND
SAFETY. REMOVING THIS TOOL, I
THINK, WOULD POTENTIALLY HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. YEAH.
OKAY. THANKS. I THINK YOU WERE
GOING TO OFFER US A PERSPECTIVE
FROM, SOMEONE WHO HAS LIVED
EXPERIENCE, AND I WANTED TO GIVE
YOU THAT OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE A GREAT
WAY FOR US TO CLOSE. DO YOU MIND
DOING THAT? THANK YOU. I'LL
SUMMARIZE MY WHAT I WANTED TO
SAY. SO I WAS INSIDE EARLY ON,
FIRST IN HOSPITALS BECAUSE OF
THE ADA. THIS WAS ALL BEFORE
VACCINES, VERY EARLY IN THE
PANDEMIC. AND THEY HAD TO LET ME
IN BECAUSE MY MOM NEEDED TOO
MUCH SUPPORT FOR THEM TO HANDLE,
SO THEY TAUGHT ME HOW TO PUT ON
AND OFF, PPE AND HELP ME WITH
THE TEAM. PART OF THAT, AND THEN
I WAS ABLE TO GET INTO THE LONG
TERM CARE FACILITY ONLY BECAUSE
THEY SAW THEY NEEDED THE HELP AS
WELL. AND, IN SPADES. THEY GOT
BACK TIME FOR THEIR STAFF, FOR
OTHER RESIDENTS. AND SO OTHER
RESIDENTS DID BETTER BECAUSE
THEY HAD MORE SUPPORT WHILE I
WAS THERE. THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO
USE AS MUCH PPE BECAUSE I DIDN'T
HAVE TO TAKE IT OFF AND ON WHILE
I WAS IN ONE ROOM WITH ONE
RESIDENT. AND I SEE US AS A
POTENTIAL TOOL IN PUBLIC HEALTH.
I THINK FAMILY CAREGIVERS ARE
CAPABLE AND READY AND WILLING TO
TAKE THE RISK AND THE
PRECAUTIONS TO FOLLOW THE SAME
PROTOCOLS AS STAFF AND HONESTLY,
MANY OF US HAVE SO MANY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE THAT IT'S, UNUSUAL TO
SEE A BRAND NEW STAFF MEMBER
GOING IN WITHOUT BECAUSE OF THE
WAIVERS, WITHOUT TRAINING OR
BACKGROUND CHECKS OR REALLY MUCH
OF ANYTHING. AND THEN THE FAMILY
CAREGIVER WHO HAS MANY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE AND CAN ASSIST IN, IN
GREAT WAYS AND SUBTLE WAYS, OUT
OF THE WAY THAT THEY CAN'T GO IN
. WE CAN FOLLOW THE SAME
PROTOCOLS AND WE DO SAVE, AND WE
END UP SAVING TIME AND MONEY FOR
OTHER RESIDENTS AND FOR THE
FACILITY OR WHOMEVER IS
PROVIDING THE PPE. SO AT THE END
OF THE DAY, THAT'S HOW WE WE'D
LIKE TO BE SEEN AS THAT SORT OF
CORE THAT YOU CAN TAP BECAUSE
WE'RE WE'RE INCENTIVIZED FOR,
FOR GOOD PUBLIC HEALTH OUTCOMES
TO WE WANT OUR LOVED ONES TO
THRIVE AND SURVIVE. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S ALL MY QUESTIONS. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS, SENATOR? ONE
ONE LAST QUESTION. I'M NOT SURE
IF I IF YOU MAY INDULGE ME JUST
A TAD. SO ONE LAST QUESTION ON,
WOULD YOUR BILL, FOR THE RECORD,
FOR THE PUBLIC, FOR, FOR THE
COUNTY, WOULD IT LIMIT TO,
FAMILY CAREGIVERS SUCH AS YOUR
WITNESS IN SUPPORT, OR IS IT
OPEN TO ANY VISITATION TO ANYONE
, THE CAPACITY IN WHICH THEY
WILL BE COMING IN? WOULD THERE
BE A PURPOSE OTHER THAN OR
MULTIPLE, OR IS IT JUST ONE
PERSON, ONE CAREGIVER, AT A
TIME. SO IT COULD BE LIMITED TO
ONE CAREGIVER. THAT IS THAT IS
THE CASE, WE HAVE GONE BACK AND
FORTH ON DESIGNATING VERSUS NON
DESIGNATING. I'M GOING TO ASK
MR. IF HE CAN REMIND ME OUR
LATEST VERSION OF THE BILL WHEN
IT COMES TO THE VISITATION
REQUIREMENTS. SURE. AT THIS TIME
THE BILL DOESN'T REFER TO
DESIGNATED SUPPORT PERSONS, BUT
THAT IS THE RECOMMENDATION OF
KANEM THAT MY ORGANIZATION TO GO
THAT ROUTE. SO WE DON'T HAVE
THAT. IT'S NOT IN HERE. YEAH.
YEAH AND I IF I RECALL
CORRECTLY, YOU DON'T YOU DON'T
SEE, FACILITIES LISTED AS
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. AND
THAT WAS PRECISELY ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY HAD CONCERNS
WITH HAVING TO GO THROUGH A
PROCESS OF LIKE, IDENTIFYING AND
KEEPING TABS AND RECORDS OF WHO
SIGNED UP TO BE THE OFFICIAL
PERSON, IN ORDER TO FACILITATE
THAT. BECAUSE IN AGAIN, IN
REFLECTION, IN THE TIME OF, OF
SUCH A SCENARIO CRISIS, I'LL
CALL IT EVEN, THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE BURDENED WITH THE TASK OF
HAVING TO FIGURE ALL THAT OUT
AND ALSO ALLOWING FOLKS TO COME
IN AND VISIT. SO IN EXCHANGE OF,
AGAIN, TRYING TO COME TO A POINT
WHERE I HAD SUPPORT FROM
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS, WE SAID,
OKAY, LET'S NOT PUT THE BURDEN
ON THE FACILITIES, THE LONG-TERM
CARE FACILITIES, TO HAVE THIS,
THIS, KEEPING OF TABS, AND
THAT'S HOW WE GOT TO WHERE WE
ARE TODAY. BUT THE BUT THE, THE
DESIGNATED PERSON COULD BE
ACTUALLY, BE DESIGNATED PRIOR
TO, OR WHEN AT THE POINT WHEN
THIS, THE SENIORS ACTUALLY HAVE
ENTERED INTO THE, THE FACILITY.
RIGHT? YEAH. CORRECT. OKAY YEAH.
GOOD SO I, I STILL STRUGGLING
WITH THIS ONE, I THINK PART OF
IT IS BECAUSE YOU KNOW, WE'VE
HAD THE BILL FOR A LITTLE OVER A
WEEK, AND, YOU KNOW, I TEND TO
BE VERY PROACTIVE TO PUT
FORWARD, QUESTIONS AND
AMENDMENTS, AND I DON'T THINK WE
WERE ABLE TO GET THAT DONE IN
THE TIME FRAME, NÓ KNOWING THAT
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE DOUBLE
REFERRED, IT SOUNDS LIKE, YOU
KNOW, IT'S GOING TO BE DIFFICULT
FOR US TO MAKE SOME OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS TO, FOR CLARITY, IN
TERMS OF WHERE THE BILL IS. SO
I'M, I'M WRESTLING WITH THIS ONE
RIGHT NOW, I THINK WHAT WE DID,
WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL HAVE YOU
CLOSE, WE'LL CONTINUE MOVING
FORWARD. I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
BE HERE FOR A FEW MORE HOURS, SO
STAY TUNED, FOLKS, SO I WILL, GO
AHEAD AND CLOSE. YEAH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I APPRECIATE BOTH OF
YOU, BOTH OF THE MEMBERS AND THE
SENATE WHO ARE HERE AT THIS
COMMITTEE ASKING QUESTIONS. I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S A GOOD, WAY
OF TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH. AND
AS I STATED IN THE BEGINNING,
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
IS TO FIND A BALANCE BETWEEN
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE GOOD
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC, BUT ALSO GOOD HEALTH FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN CARE. AND IF
YOU KNOW ANYONE WHO'S EVER
CARED, HAD I SAY IT THIS WAY
BECAUSE IT WAS AN HONOR FOR ME
TO CARE FOR MY FATHER, AT THE
END OF HIS LIFE. IF YOU KNOW
ANYONE WHO'S EVER CARED FOR
SOMEONE, IT'S REALLY AN HONOR TO
DO THAT. AND TO BE FIND YOURSELF
IN THE CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE YOU
CANNOT OFFER THAT LOVE AND THAT
CARE, PARTICULARLY AT THAT TIME
IN THEIR LIVES, WHICH IS AS
IMPORTANT AS ANY OTHER TIME IN
THEIR LIFE, IS REALLY, REALLY A
DIFFICULT THING TO PROHIBIT THAT
FROM, FROM OUR CITIZENS IN
CALIFORNIA, THIS WAS I THINK, AS
THOUGHTFUL AS YOU CAN GET, THERE
WAS AN ATTEMPT TO DO THIS LAW
THIS WAY A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
I THINK THE LEGISLATURE, RIGHT,
RIGHTFULLY SO, SAID GO AND STUDY
IT, CREATED A WORK GROUP. THEY
MET FOR MONTHS. IT INCLUDED ALL
STAKEHOLDERS, THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS. I WOULD SAY GO
BEYOND EVEN THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT I HAVE IN THIS BILL, TO THE
EXTENT THAT I THINK SOME OF THEM
WHO WERE PARTICIPATING IN THAT
AND WHO REALLY WERE IN EARNEST
TRYING TO FIND, THE RIGHT
PATHWAY FORWARD, I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THEM FOR STILL BEING
OKAY WITH MOVING FORWARD WITH
THIS, EVEN THOUGH IT IS MORE
LIMITING THAN WHAT I THE EXPERTS
WHO WERE PUT TOGETHER AS A AS
REQUIRED BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
GIVE US RECOMMENDATIONS, DID
THAT. WE TOOK THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS. WE'VE WORKED
THEM THROUGH. WE'VE NARROWED IT
TO MAKE SURE WE MAINTAIN THAT
BALANCE THAT I THINK WE'RE ALL
STRIVING FOR, CERTAINLY THERE
WILL BE RARE CIRCUMSTANCES. I
DON'T THINK YOU CAN LEGISLATE
YOUR WAY THROUGH EVERY RARE
CIRCUMSTANCE. SO WE'RE TRYING TO
REALLY HARD FIND A WAY FORWARD
SO THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO
CARE FOR THEIR LOVED ONES HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO TO
AUGMENT OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKLOAD. THAT OFTENTIMES,
UNFORTUNATELY, FALLS ON THE
SHOULDERS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
WORKING REALLY HARD AND REALLY
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES AS THEY
ARE IN FACILITIES LIKE THAT. SO
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT,
THAT YOU SUPPORT ALL EVERYONE
WHO HAS EVER HAD A LOVED ONE WHO
WILL UNFORTUNATELY PROBABLY BE
MORE OF THESE CASES AS
CALIFORNIA BECOMES GRAYER RIGHT
IN THE NEXT, SEVEN YEARS,
SOMETHING LIKE 20 PLUS PERCENT
OF THE POPULATION WILL BE OVER
THE AGE OF 65 IN CALIFORNIA,
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS
WHAT WILL LIKELY BECOME, A
BIGGER ISSUE WHERE MORE OF US
HAVING FAMILY MEMBERS THAT ARE
RECEIVING CARE AND I THINK MORE
OF US WANTING TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THEM, THE BILL HAS THE
SAFEGUARDS SO THAT IT REALLY IS
THAT BIG OF AN EMERGENCY. THIS
THERE'S A BACKSTOP TO IT. AND IF
IT REACHES THAT LEVEL, THEN THE
ACCESS WILL NOT BE THERE. I
THINK, AGAIN, TO WHAT SOME FOLKS
THINK, THE DETRIMENT IS OF THOSE
WHO ARE RECEIVING CARE. SO WITH
THAT, I'D RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE BEAUTIFULLY SAID.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, ARE YOU PREPARED TO, GIVE
A MOTION? CERTAINLY. IT'S JUST
YOU AND I. YES. I JUST DIDN'T
KNOW IF YOU WANTED TO WAIT TILL
WE CAN. THAT'S WHY I ASK, I CAN
I CAN MAKE A MOTION, BUT THAT
WOULD FINISH THE DIALOG, RIGHT?
THAT WOULD. BUT. YEAH, BUT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO MOVE ON. OKAY.
YEAH. AND UNLESS YOU HAVE SOME
MORE QUESTIONS. NO, I, WELL,
ACTUALLY, YES. OKAY. WE'RE GOING
TO END THE DISCUSSION. I'M JUST
GOING TO LET'S GO AND DO ONE
MORE MEMBER. ALVAREZ. THE. YEAH,
LET'S GIVE THEM THE TIME. SO
SORRY. JUST HOPEFULLY MY LAST
QUESTION, UNLESS SOMEBODY
ANSWERS AND SOMETHING ELSE POPS
UP BUT OUT OF HERE. SO ALL OF
THESE LOOSE END QUESTIONS THAT
WE HAVE THAT WE HAVEN'T
ADDRESSED HERE TODAY, THEY KIND
OF HAVEN'T TIGHTENED THINGS OVER
A BIT. IF WE DON'T ADDRESS THEM
NOW. AND HERE, IN THIS COMMITTEE
MOVING FORWARD, WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS, THE BILLS IS Dð, MOVE
TO APPROPRIATIONS PASSED THROUGH
PAST APPROPRIATIONS. SO I MEAN,
THE BILL CAN TAKE BUT NO
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN OFFERED OR
OR, CONSIDERED MOVING FORWARD
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE INTO THE
NEXT ONE. THAT'S CORRECT. IF I
MAY INTERJECT, MADAM CHAIR,
PLEASE, AT THAT POINT,
APPROPRIATIONS, AS YOU KNOW, HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO MAKE AMENDMENTS
OR NOT MOVE THE BILL FORWARD OR
NOT. SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE, IF
YOU HAVE THOUGHTS ABOUT WHAT
CHANGES ARE REQUIRED TO MAKE
THOSE, THOUGHTS KNOWN. AND
CERTAINLY I'LL TAKE THEM INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WELL. THANK
YOU. SO, IN GOOD FAITH, I'M
GOING TO, MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE
THE BILL FORWARD. AND THEN IN
HOPES THAT YOU MAY BE ABLE TO
WORK A LITTLE FURTHER ON SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE EXPRESSED
IN COMMITTEE TODAY, IN THE NEXT
ONE. AND THEN I WILL RESERVE MY
RIGHT TO, REASSESS THE BILL WHEN
IT COMES TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
I'M HOPING THAT THERE MIGHT BE
SOME, SOME LEEWAY, SOME MIDDLE
GROUND THERE BETWEEN SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE EXPRESSED HERE
AS COMMITTEE MEMBERS, IN
APPROPRIATIONS. ABSOLUTELY. AND
IF YOU WILL FOLLOW UP TO MAKE
SURE WE SPECIFICALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT THOSE CONCERNS ARE. SURE.
THANK YOU. ARE YOU OKAY WITH
THAT, MADAM CHAIR? I'M PERFECTLY
OKAY WITH IT. THAT'S WHY WE'RE
THE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE.
BECAUSE WE ARE. WE ARE HUMAN IN
TERMS OF HOW WE APPROACH OUR
BILLS. RIGHT SO, I, WE ALREADY
CLOSED. I AM GOING TO CLOSE OFF
THE DISCUSSION NOW, AND THEN I,
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
CHOBOQ, SISTER, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MOVED BY. SENATOR BORG,
FILE ITEM NINE, AB 2075. MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ALVARADO GIL, A
ALVARADO GIL I, OKOBOJI I
OKOBOJI I. OKAY. EYES TWO. WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OUR
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE. EVERYONE ALL RIGHT?
I'M GONNA TAKE A STRETCH BREAK.
I THINK I SAW SOME MEMBER WICKS.
YES HELLO, SOME OF OUR BONTA'S
HERE. OKAY. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT
. OH. DID SHE. NO, I DIDN'T HEAR
IT. OH, DID I? IT'S OKAY ON THIS
ONE YET. NO, NO, NO, IN TERMS OF
THE ROLL. OH, YOU DIDN'T GET A
CHANCE TO CALL ALL THE NAMES.
WE'LL DO IT AGAIN. I'M SORRY.
IT'S OKAY. I DIDN'T EVEN SAY IT
WAS. HE WAS SAYING. I DIDN'T SAY
IT WAS OUT. NO, I DIDN'T NO I
DIDN'T. ALL RIGHT. OKAY. WE'RE
GOOD. OKAY PERFECT. ALL RIGHT. A
LITTLE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES ON
THIS SIDE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS, WE HAVE
YOU FOR ITEM NUMBER SEVEN,
ASSEMBLY BILL 1961. WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBER, FIRST, I WANT TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOUR STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THE BILL AND
THE CONVERSATIONS YOU AND I HAD
ON THIS. MADAM CHAIR, AB 1961
WILL REQUIRE THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL TO ESTABLISH A
CONVENE. THE END HUNGER IN
CALIFORNIA MASTER PLAN TASK
FORCE. THIS TASK FORCE WILL
RECOMMEND FUTURE STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS ACCESS TO HEALTHY AND
CULTURALLY RELEVANT FOOD FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS, ADDRESSING
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING ADEQUATE,
NUTRITIOUS, AND CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE FOOD REQUIRES A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH BEYOND
SHORT TERM FIXES. BY CONVENING
EXPERTS, STAKEHOLDERS, AND
COMMUNITY LEADERS, WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CRAFTING A HOLISTIC
PLAN THAT TACKLES THE ROOT CAUSE
OF FOOD ACCESS AND INSECURITY
AND CREATES SUSTAINABLE
SOLUTIONS. I WANT TO THANK OUR
SPONSORS, THE U OF C C¯ WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL, CALIFORNIA FOOD
AND FARMING NETWORK, AND GRACE
AND POVERTY CALIFORNIA, I'LL LET
MY WITNESSES, SELF INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES TO DO TESTIMONY. AND
I'D ALSO JUST SAY THAT IF WE ARE
ABLE TO DO THIS, THIS WILL BE
THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE'RE DOING THIS
ON THIS ISSUE, AND OBVIOUSLY, I
THINK HUNGER PERMEATES ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES, URBAN SUBURBAN,
RURAL, THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR, GIVEN SOME
OF THE POVERTY ISSUES THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES FACE. BUT HAVING A
HOLISTIC APPROACH, I THINK IS
THE RIGHT WAY TO TACKLE AN ISSUE
THAT THERE'S NO REASON WHY WE
SHOULD HAVE HUNGER IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND I VIEW THIS
AS, ONE OF OUR MOST BASIC HUMAN
RIGHTS IS ACCESS TO GOOD,
NUTRITIOUS FOOD. SO WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, AND WE'LL GET TO MY
WITNESSES TESTIFY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'LL GIVE YOU ABOUT TWO
MINUTES EACH. OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, CHAIRPERSON ALVARADO
GILL. AND THANK YOU, VICE CHAIR
OCHOA BOGH. AND MY NAME IS
ESTHER PAMINTUAN. I'M THE SENIOR
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH ALAMEDA
COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD BANK, OR A
CFP BASED IN OAKLAND. PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY DECLARATIONS MAY HAVE
ENDED, BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE,
HUNGER IS STILL AN EMERGENCY.
AROUND 1 IN 4 ALAMEDA COUNTY
RESIDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING SOME
LEVEL OF FOOD INSECURITY. 7 IN
10 LIVING IN POVERTY ARE PEOPLE
OF COLOR, AND NEARLY 1 IN 5
SENIORS LIVE AT OR NEAR THE
POVERTY LEVEL. ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK IS ON THE
FRONT LINES RESPONDING TO THIS
HUNGER CRISIS. OUR FISCAL YEAR
ENDED YESTERDAY AND PENDING
FINALIZED JUNE NUMBERS. WE WILL
HAVE DISTRIBUTED MORE FOOD LAST
FISCAL YEAR THAN ANY OTHER OF
OUR 40 YEARS OF EXISTENCE. 59.4
MILLION POUNDS HIGHER THAN OUR
PEAK PANDEMIC YEAR. EKFB
PROVIDES NEARLY 1 MILLION MEALS
EVERY WEEK THROUGH OUR NETWORK
OF OVER 400 PARTNERS. OUR
CALFRESH OUTREACH EFFORTS HELP
MORE THAN 4000 HOUSEHOLDS BUY
THE FOOD THEY NEED MOST FROM
GROCERY STORES. YET FOOD BANKS
ARE BEARING THE BRUNT OF PUBLIC
SECTOR PUBLIC SECTOR CUTS. AFTER
CALFRESH EMERGENCY ALLOTMENTS
ENDED IN SPRING 2023, OUR
HELPLINE EXPERIENCED A 124%
INCREASE IN CALL VOLUME WHEN
COMPARING FEBRUARY 2024 TO
FEBRUARY 2023, BUT DESPITE THESE
CHALLENGES, EKFB REMAINS
COMMITTED TO THE PRINCIPLE THAT
FOOD IS A BASIC HUMAN RIGHT. AND
THAT IS WHY WE SUPPORT AB 1961.
WE'RE WORKING NOT JUST TO
ALLEVIATE HUNGER, BUT TO
ERADICATE HUNGER, AND THIS WILL
TAKE PARTNERSHIP ACROSS THE
STATE AND ACROSS SECTORS,
CENTERING COMMUNITY MEMBERS WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE WITH HUNGER. IT
WILL INVOLVE TACKLING SYSTEMIC
RACISM, POVERTY AND OTHER FORMS
OF INEQUITY. ENDING HUNGER IS AN
IMMENSE UNDERTAKING AND IT
REQUIRES SMART, EQUITABLE POLICY
TO TAKE THE FIRST STEP TO
ACHIEVING IT. AND FOR THESE
REASONS, I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB 1961. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. UNDER TWO MINUTES I
LOVE IT. THANK YOU. MOVE
FORWARD. HI, I'M SAM WILKINSON,
SENIOR POLICY ASSOCIATE WITH
GRAYSON AND CHILD POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA, THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER. AND MANY
THANKS TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER WIX
FOR YOUR FANTASTIC LEADERSHIP IN
POVERTY RELATED HUNGER. SIMPLY
PUT, NO ONE IN OUR GREAT STATE,
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD AND THE STATE THAT FEEDS
THE WORLD SHOULD GO HUNGRY. YET
HUNGER IS AT SHOCKING LEVELS IN
CALIFORNIA, REACHING 28% OF ALL
HOUSEHOLDS WITH CHILDREN AND
WITH SHAMEFUL RACIAL INEQUITIES.
HALF OF BLACK FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN ARE FOOD INSECURE,
COMPARED TO 21% OF WHITE
FAMILIES. THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
WE KNOW IT WORKS, PARTICULARLY
ON THE HUMAN SERVICES SIDE. WE
SAW THE HISTORIC IMPACT AND
POWER OF PANDEMIC ERA POLICIES
TO PREVENT HUNGER AND THE
PREDICTABLE CONSEQUENCES OF
HUNGER SOARING TO THESE LEVELS
ONCE THEY EXPIRED. WE KNOW WHAT
WORKS, BUT WE NEED A PLAN TO GET
THERE. AB 1961 DELIVERS THE
COMPREHENSIVE WHOLE GOVERNMENT
APPROACH NEEDED, BRINGING
TOGETHER NOT JUST DSS BUT CDE
FOR SCHOOL MEALS, CDFA AND OTHER
AGENCIES THAT TOUCH OUR FOOD AND
NUTRITION NUTRITION SYSTEM. MANY
OF THESE SOLUTIONS WILL IMPROVE
OUR DRAWDOWN OF FEDERAL
RESOURCES. RIGHT NOW, CALIFORNIA
CALFRESH IS AT 71% ENROLLMENT,
MEANING THAT WE ARE LEAVING 3.5
BILLION IN FEDERALLY FUNDED FOOD
BENEFITS ON THE TABLE IN SOME
2.7 MILLION CALIFORNIANS, NOT
ACCESSING THAT FOOD AID WITH
PARTICIPATION IS EVEN LOWER AT
65. AND MANY OF THESE SOLUTIONS
MATTER MOST TO RURAL FOOD
PRODUCING REGIONS LIKE YOUR
DISTRICT CHAIR, FOR EXAMPLE,
EVERY $1 IN CALFRESH BENEFITS
GENERATES AS MUCH AS 1.8 GDP,
AND EVERY 1 BILLION IN BENEFITS
CREATES MORE THAN 10,000 JOBS.
FARM WORKERS, TRUCKERS, GROCERY
WORKERS AND OTHERS ACROSS OUR
VITAL FOOD ECONOMY. AGAIN, I
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS FOR
LEADING THIS EFFORT AND ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT. ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT? COME ON
OVER. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
JOSE GRAVEL WITH UFCW WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL PROUD CO-SPONSOR
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. Kò
CONTRA COSTA SOLANO FOOD BANK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SHARON
GONSALVES WITH THE CITY OF
MERCED IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
KIM LEWIS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NICO MASLAN WITH THE
MESA VERDE GROUP ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. KELLY LONGO FLORES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS, PROUD CO-SPONSOR AND IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU, BETH
SMOKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
AND FARMING NETWORK, ALSO A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR AND IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR BETSY MONTIEL
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU, MACKENZIE
RICHARDSON. THRIVING FAMILIES,
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OSCAR SANDOVAL WITH THE
CENTER FOR HEALTHY COMMUNITIES
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, ADAM KEGUAN ON
BEHALF OF NO KID HUNGRY AND
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, HENRY
ORTIZ WITH COMMUNITY HEALERS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, Þ. IT JUST FEELS REALLY
GOOD. SORRY WAVE OF POSITIVE
ENERGY. ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL THAT LIKE
TO BE HEARD TODAY? PLEASE COME
FORWARD. ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION TO TODAY'S
BILL. OKAY. SEEING NONE, I'LL
BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. SENATOR, DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR? YES, ACTUALLY I DO. OKAY
HELLO. WELCOME, MEMBER WICKS. SO
I THINK IT'S GREAT WE HAVE SO
MANY PEOPLE WORKING ON,
PROVIDING MEALS THROUGHOUT THEIR
STATE, PRIVATE, PUBLIC, WE HAVE
SO MUCH THAT I THINK IT'S A
GOOD, GOOD IDEA TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT PUTS EVERYTHING
TOGETHER AND ANALYZES WHAT'S
WORKING AND NOT WORKING AND GIVE
SUGGESTIONS ON THAT END, TO
ENSURE ACTUALLY MY THING IS TO
START ADDRESSING THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM OF WHY THERE IS HUNGER,
WHY THE POVERTY? WHY DO WE HAVE
SO MANY INDIVIDUALS THERE? I
HAVE AN IDEA. BUT, YOU KNOW, IF
WE COULD PUT IT OFFICIALLY IN IN
PLAY, THAT WOULD BE GREAT, SO MY
QUESTION HAS TO DO WITH THE TASK
FORCE, BECAUSE THIS THIS BILL IS
, AS I READ HERE, WOULD REQUIRE
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL IN
CONSULTATION WITH SPECIFIED
ENTITIES, TO APPOINT AND CONVENE
THE END HUNGER. CALIFORNIA
MASTER PLAN TASK FORCE, TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR FUTURE
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGIES AIMED
AT ADDRESSING ACCESS TO HEALTHY
AND CULTURALLY RELEVANT FOOD OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS. AS WITH ANY
DEPARTMENT, MY BIGGEST THING IS
THAT I SEE WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND ENTITIES
GROW AND GROW AND THAT COST.
IT'S AN ONGOING COST FOR THE
STATE IN WHICH WE THEN HAVE TO
TAX INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES OR
COMPANIES OR BUSINESSES IN ORDER
TO HAVE THAT FUNDING TO TRY TO
FIX, THIS PROBLEM. SO,
ULTIMATELY, YOU KNOW, POVERTY
IS, IS MANY A TIMES THE
REFLECTION OF, OF POLICIES THAT,
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE ARE WORKING IN
CALIFORNIA, YOU KNOW, MANY
FAMILIES ARE WORKING TWO, THREE,
FOUR JOBS AND THEY'RE STILL
STRUGGLING FINANCIALLY, THE COST
OF LIVING IS REALLY HARD. SO, IN
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE, I WAS
KIND OF CURIOUS, WOULD THERE BE
WOULD YOU HAVE CONSIDERED OR
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED THE TIME
FRAME IN WHICH THEY WOULD HAVE
TO BE, IN EFFECT, THE TIME FRAME
IN WHICH THEY COULD WORK TO GET
THIS TASK FORCE, WITH THE PLAN
THAT THEY NEED IN ORDER TO
DEVELOP THOSE STRATEGIES. IS
THERE A SUNSET WHERE WE SAY,
OKAY, THIS IS IN PLACE FOR THESE
MANY YEARS TO FIGURE OUT THE
STRATEGIC PLAN, AND THEN WE
IMPLEMENT IT AND LET THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS, SUCH AS, LET'S SEE,
WHO DO WE HAVE THE, THE STATE
DEPARTMENT ON SOCIAL SERVICES,
THE SECRETARY OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCIES AND THE GOVERNORS, TO
CONTINUE DOING THE WORK PER SE,
OR IS THIS AN ONGOING TASK FORCE
THAT YOU SEE, IT'S FOREVER GOING
TO BE IN PLACE. SO, LET ME
UNPACK THAT A LITTLE BIT. I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION. AND I
ACTUALLY VIEW THIS AS A GOOD
GOVERNANCE BILL AS WELL. RIGHT?
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, AND I'VE
TRADITIONALLY CARRIED THE BUDGET
ASK FOR THE FOOD BANKS. I THINK
EVERY YEAR APART FROM LAST YEAR,
SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE, TO THE TUNE OF $100
MILLION OR MORE, YOU KNOW, AND
THOSE FOOD BANKS NEED THOSE
RESOURCES. THAT'S LIKE A DROP IN
THE BUCKET OF THE FUNDS THAT WE,
YOU KNOW, INVEST IN THIS, WHICH
I THINK ARE CRITICAL, NOT TO
MENTION WHAT OUR COUNTIES ARE
DOING AND SO ON AND SO FORTH. SO
I THINK THE BIGGEST QUESTION IS,
IS THAT WORKING? ARE THOSE
RESOURCES WORKING? ARE THEY
REACHING THE PEOPLE THAT WE NEED
THEM TO REACH, AND IF NOT, WHY?
AND SO I THINK YOU'RE ASKING THE
RIGHT QUESTION. YOU KNOW, WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE AS TAXPAYERS
THAT OUR MONEY IS GETTING SPENT
WISELY. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY, WE
WANT TO SOLVE ACTUALLY SOLVE THE
PROBLEM. MAKE SURE THAT OUR
SOCIAL SAFETY NET IS REALLY,
BENEFITING THE PEOPLE WHO NEED
IT MOST. AND SO I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE MAIN FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTIONS OF THE TASK FORCE. YOU
KNOW, WE AND, YOU KNOW, ON ON
PAGE THREE OF THE ANALYSIS KIND
OF TALKS THROUGH WHO
SPECIFICALLY WOULD BE ON THE
TASK FORCE. WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE WE HAD A NICE DIVERSE GROUP
OF STAKEHOLDERS. GOVERNMENT AND
NON-GOVERNMENT ETCETERA, PEOPLE
AT DIFFERENT ANGLES OF THIS
ISSUE. AND THIS ISSUE TOUCHES SO
MANY DIFFERENT THINGS, FROM AG
TO ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES TO
POVERTY ISSUES, RACIAL JUSTICE
ISSUES. I MEAN, THERE'S A WHOLE
BUNCH THAT KIND OF COMES INTO
PLAY HERE. SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE HAD, YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
DIVERSE STAKEHOLDERS, AS IT
WITHIN THE BILL, THE IDEA IS
THAT THE MASTER PLAN WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
JANUARY 1ST, 2026, WITH A SERIES
OF RECOMMENDATIONS, I THINK IT'S
OUTSTANDING AROUND WHAT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE AND THEN
WHAT THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH
THOSE WOULD BE. BUT THIS WOULD
REALLY SERVE AS A CENTER OF
GRAVITY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN THE SPACE, WHO ARE
EXPERTS IN THIS SPACE AROUND
WHAT ARE WE DOING AND WHAT ARE
WE NOT DOING? WELL, YOU KNOW,
AND HOW CAN WE MAKE THAT BETTER?
AND SO I DON'T VIEW IT AS
ANOTHER LAYER OF GOVERNMENT. I
VIEW IT AS, LET'S TAKE A BEAT
AND ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND WHERE
WE'RE SUCCEEDING AND WHERE WE'RE
FAILING, AND FIGURE OUT THE
RIGHT POLICY PRESCRIPTION TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE SUCCEEDING.
BUT THIS STILL WOULD BE A
GOVERNMENT, ASSIGNED AND THERE'S
A COST TO IT. RIGHT? A COST TO
IT. THERE IS, YOU KNOW, AND
IT'S, THE COST IS ON PAGE SIX OF
THE ANALYSIS, AND IT'S 3.71
MILLION FOR THE FIRST YEAR AND
2.2, IN THE SECOND YEAR, YOU
KNOW, AND I ALSO, AS THE
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR, ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE MOMENT THAT WE'RE
IN IN TERMS OF RESOURCES FOR THE
STATE. AND OBVIOUSLY, THIS WILL
YOU KNOW, IF IT GETS OUT TODAY,
IT'LL GO THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HERE IN THE SENATE AS
WELL, I'M REALLY OPEN TO
POTENTIAL COST SAVING MEASURES
ON WHAT WE COULD DO TO HELP
BRING DOWN THAT COST OR OTHER
KIND OF CREATIVE IDEAS TO THAT
END, AND I'M HAPPY TO TALK WITH
YOU OR OTHERS OR THE
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR IN THE
SENATE AROUND THAT, BUT I DO
VIEW A LIMITED INVESTMENT I
THINK CAN HAVE A MUCH BIGGER ROI
ON WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY DOING AND
HOW WE'RE ACTUALLY TACKLING THE
PROBLEM, AND I'M PERFECTLY OKAY
WITH THAT. I'M JUST CURIOUS AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT YOU ENVISION
THIS TASK FORCE TO BE AN
ONGOING, IN INFINITELY, OR IS
THERE A CERTAIN TIME FRAME THAT
YOU SEE? OKAY, THEY'VE DONE
THEIR JOB. IT'S COMPLETED NOW.
WE'LL LET THE POWER FORCES BE,
ENACT AND MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND THEN IF YOU
KNOW, THERE WERE A NEED TO SEE
IT COME BACK IN YEARS, YOU KNOW,
FORWARD IS I THINK THE REPORT
ITSELF IS GOING TO HELP
DETERMINE THEN WHAT WE END UP
DOING. YOU KNOW, I MEAN, I DOUBT
IT'S GOING TO COME BACK AND SAY
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING
PERFECTLY. SO I THINK THERE WILL
BE ONGOING NEED. AND THOSE ARE
BRIDGES WILL CROSS WHEN WE WHEN
WE GET THERE AFTER THE ANALYSIS,
I UNDERSTAND THAT. BUT ONCE THE
STUDIES COME OUT AND ONCE THEY
COME BACK, YOU KNOW, USUALLY
LIKE THE LEGISLATIVE AUDIT, I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS HAS A SUNSET
ON IT. I CAN I CAN DOUBLE CHECK.
OKAY. WOULD YOU BE OPEN TO
CONSIDERATION OF, OF A SUNSET
PERIOD? I'M JUST SAYING, YEAH.
YOU DON'T WANT TO CREATE MORE
LAYERS THAT ARE ONGOING AND
ONGOING FUNDING AND ALL THAT
SORT OF STUFF. YEAH THAT IN
HOUSING AND, YOU KNOW, IN LA
WHERE WE JUST ADD MORE AND MORE
AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE, YOU KNOW, I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS, BUT I
WANT TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT,
YEAH, THERE'S ANY MEASURE OF IT,
IT IS A ONE TIME TASK FORCE, IF
THAT'S THE SPECIFIC QUESTION.
YEAH. BUT I DON'T KNOW IF IT HAS
A SPECIFIC SUNSET, BUT IT IS A
ONE TIME TASK FORCE. I WOULD SO
WHICH MEANS THAT IT WOULD
CONCLUDE AS SOON AS THAT WE GET
THE REPORT. THAT'S RIGHT. I
WOULD JUST CAUTION CAUTION US
FROM NEGOTIATING AT THE DAIS.
ANY AMENDMENTS ACTIVELY, BUT
JUST SHARE YOUR THOUGHTS. YEAH.
CONVERSATIONS. WE'RE HAVING A
CONVERSATIONS. YES. ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS, SENATOR?
I'M GOOD. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING SO
CLOSELY WITH US, TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD, YOU KNOW, I REALLY
HAVE A PHILOSOPHICAL QUESTION,
AND IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A LONG
ANSWER, BUT WHAT WOULD WHAT
WOULD IT LOOK LIKE TO END HUNGER
IN CALIFORNIA? WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE? I MEAN, I THINK
THAT'S THAT IS THE GOAL, RIGHT?
AND I THINK IT'S NOT JUST, I
THINK IT'S ALSO KIND OF HOW YOU
DEFINE HUNGER. I THINK IT ALSO
MEANS MAKING SURE WE HAVE ACCESS
TO NUTRITIOUS FOOD, NOT JUST
FOOD, BUT NUTRITIOUS FOOD. AND
FOR ME, THIS IS TIED TOGETHER TO
SO MANY THINGS AROUND OUTCOMES,
AROUND EDUCATION, AROUND HOUSING
SECURITY. I MEAN, THERE'S SO
MANY PIECES THAT THAT HUNGER
TOUCHES, WHICH IS ALSO WHY I
THINK THIS TYPE OF TASK FORCE IS
IMPORTANT, BECAUSE I THINK THE
IDEA IS THAT WE HAVE THAT
MOONSHOT GOAL, AND WE THINK
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET
THERE. OKAY. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ASK THAT QUESTION.
AND I THINK THE TASK FORCE IS
GOING TO BE TASKED WITH DEFINING
THAT BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, WE OFTEN
SEE MOVEMENTS LIKE THE
ANTI-POVERTY MOVEMENT. AND THE
QUESTION FOR ME IS ALWAYS JUST
LIKE, WELL, WHAT DOES THAT LOOK
LIKE? ONCE WE ACHIEVE THAT?
RIGHT? AND I THINK THIS IS A
BOLD AND AMBITIOUS GOAL, AND,
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
AUTHOR TO MOVE THIS FORWARD.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE WHEN WE PUT
FORWARD LEGISLATION THAT HAS A
PRICE TAG, PARTICULARLY IN A
BUDGET YEAR, A BUDGET DEFICIT
YEAR, WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS THEN, LEVERAGING THE
INVESTMENT, UPSTREAM. AND SO I
THINK CERTAINLY THAT'S, THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT IT HERE.
AND I KNOW, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS, THAT'S HOW YOU HAVE
FRAMED THIS AND BUILT THAT AS
WELL. SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE OUTCOMES OF, OF THE
TASK FORCE. AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ENTERTAINING OUR
AMENDMENTS AS WELL. OF COURSE.
THANK YOU. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, ARE YOU OPEN
FOR A MOTION OR DO YOU WANT ME
TO HOLD? OKAY. ALL RIGHT. I'M
HAPPY TO MAKE THE MOTION. WE'LL
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
OCHOA, BOGH ASSISTANT. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. BEALL MOVED BY
SENATOR OCHOA. BOGH FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB 1961. MOTION IS DUE.
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ALVARADO, GIL. A
ALVARADO GIL I A CHOBOQ I A
CHOBOQ. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER LIMÓN
MENGIBAR. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO WE
HAVE TWO EYES AND WE WILL LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE. ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, I SEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA HAS BEEN VERY PATIENT,
SALLY FRIEDMAN HAS SNUCK IN
BEFORE YOU. I'M SO SORRY, BUT
WE'LL GET YOU NEXT. NO MATTER
WHO COMES IN THE ROOM. OKAY AND
THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS, WE
DO HAVE A VOTE ONLY FOR YOU, BUT
WE ARE GOING TO WAIT UNTIL THE
END OF THE HEARING. OKAY? ALL
RIGHT. THAT WAS YOUR QUESTION.
OKAY. GOT YOU. YEAH ALL RIGHT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN, DO YOU
HAVE WITNESSES WITH YOU TODAY?
YES. OKAY. WE'LL HAVE THEM COME
FORWARD TO THE TABLE, PLEASE.
WE'LL BE ALL READY TO GO AND
THEN GET STARTED WHENEVER YOU'RE
SET. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, 5 MILLION CALIFORNIANS
ARE LIVING IN POVERTY. IT
SHOULDN'T SURPRISE ANYONE THAT
CALIFORNIA CONTENDS WITH THE
ENDURING CHALLENGE OF HAVING ONE
OF THE NATION'S HIGHEST LIVING
COSTS, THE STAGGERING HOUSING
PRICES, THE RELENTLESS SURGE IN
EDUCATIONAL EXPENSES, HEALTH
CARE ACCESS, AND THE OVERALL
BURDEN OF MEETING BASIC NEEDS
POSE A FORMIDABLE ECONOMIC
HURDLE FOR A SUBSTANTIAL SEGMENT
OF OUR POPULATION. WITH THESE
FACTORS AND THE INSTITUTIONAL
BARRIERS THAT MAKE ACCESSING AID
PROGRAMS DIFFICULT FOR MANY,
IT'S NO SURPRISE THAT CALIFORNIA
IS HOME IS HOME TO THE NATION'S
STARKEST INCOME AND WEALTH
INEQUALITIES. GUARANTEED INCOME,
OR GI PROGRAMS OFFER A BEACON OF
HOPE. GI EXTENDS BEYOND
ALLEVIATING FINANCIAL HARDSHIP.
IT INFUSES DIGNITY INTO THE
LIVES OF THOSE FACING ECONOMIC
ADVERSITY AND GRAPPLING WITH
SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES. THANKS TO
THE TIRELESS WORK OF MANY OF THE
PEOPLE HERE IN THIS ROOM. MY
WITNESSES CALIFORNIA ALLOCATED
$35 MILLION TO LAUNCH THE
NATION'S PIONEERING GI PROGRAM
THREE YEARS AGO WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. OVER $25
MILLION IN GRANT FUNDING WENT TO
SEVEN DISTRICT GI PILOT
INITIATIVES STATEWIDE. THESE
PILOTS AIM TO PROVIDE
UNCONDITIONAL INDIVIDUAL AND
REGULAR CASH PAYMENTS TO DISRUPT
CYCLES OF POVERTY, PROMOTE
EQUITY AND MEET THE BASIC NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND
PIVOTAL LIFE STAGES, INCLUDING
THOSE WHO ARE PREGNANT OR AGING
OUT OF EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. THE
PILOTS WILL ASSESS THE IMPACT OF
ECONOMIC INTERVENTIONS DURING
THESE CRUCIAL LIFE TRANSITIONS,
BUILDING UPON THE LESSONS AND
SUCCESSES OF PREVIOUS GI
PROJECTS, IT'S VITAL TO
TRANSLATE THESE VITAL THESE
PILOT PROGRAMS INTO FINDINGS SO
THAT WE UNDERSTAND HOW THESE
PROGRAMS OPERATE, HOW THEY WORK
BEST, AND THE BEST WAY TO
IMPLEMENT THEM INTO THE FUTURE.
AND THAT'S WHERE AB TWO, TWO,
SIX, THREE COMES IN. OUR BILL
PROPOSES TO CONDUCT A
COMPREHENSIVE STUDY ON THE
NEEDED INFRASTRUCTURE, FUNDING
MECHANISMS AND PRIORITIZATION OF
POPULATIONS FOR STATEWIDE GI
PROGRAM IN THE FUTURE TO
ALLEVIATE POVERTY AND PROMOTE
ECONOMIC EMPOWERMENT. WITH THE
GUIDANCE AND ASSISTANCE OF A
NEWLY CREATED COORDINATING
COUNCIL. THE EARLY DATA FROM GI
PROGRAMS IS VERY PROMISING. WITH
THIS, BILL WILL BE SETTING UP
THE FRAMEWORK TO MOVE FORWARD IN
THE FUTURE TOWARDS A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM THAT WILL LIFT
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS OUT OF
POVERTY, AND WE'LL BE ABLE TO
MEASURE THAT SUCCESS. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE, AND TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS KIVA DEAN AND LAUREN
DALBERT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
EACH WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES. OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
KIVA DEAN. I'M A RESIDENT, A
RECIPIENT OF THE COCO GOBI
GUARANTEED INCOME PILOT AND A
MEMBER OF COMMENT STUDIOS. I
ALSO SIT ON THE BOARD OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE FOOD
BANK OF CONTRA COSTA. AND I'M AN
ADVOCATE FOR THEM AS WELL. I
ALSO LAST YEAR RETIRED FROM
CONTRA COSTA, IN THE SAME
BUILDING WHERE 26 YEARS PRIOR, I
RECEIVED CASH AID BENEFITS WHEN
I JOINED COMET STUDIOS. BEFORE I
RETIRED, I WAS NOT PARTICULARLY
ON BOARD WITH GUARANTEED INCOME,
BUT LAST YEAR I WAS FORCED TO
RETIRE DUE TO HEALTH CONCERNS.
AS A RESULT, MY INCOME HAS BEEN
CUT IN HALF AND I BEGAN TO SEE
ITS VALUE. MY COLLEAGUE TOLD ME
THAT I WAS SOMEONE WHO DID ALL
THE RIGHT THINGS, AND YET I
FOUND MYSELF IN FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTIES. AS A HOMEOWNER. I
USED THE GI FUNDS FOR
EMERGENCIES SUCH AS PLUMBING
NEEDS, AND TO PURCHASE HEALTHY
GROCERIES, AS I'VE BEEN TASKED
WITH LOSING 50 POUNDS SO I CAN
GET SOME SURGERIES SO THAT I CAN
GET HEALED, WE KNOW THAT AT THIS
TIME, THE AGING POPULATION ARE
MOST AT RISK OF FINANCIAL
VULNERABILITY AND HOMELESSNESS.
GIVING THIS DEMOGRAPHICS
RESOURCES TO MEET THEIR NEEDS,
NOT ONLY GIVES THEM DIGNITY, BUT
PEACE OF MIND. I URGE YOUR
STRONG SUPPORT IN FUNDING AB
2263, SO THAT WE CAN DO A DEEPER
DIVE INTO HOW GI CAN BE FUNDED
AND DISSEMINATED FOR THE BETTER
OF OUR OVERALL WELFARE AND
ECONOMY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
SENATORS, MY NAME IS LAUREN
DAUBERT, AND I LIVE IN BAY POINT
IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. I'M ONE
OF THE CO-FOUNDERS OF COMET
STUDIO. COMMENT. THE COM STANDS
FOR COMMUNITY AND THE INT STANDS
FOR ENTERPRISE. AND WE ARE
COMMUNITY ENTREPRENEURS AND WE
CREATED. AND COMET STUDIO IS A
COMMUNITY LED RESTORING
NEIGHBORHOODS PROGRAM OF SF
CONNECTS. NOW WE KNOW THAT
INVESTING IN LOCAL LEADERS HELPS
BUILD STRONGER COMMUNITIES. THIS
KNOWLEDGE LED US TO DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENT THE GUARANTEED INCOME
PILOT FOR OUR COUNTY, NOT TO
PROVE THE EFFICACY OF GI, BUT TO
EXPLORE THE CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES RELATED TO
IMPLEMENTATION AS COMMUNITY
RESIDENTS, WE WANT TO KEEP OUR
VOICE CENTERED IN THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION OF GUARANTEED
INCOME. AS A TWICE FORMERLY
HOMELESS DISABLED VETERAN, I
KNOW GI WORKS FOR TWO YEARS IN
MY 20S AND FOR FOUR YEARS IN MY
50S. I'LL LEAVE IN THE 50S. THIS
YEAR I EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS
DUE TO MILITARY TRAUMA, AND THE
ONLY REASON I AM NOT CURRENTLY
HOMELESS IS BECAUSE I AM A
PARTICIPANT IN A PERMANENT
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GUARANTEED
INCOME PROGRAM CALLED VA
DISABILITY. GUARANTEED INCOME IS
ABOUT MORE THAN JUST FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. THAT'S THE BEGINNING.
BUT IT IS A POWERFUL TOOL FOR
NURTURING RESIDENT LEADERSHIP
AND DEVELOPING LOCAL ECONOMIES,
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AND
UNDER-RESOURCED COMMUNITIES. FOR
EXAMPLE, BECAUSE I HAVE A
PERMANENT INCOME FLOOR, I HAVE
LEFT FIVE YEARS OF HOMELESSNESS
AND UNEMPLOYMENT BEHIND TO
BECOME A SUCCESSFUL SOCIAL
ENTREPRENEUR WHO IS CREATING NEW
JOBS, PROVIDING ESSENTIAL
SERVICES AND STIMULATING OUR
COUNTY'S ECONOMY. AND THAT IS
WHY I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE TO SUPPORT AB 2263, TO
HELP US EXPLORE A STATEWIDE GI
PROGRAM THAT ENSURES THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIA HAS THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY THEY NEED TO ENGAGE,
LEAD, INNOVATE, AND COLLECTIVELY
TRANSFORM OUR STATE FOR THE
BETTER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. WE WILL OPEN IT
UP TO THE PUBLIC. ANY MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THEIR
POSITION FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS MARTHA
GUERRERO, REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. WELCOME
SUPERVISOR REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SUPPORT. NICOLE
WATERMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, RACHEL
BOGERT WITH ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
ADRIN CARILLO. ON BEHALF OF
UNITED WAY, CALIFORNIA CAPITOL
REGION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
LAN LEI, ON BEHALF OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE,
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AMANDA KARCHER, ON
BEHALF OF COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SAM
WILKINSON WITH GRAYSON AND CHILD
POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA
CO-SPONSORING THE BILL AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. RIGHT. SORRY, MADAM
CHAIR, SENATOR MONICA MILLER,
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN LÀ ALSO
A CO-SPONSOR WITH GRAYSON
CHILDHOOD POVERTY. BUT HERE TO
PROVIDE ANY TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THAT'S NEEDED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANKS FOR CATCHING
ME BEFORE I MOVED ON TO
OPPOSITION. YOU'RE CONFUSING ME.
THERE I WAS. WAIT. YOU'RE AN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT. ANY
MEMBERS LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? NO. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION. YOU WALKING OUT?
OKAY, THERE WE GO. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS?
CONCERNS. SENATOR I PASS IT TO
YOU, JUST A QUICK QUESTION. I
THINK, FOR, THE PUBLIC, I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO, KIND OF
DEFINE OR, MAKE CLEAR, WHAT THE
DIFFERENCE IS BETWEEN HAVING,
SAY, WELFARE ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
AND GUARANTEED INCOME. I THINK
MANY PEOPLE WOULD SAY, WELL, I'M
NOT GOING TO SAY, BUT I'M JUST
SAYING I THINK THAT IS PROBABLY
SOMETHING THAT IS ON A LOT OF
PEOPLE'S MIND IS THE DIFFERENCE
OF WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE TO
WHAT YOU FOLKS ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO HAVING. YEAH, YOU CAN
ANSWER IF YOU'D LIKE. YEAH OKAY.
SO WE WOULD AGREE WITH YOU. I
MEAN, I THINK ULTIMATELY THE
GOAL OF GUARANTEED INCOME IS TO
PROVIDE TO LIFT PEOPLE UP IN ALL
COMMUNITIES. SO, AND WE KNOW
THAT THERE IS OFTENTIMES SORT OF
THAT, THAT STIGMA THAT IT'S A
WELFARE PROGRAM, IF YOU WILL.
BUT BUT WE THINK IT'S SO MUCH
MORE THAN THAT, AND WE WOULD
DEFINE IT AS SO MUCH MORE THAN
THAT, QUITE FRANKLY. AND WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT, AS WE LOOK BOTH AT
THE FEDERAL, STATE AND LOCAL
LEVELS, WE ARE TRYING TO DECIDE
ON HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE ELIGIBLE FOR ALL
PROGRAMS. SO, YOU KNOW, WHEN
THEY COME THROUGH A WELFARE
OFFICE WITH THE WITH THE COUNTY
MAKING SURE THAT THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR ALL PROGRAMS AND
SO, FOR EXAMPLE, MAYBE THEY
AREN'T ELIGIBLE FOR SOME OF THE
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE OUT THERE, BUT THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR GUARANTEED INCOME.
AND SO ULTIMATELY THE GOAL IS,
IS TO TRY AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE
HOW WE DETERMINE WHAT THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR AND WORK WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE IN
EXISTENCE RIGHT NOW WITH THE
SEVEN PILOT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
STATEWIDE, AND THEN THERE'S ARE
MANY PROGRAMS THAT ARE ALSO IN
EXISTENCE THAT ARE FUNDED BOTH
PRIVATELY AND AT LOCAL LEVELS,
WE WANT TO TRY AND SCALE THAT AT
A STATEWIDE LEVEL, TO AND AGAIN,
WORK WITH OUR COUNTY PARTNERS TO
TRY AND MAKE SURE THAT THESE ARE
ONE OF MANY OF THE TOOLS IN THE
TOOLBOX THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
PARTICIPANTS, AS WELL AS, THOSE
THAT ARE DIRECTING INDIVIDUALS
TO IDENTIFY WHAT PROGRAMS THAT
THEY WOULD MOST BE ELIGIBLE FOR.
OKAY. DOES THAT NOT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION? YEAH. YES. MAY I SAY
SOMETHING? IF THE CHAIR. YES. DO
YOU HAVE IS YOUR QUESTION WAS
YOUR NOT QUITE OKAY. YEAH. LET'S
SEE IF WE CAN ADDRESS THIS. YES,
AS A PERSON WHO HAS RECEIVED
WELFARE BENEFITS, GIVEN OUT
WELFARE BENEFITS AND RECEIVED
GUARANTEED INCOME, THERE IS A
STARK DIFFERENCE IN IN THE
WELFARE SYSTEM AND GUARANTEED
INCOME. AND ONE OF THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCES IS DIGNITY. WHEN I
RECEIVED BENEFITS AND WHEN I HAD
TO GIVE OUT BENEFITS IN THE
WELFARE DEPARTMENT, I FOUND A
LOT OF MY, CLIENTS DIDN'T FEEL
DIGNIFIED BECAUSE OF THE
APPLICATION PROCESS, BECAUSE OF
THE RENEWAL PROCESS, AND HAVING
TO GO THROUGH THE INTERVIEWS.
BUT WHEN I APPLIED FOR
GUARANTEED INCOME, IT WAS A
SIMPLE PROCESS. THERE WAS NO IT
WAS IT WAS NOT UNDIGNIFIED. IT
WASN'T VERY INTRUSIVE. AND I
FELT LIKE I WAS, I FELT LIKE I
WAS A HUMAN BEING. I FELT LIKE I
WAS ACTUALLY SOMEBODY WHO HAD
SOME DIGNITY AND SOME PRIDE. AND
SO I THINK THAT THERE'S A STARK
DIFFERENCE NOW. I THINK THAT WE
ALSO HAVE THE CONVERSATION.
WE'VE HAD THE CONVERSATION, AND
WE UNDERSTAND AS PRACTITIONERS
THAT WE KNOW THAT WHEN WE GIVE
OUT GUARANTEED INCOME BENEFITS,
IT MIGHT ADVERSELY AFFECT
WELFARE OR OTHER BENEFITS. AND
THAT'S AN ONGOING CONVERSATION.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THAT MAY BE
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT AB 2263
DOES ADDRESS. OKAY. WE'RE GOING
TO GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE, AND THEN I'M NOT GOING TO
CALL FOR A MOTION BECAUSE I NEED
TO GET SOME MORE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IN THE ROOM. BUT PLEASE,
GIVE US YOUR CLOSING. SURE. AND
JUST TO BE CLEAR, THIS BILL DOES
NOT INSTITUTE A GI PROGRAM. WHAT
IT'S DOING IS IT'S GATHERING
DATA ABOUT THE EXISTING PILOT
PROGRAMS TO SEE HOW IT'S WORKING
BEST. AND FOR WHOM, AND IN WHAT
WAY, ONE OF THE DIFFERENCES WITH
WELFARE IS, YOU KNOW, THESE ARE
FEDERAL PROGRAMS THAT OFTEN
CHANGE IN TERMS OF WHO'S
ELIGIBLE AND SORT OF WHAT THE
STRINGS ARE ATTACHED TO THOSE
PAYMENTS. GUARANTEED BASIC
INCOME IS JUST THAT. IT'S BASED.
IT'S SAYING TO PEOPLE, YOU NEED
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY TO
LIVE. WE'RE GOING TO GUARANTEE
THAT TO YOU WITHOUT THOSE
STRINGS ATTACHED, SO THAT YOU
CAN LIVE WITH DIGNITY, YOU CAN
PAY YOUR BILLS. AND WHAT THE
DATA HAS BEEN SHOWING IS THAT
THOSE PEOPLE TEND TO ACTUALLY
THRIVE, AND THEY ARE ABLE TO
MOVE UP ECONOMICALLY. THEY'RE
ABLE TO FIND EMPLOYMENT. MANY
TIMES IF THEY'RE IF THEY'RE ABLE
TO AND IT DOES ALLEVIATE THE
KIND OF DEEP POVERTY THAT WE
OFTEN SEE LEADING TO
HOMELESSNESS AND OTHER,
SITUATIONS THAT PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA JUST DON'T WANT OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND OUR
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS TO HAVE TO
GO THROUGH. SO IT REALLY IS
ABOUT THAT DIGNITY AND ABOUT
GIVING PEOPLE OPPORTUNITIES. AND
AGAIN, THIS BILL DOES NOT SET UP
A GI PROGRAM, BUT IT HELPS US TO
UNDERSTAND THE ONGOING PILOTS SO
THAT WE DO KNOW WHAT WORKS AND
WHAT DOESN'T TO ALLEVIATE
POVERTY, WHICH IS THE BOTTOM
LINE OF WHAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
ALL TRYING TO DO TO END CYCLES
OF POVERTY, WITH THAT, I WANT TO
THANK MY WITNESSES FOR COMING
HERE TODAY AND GIVING THEIR
REALLY POWERFUL AND VERY
PERSONAL TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IT'S REALLY
MEANINGFUL TO, I THINK, PUT A
VOICE AND A FACE TO WHAT, WHAT
CAN HAPPEN WITH THESE KINDS OF
PROGRAMS. AND WITH THAT I WOULD
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. SO WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
PRESENTATION OF ITEM NUMBER 16,
ASSEMBLY BILL 2476, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA, WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
HE'S GOING TO Ó. OKAY. THANK
YOU. WELCOME. PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. CHILDCARE IS THE WORK
THAT ENABLES ALL OTHER WORK.
PARENTS RELY ON CHILD CARE SO
THAT THEY CAN PURSUE WORK OR
SCHOOL AND BUILD FINANCIAL
STABILITY TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AND BUSINESSES, RELY ON
CHILD CARE TO MAINTAIN A STABLE
WORKFORCE. CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
ADMINISTERS SIX DIFFERENT
VOUCHER BASED CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS, COLLECTIVELY REFERRED
TO AS THE ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAMS. THESE PROGRAMS PROVIDE
VOUCHERS FOR FAMILIES TO USE FOR
CHILD CARE OF THEIR CHOOSING.
MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS RECEIVE
FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL CHILD
CARE DEVELOPMENT FUND, PART OF
THE CHILD CARE DEVELOPMENT BLOCK
GRANT. ON MARCH 1ST, 2024, THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PUBLISHED A FINAL RULE
TO MAKE REGULATORY CHANGES TO
THE CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
FUND EFFECTIVE APRIL 30TH, 2024.
AS PART OF THAT FINAL RULE,
STATES, TERRITORIES AND TRIBES
ADMINISTERING PROGRAMS USING
CHILD CARE DEVELOPMENT FUNDING
MUST USE PRIVATE PAY PRACTICES.
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS REQUIRE
PRIVATE PAYERS TO PAY FOR
SERVICE UP FRONT BEFORE THE CARE
IS PROVIDED TO COVER THEIR
MONTHLY EXPENSES. THESE
PROVIDERS OFTEN USE THE COST OF
EACH CHILD CARE SPOT TO FORECAST
REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES, AND
FINANCIALLY PLAN FOR THE FUTURE.
THERE IS THEREFORE A FINANCIAL
DISINCENTIVE FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO ACCEPT SUBSIDIZED
CHILD VOUCHERS, AS PAYMENT WILL
ONLY BE RECEIVED UNTIL 21 DAYS
AFTER THE CARE HAS ALREADY BEEN
PROVIDED. TO CORRECT THIS
INEQUITY, WE MUST CONTINUE TO
WORK TO ALIGN CALIFORNIA'S
SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
WITH THE PRIVATE PAY MARKET AND
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE RECENT
FEDERAL FINAL RULE, AB 2476
WOULD CLOSE THE GAP BETWEEN
SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE AND THE
PRIVATE PAY MARKET BY ENABLING
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS RECEIVING
STATE VOUCHERS TO BE PAID UP
FRONT PRIOR TO PROVIDING CARE.
I'LL NOW TURN IT OVER TO ANNIE
MAC FROM CHILD ACTION AND DENEEN
COBURN FROM THRIVING FAMILIES
CALIFORNIA. TO SPEAK MORE ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE. COOL,
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
ANNIE MAC, AND I'M THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF CHILD
ACTION, A PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF AB
2476. I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA, FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. SINCE 1976, CHILD ACTION
HAS BEEN DEDICATED TO EDUCATING
AND EMPOWERING FAMILIES AND
CHILD CARE PROFESSIONALS IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. OUR PROGRAMS
INCREASE ACCESS TO CHILD CARE
AND IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF CHILD
CARE SERVICES. THIS BILL WILL
HELP SUPPORT OUR MISSION BY
PROVIDING THE NECESSARY FUNDS TO
SUPPORT CHILD CARE BUSINESSES
AND KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN. IT
ALSO ADDRESSES AN EQUITY ISSUE
AS WE SERVE THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN FROM FAMILIES IN THIS
COUNTY. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
WHOM ARE FAMILIES OF COLOR. BY
ENSURING AN UPFRONT PAYMENT FOR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS TO COVER
THE COST OF CARE FOR SUBSIDIZED
FAMILIES, AB 2476 GREATLY
REDUCES THE DISCRIMINATION THESE
FAMILIES FACE WHEN ACCESSING
CHILD CARE. AB 2476 ACKNOWLEDGES
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AS
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO DESERVE TO
BE TREATED AS SUCH, AND FOR
FAMILIES, THIS GUARANTEED
PAYMENT LEVELS THE PLAYING FIELD
BY ALIGNING THE RULES BETWEEN
THE PRIVATE AND SUBSIDIZED
MARKETS. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK.
DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO SHOW?
OH, I'M SO SORRY. I AM SO SORRY.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK HERE, DANNY
MICHELETTI, COLBURN CEO WITH
THRIVING FAMILIES CALIFORNIA I'M
GOING TO KEEP IT VERY BRIEF. I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
CARRYING THIS, THIS TREMENDOUS
BILL THAT IS REALLY GOING TO
GIVE A GREAT DEAL OF RELIEF TO
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. THIS
POLICY HAS BEEN IN EFFECT SINCE
1978, WHERE PROVIDERS HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN REIMBURSED AFTER THE
CARE IS PROVIDED. ADDITIONALLY,
I WANT TO SAY THAT THIS BILL IS
GOING TO LIFT UP THE PRIVATE
NONPROFITS IN THIS SPACE THAT
SUPPORT CONNECTING FAMILIES TO
PROVIDERS. CURRENTLY, WE HAVE
OVER A THIRD OF NONPROFITS WHO
HAVE TO TAP INTO A LINE OF
CREDIT JUST TO PAY THE JUNE
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR CHILD CARE
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN PROVIDED.
THIS BILL IS GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT A LOT OF THESE SYSTEMIC
ISSUES ARE TAKEN CARE OF. IT
LIFTS UP THE NEEDS OF FAMILIES,
PROVIDERS AND THOSE THAT SERVE
BOTH. THANK YOU. NOW THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME. DO WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT? PLEASE
COME FORWARD. HELLO. GENESIS
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR ELENI KOUNALAKIS IN
SUPPORT, THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
JERILYN MCGOWAN, WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. AND
SENATOR ROSANNA CARAVAGGIO
ELLIOTT HERE, ON BEHALF OF THE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE NAPA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR.
MALIK BIDEN WITH UAW LOCAL 3930,
IN PARTNERSHIP AND ON BEHALF OF
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS, CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS, UNITED CPU, WE
ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE A POSITION
AT THIS TIME, BUT WE DO
APPRECIATE THE INTENT FROM THE
AUTHOR ON THE NOTION OF
PROSPECTIVE PAYMENT FOR CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY'RE PAID AHEAD OF
PROVIDING CARE. WE'VE HAD
ONGOING CONVERSATION, THAT'S ALL
JUST OKAY. AND THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION, MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION. OKAY, WE'LL BRING
QUESTIONS BACK TO THE DAIS.
SENATOR CHUBBUCK. I'M GOOD. NO
QUESTIONS. HAPPY TO MAKE A
MOTION WHEN THE TIME IS OKAY, I
DO WANT TO GET JUST SOME
CLARIFICATION FROM OUR AUTHOR
ABOUT SOME LATE AMENDMENTS. IF
YOU CAN JUST TELL US A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THOSE AMENDMENTS, AND
I UNDERSTAND THEY'LL BE GOING TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
YES. I THINK OUR AMENDMENTS ARE
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON IDENTIFYING
THE TIME OR DEADLINE THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS WILL
GO INTO EFFECT, AND WE'RE IN
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CCU TO MAKE SURE THAT WE COME UP
WITH A DEADLINE THAT IS
RESPONSIVE TO THE FEDERAL FINAL
RULE WAIVER. OKAY. SO THE, THE
CONTENT OF THE BILL WILL STAY
THE SAME. YOU'RE JUST GOING TO
REFINE SOME OF THE DEADLINES.
CORRECT? GREAT. THANK YOU. SO
MUCH FOR THAT CLARIFICATION. ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR BORG. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? THANK YOU. CALIFORNIA
LOST MORE THAN 1100 LICENSED
CHILD CARE FACILITIES AND NEARLY
19,000 LICENSED CHILD CARE
SPACES BETWEEN 2019 AND 2021. IT
IS INCREDIBLY CRUCIAL THAT WE
ENSURE THAT OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS ARE PROVIDED AND
AFFORDED THE ABILITY TO HAVE
DIGNITY OF, OF, AND SUSTENANCE
IN THEIR SERVICE TO OUR CHILDREN
AND WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. SO MUCH. THE MOTION FROM
SENATOR OCHOA BOGH, ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
16 AB 2476. MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO GIL A ALVARADO GIL A
AQUEBOGUE AQUEBOGUE AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER, LIMÓN MENGIBAR. ALL
RIGHT, SO THAT'S TWO EYES. NO
NO'S. WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR,
THE REST OF OUR COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. STRETCH
BREAK. DO WE SEE AUTHORS, OKAY.
WE ARE GOING TO GO INTO A FIVE
MINUTE RECESS UNTIL WE SEE SOME
AUTHORS. IT IS INDIRECTLY.
FROM RECESS AND WE HAVE AN
AUTHOR. HELLO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. AND I UNDERSTAND
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING TWO ITEMS
WITH US TODAY. ITEM NUMBER 15,
ASSEMBLY BILL 2452. AND ITEM
NUMBER 24, ASSEMBLY BILL 2935
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
YES. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. START WHEN YOU'RE READY.
YES IF YOU DO HAVE ANY
WITNESSES, WE'LL HAVE THEM COME
FORWARD. OKAY. I'M GOING TO DO
MY BILL FIRST. YEAH. AND THEN.
YEAH. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS. TODAY I
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2452. I'D
LIKE TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR THE
WORK ON THEIR ON THIS BILL. THIS
BILL WILL STANDARDIZE A MONTHLY
PAYMENT FOR TRANSPORTATION COSTS
FOR INDIVIDUALS PARTICIPATING IN
THE CALIFORNIA WORK OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAM, WELFARE TO WORK PROGRAM
WHO ARE ALREADY APPROVED FOR
TRANSPORTATION SUPPORT,
TRANSPORTATION SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROVIDED BY CAL WORKS
OFTEN COME IN THE FORM OF BUS
PASSES OR MILEAGE REIMBURSEMENT.
PAYMENTS FROM THE LOCAL
ADMINISTERING COUNTY WELFARE
DEPARTMENT. THESE SERVICES ARE
LARGELY FUNDED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THIS BILL WILL HELP
LESSEN ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS
FOR COUNTY WELFARE
ADMINISTRATORS AND STREAMLINE
TRANSPORTATION REIMBURSEMENT FOR
QUALIFYING PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS.
THE STANDARDIZED PAYMENT WILL
BETTER PROVIDE LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES THE
TRANSPORTATION SUPPORT RESOURCES
THEY NEED FOR REQUIRED PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES, PROVIDING THESE
PAYMENTS IN A TIMELY MANNER WILL
MAKE SURE INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE
TO GET TO SCHOOL OR WORK, GIVING
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO FULFILL
CAL WORKS REQUIREMENTS
SUCCESSFULLY WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. IS MR. CHRISTOPHER
SANCHEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS. HELLO, MR.
SANCHEZ, WELCOME. GIVE YOU TWO
MINUTES TO GIVE YOUR BEST
PRESENTATION. SURE, GOOD
EVENING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ WITH THE
MESA VERDE GROUP HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE SPONSOR, THE COALITION OF
THE CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. THAT
LESSENS THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN FOR CALWORKS RECIPIENTS
AND COUNTY HUMAN SERVICE
AGENCIES OVER THE YEARS, THE
LEGAL SERVICE COMMUNITY HAS
EXPRESSED THEIR FRUSTRATION
ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF HOOPS THAT
CALWORKS RECIPIENTS HAVE TO JUMP
THROUGH TO RECEIVE A
REIMBURSEMENT FOR TRAVEL
EXPENSES THAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE
FOR. IN FACT, A RECENT REPORT
RELEASED BY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION OF THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS AND THE GOLDEN
STATE OPPORTUNITY, TITLED
EVERYTHING I ONCE MENTIONED THAT
IN GENERAL, RECIPIENTS OF PUBLIC
BENEFIT PROGRAMS EXPRESSED THAT
THEY WOULD SAVE MORE TIME AND
ENERGY NOT TRYING TO REQUEST
REIMBURSEMENT FOR VARIOUS
SERVICES BECAUSE THEY WOULD HAVE
USED THAT TIME AND ENERGY
ELSEWHERE. THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
MORE PRODUCTIVE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. AND THE DATA SUPPORTS
THIS. ACCORDING TO THE DATA FROM
CDSS IN SEPTEMBER OF 2023, THERE
WAS ABOUT 26 COUNTIES THAT HAD
LESS THAN 50% OF CALWORKS
RECIPIENTS WHO HAD ACCESS
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING IN BOTH
RURAL CALIFORNIA AND HIGHLY
POPULATED COUNTIES SUCH AS LOS
ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO. THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR REIMBURSEMENT
DO NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
LIFE FACTORS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
WHO ARE LIVING TODAY IN THESE
TIMES, WHO ARE TRYING TO MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS. ADDITIONALLY,
WE KNOW THAT CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS ARE TRAVELING FROM
HOME TO WORK TO SCHOOL AND TO
CHILD CARE TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
LIFE AND THOSE OF THEIR CHILDREN
. IT IS FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK
IN OUR DRIVE OUT, THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT. PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD EVENING. REBECCA GONZALEZ
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
TIFFANY WHITEN WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. OKAY. ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL WOULD
LIKE TO BE HEARD. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION. OKAY.
WE'LL BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO COMMITTEE. I HAVE A
MOTION QUESTION, QUESTION,
QUESTION FOR SENATOR CHOBOQ AND
A MOTION FROM SENATOR MENGIBAR.
THANK YOU. SO OUT OF CURIOSITY,
ONE, HOW DO WE COME UP TO WITH
THE $200 REIMBURSEMENT RATE? AND
NUMBER TWO, IN OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM, IS THERE A CAP AT $200,
IF I MAY, MADAM CHAIR, THE $200
AMOUNT, IS SOMETHING THAT THE
ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICE COMMITTEE
HAD REQUESTED TO BE PLACED INTO
THE BILL, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LEGISLATIVE HISTORY, THE AUTHOR
AND US, BELIEVED THAT 100, WOULD
HAVE BEEN SUFFICIENT, WE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH CDSS TO
TRY TO FIGURE WHAT THE CURRENT
AVERAGE AMOUNT IS, REQUESTED BY
CALWORKS RECIPIENTS WHO
CURRENTLY ACCESS THE PROGRAM,
AND THEN TO THE SECOND POINT,
THERE IS CURRENTLY NO CAP FOR,
THIS FUNDING. TYPICALLY IT IS
USED FOR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION,
BUT YOU COULD ALSO USE IT FOR,
SAY, AUTO REPAIRS TO YOUR
VEHICLE OR SO FORTH. AND THAT'S
WHY THERE'S NO CAP, AND WHICH IS
ALSO IN THE BILL, AS WELL. SO IN
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM, THERE IS NO
CAP, TO WHAT YOU CAN BE
REIMBURSED FOR, WE DON'T HAVE AN
AVERAGE OF WHAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS, AVERAGING AS FAR AS
WHAT PEOPLE ARE BEING REIMBURSED
FOR AND THE 200 CURRENT DOLLARS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE BILL IS JUST
JUST KIND OF RANDOMLY PLACED ON
THERE OR, LET ME ANSWER THAT,
THAT WE INITIALLY HAD 100, BUT
THE CHAIR OF THE HUMAN SERVICE
COMMITTEE ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
ASKED IT TO BE MOVED TO 200. WE
KNOW IN THIS BUDGET THAT EVEN A
$100 STIPEND MIGHT BE VERY
STEEP, BUT THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS, WE WORKED WITH
THAT CHAIR AS WELL TO MAKE SURE
WE COULD GET THIS BILL OUT. I
THINK ONE OF THE, COMPARISONS I
WOULD MAKE, AS ALL OF US HAVE
OUR OWN STAFF WHO TRAVEL, TAKING
US PLACES, WE KNOW THAT WHEN
THEY, MANY TIMES ON A MONTHLY
BASIS TURN IN THEIR
REIMBURSEMENT FORMS THAT SOME OF
THEM ACTUALLY DON'T DO THAT
BECAUSE OF THE STEPS THAT IT
TAKES. I KNOW WITH MY TEAM,
I'VE, I'VE TOLD THEM SEVERAL
TIMES, DON'T FORGET TO TURN IN
YOUR REIMBURSEMENT. OTHERWISE
YOU'RE IN ESSENCE, YOU KNOW,
PUTTING MONEY OUT THAT YOU'RE
NOT BEING REIMBURSED FOR. SO THE
ATTEMPT OF THIS BILL IS TO ALLOW
THEM TO GET THIS STIPEND UP
FRONT SO THAT THEY AREN'T GOING
THROUGH THESE STEPS, THROUGH
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS, IN ORDER
TO GET TO THEIR JOBS OR SCHOOL.
THE PRICE IS A LITTLE TRICKY, AS
WE INITIALLY WERE ASKING FOR THE
$100 STIPEND, BUT THE CHAIR
ASKED FOR 200 AND THERE THE
CHAIR GOT IT. AND SO OUT OF
CURIOSITY. SO IF THEY DON'T
UTILIZE AND I'M NOT SURE IN WHAT
FORMAT YOU WOULD GIVE THE $200,
TO THE RECIPIENT. BUT IF THEY
WERE NOT TO USE ALL OF THE $200
FOR THEIR TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES, VISIT, KIND OF STAY
ON, ON, ON THEIR ACCOUNT, ON
THEIR, ON THEIR CARD, AND IS IT
TRANSFERRED OVER AS PART OF THE
$200 MOVING FORWARD FOR THE
FOLLOWING MONTH, OR IS IT
SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN JUST
UTILIZE IN FOR SOMETHING ELSE,
LIKE A DEBIT CARD? IS WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING? YES. I THINK
THOSE DETAILS STILL NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT. EXACTLY HOW THAT
WOULD LOOK. AS FAR AS THE UP
FRONT PAYMENT, BUT I DID HEAR
THE CONVERSATION IN THIS
COMMITTEE. A LITTLE WHILE BACK
TALKING ABOUT GUARANTEED INCOME.
SO IN THIS FOCUS AREA, IT'S FOR
TRANSPORTATION REIMBURSEMENT.
BUT AS WAS MENTIONED, YOU KNOW,
IT COULD BE CAR REPAIRS. IT
COULD BE THESE TYPES OF
TRANSPORTATION. THE FOCUS
GETTING BACK AND FORTH TO WORK
OR SCHOOL AND ELIMINATING THESE
MULTIPLE TIMES TO ASK FOR
REIMBURSEMENT. AND IN YOUR
OPINION, WHAT ARE THE THOUGHTS
WITH REGARDS TO WOULD THIS BE A
CASH CHECK OR WOULD IT BE LIKE A
DEBIT CARD THAT YOU WOULD GIVE
SOMEONE? IS THERE IS THERE ANY
IDEA OF HOW THIS WOULD BE,
IMPLEMENTED? IT DOESN'T SAY
SPECIFICALLY IN THE BILL, BUT WE
IMAGINED THAT IT WOULD GO
THROUGH THE, THE THROUGH THE EBT
CARD THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS. SO
POTENTIALLY SAY POTENTIALLY YOU
COULD SAY THAT, YOU KNOW, $200
ARE GIVEN TO THESE TO THE, TO
THE CARD. IF THEY WEREN'T TO USE
IT, IT COULD MOVE ON TO THE
FOLLOWING MONTH AND BE. SO IF
THEY YOU UTILIZE $150, $50 MOVES
FORWARD, THE STATE COULD
ALLOCATE $150 TO THEM AND MAKE
AN EQUAL TO 200. OR WOULD IT BE
AN ADDITIONAL 200 TO THE 50? AND
WE HAVE $250 ON THAT CARD? I
THINK THAT THERE'S STILL SOME
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE THAT NEEDS
TO TAKE PLACE AS EXACTLY, BUT I
THINK AS FAR AS THEIR MONTHLY
ALLOWANCE ON THEIR EBT WOULD BE
AN APPROPRIATE WAY TO USE THOSE
FUNDS. AGAIN, FOCUSING ON
TRANSPORTATION. BUT WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S SOMETIMES ADDITIONAL
UNFORESEEN COSTS THAT COULD COME
UP THAT, YOU KNOW,
TRANSPORTATION IS NOT ONLY A BUS
OR A MOTOR VEHICLE. IT COULD BE
A BIKE. MAYBE THEY NEED A BIKE
REPAIR THESE TYPE OF THINGS. SO
IT'S UNDER THE IDEA OF HOW DO WE
GET PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THESE
CALWORKS PROGRAMS BACK AND FORTH
TO WORK AND TO SCHOOL? THANK YOU
MADAM. ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
MENGIBAR. SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM 15 A B
2452. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ALVARADO GIL A
ALVARADO GIL A AQUEBOGUE
AQUEBOGUE AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
LIMÓN MENGIBAR. OKAY, SO WE HAVE
TWO EYES, AND WE WILL KEEP THIS
OPEN FOR OUR COLLEAGUES TO COME
AND MAKE THEIR VOTES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, AND I APOLOGIZE. I
DIDN'T ASK YOU TO CLOSE, DID I?
I WILL LET NÓ COMMENT BE MY
CLOSE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT. YES. AS AS THE
EVENING GETS LATER, I'M GOING TO
MAKE MORE. YES. OKAY ITEM NUMBER
24, ASSEMBLY BILL 2935. YOU'RE
WITH ME. I THOUGHT IT WAS AB 29.
OH, YES. ARE WE OKAY? LET'S SEE.
YES. I THOUGHT I JUST HEARD THE
WRONG. YES. OKAY, OKAY. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, I'M HAPPY TO
PRESENT TODAY AB 2935 ON BEHALF
OF MY COLLEAGUE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN, WHICH IS AN
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION TO PROTECT
FOSTER YOUTH. FOSTER YOUTH ARE
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO HAVING
THEIR IDENTITY STOLEN DUE TO THE
LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ACCESS TO THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION. EACH TIME A FOSTER
CHILD CHANGES PLACEMENTS,
ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS GAIN
ACCESS TO THEIR INFORMATION,
INCLUDING THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER. CHILDREN HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN AN ATTRACTIVE TARGET FOR
IDENTITY THIEVES BECAUSE THEIR
CREDIT REPORTS ARE CLEAN AND ARE
OFTEN LEFT UNMONITORED. FOR MANY
YEARS, PROVIDING AMPLE TIME TO
CAUSE SUBSTANTIAL DAMAGE TO THE
CHILD'S CREDIT. ONCE THE FOSTER
YOUTH REACHES 14, OR IF THEY
COME INTO THE SYSTEM AFTER THE
AGE OF 14. CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
COUNTY WELFARE DEPARTMENTS TO
CHECK WITH THREE CREDIT BUREAUS
TO SEE IF A CREDIT REPORT
EXISTS. BECAUSE CHILDREN SHOULD
NOT HAVE CREDIT REPORTS, THE
EXISTENCE OF A REPORT IS LIKELY
THE RESULT OF FRAUD. HOWEVER,
OUR CURRENT LAWS ONLY COME INTO
PLAY AFTER A YOUTH HAS BEEN
VICTIMIZED. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
PREVENT IDENTITY THEFT IN THE
FIRST PLACE BY REQUIRING THE
CREDIT BUREAUS TO AUTOMATICALLY
FREEZE AN INDIVIDUAL'S CREDIT
REPORTS WHEN THEY RECEIVE AN
INQUIRY, AN INQUIRY FROM A
COUNTY WELFARE DEPARTMENT
REGARDING A FOSTER YOUTH,
PLACING THE AUTOMATIC FREEZE
WILL PREVENT NEFARIOUS ACTORS
FROM BEING ABLE TO OPEN ACCOUNTS
IN A CHILD'S NAME. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS JESSICA
HELDMAN WITH CHILDREN ADVOCACY
INSTITUTE. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, I'M JESSICA
HELDMAN. I'M A PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL
OF LAW, AND IT'S CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY INSTITUTE. THE
INSTITUTE IS PLEASED TO
CO-SPONSOR AB 2935. THE BILL WAS
ACTUALLY THE IDEA OF FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH THEMSELVES, WHO HAD
SUFFERED FROM IDENTITY THEFT.
ONE OF THESE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WANTED TO TESTIFY TODAY BUT
COULD NOT. SO SHE'S ASKED ME TO
SHARE HER STATEMENT, WHICH I
WILL READ WITH YOUR PERMISSION.
YES, MY NAME IS KIERA ANDERSON.
WHEN I WAS 15 YEARS OLD, I WENT
INTO FOSTER CARE AT 17, I
STARTED TO SAVE UP, TO MOVE OUT.
IT WAS THEN THAT I LEARNED THAT
I NEEDED A DECENT CREDIT SCORE
TO RENT AN APARTMENT, BUT MY
CREDIT SCORE WAS 319. I HAD
DELINQUENT ACCOUNT DELINQUENT
ACCOUNTS FOR THE PAST 16 TO 17
YEARS. I DISCOVERED THAT MY
BIOLOGICAL FATHER HAD BEEN
OPENING ACCOUNTS USING MY SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER SINCE I WAS AN
INFANT. SHORTLY AFTER I TURNED
18, MY FOSTER PARENTS HANDED ME
ALL OF MY BELONGINGS IN A TRASH
BAG IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT
AND TOLD ME TO LEAVE. I HAD
NOWHERE TO GO. I ENDED UP LIVING
IN A CAR. I COULDN'T RENT AN
APARTMENT, AND I WORKED FOUR
JOBS TO COME BACK. THE IMPACT OF
MY LOW CREDIT SCORE. I SPENT
COUNTLESS HOURS ON THE PHONE. I
WROTE ENDLESS APPEALS THE SAME
DOCUMENTS, THE SAME STORY OVER
AND OVER. MY EXPERIENCE DEALING
WITH THE BUREAUS WAS COLD AND
IMPERSONAL, AND ALL OF THIS WORK
TOOK SEVERAL OVERWHELMING YEARS.
DID I FINALLY BRING MY CREDIT
SCORE BACK UP? YES. BUT DOES
WHAT HAPPENED TO ME STILL IMPACT
ME TODAY? YES. MY BROTHER IN
FACT ENDED UP COMMITTING SUICIDE
AT 20 YEARS OLD, AND I DIDN'T
LEARN UNTIL AFTER HE PASSED THAT
HE HAD ALSO BEEN VICTIMIZED BY
OUR FATHER'S IDENTITY FRAUD. I
HOPE WE CAN ALL COME TOGETHER
TODAY SO LESS FOSTER CHILDREN
HAVE TO SUFFER ON BEHALF OF KIRA
AND THE OTHER FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH WHO PUT FORWARD THE
SOLUTION PROPOSED BY AB 2935, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. JUST
ONE TEST, ONE WITNESS TO THIS
FOR QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THEIR
SUPPORT, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
OKAY. ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? PLEASE TAKE A SEAT.
WE'LL GET IT TURNED OFF. GREAT.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, RANDY POLLOCK,
ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER DATA
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION, AND WE ARE
IN TOTAL AGREEMENT THAT A FILE
SHOULD BE LOCKED DOWN,
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR FOSTER YOUTH,
TO MAKE SURE THAT FRAUD DOES NOT
OCCUR. OUR ONE CONCERN WITH THE
BILL IS THAT THE BILL CALLS FOR
THE AUTOMATIC REMOVAL OF THAT
FREEZE AT AGE 18. SO WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT. WE BELIEVE
IT SHOULD BE UP TO THE FOSTER
YOUTH AND THE PROTECTED CONSUMER
TO DETERMINE WHEN THAT FREEZE
SHOULD BE LIFTED, BECAUSE IF YOU
HAD FRAUD COMMITTING AT 17 YEARS
OLD, THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE THAT
18 YEARS AND ONE DAY IT STILL
COULD BE TRIED TO BE COMMITTED
BY THOSE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO MAY
BE TRYING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
YOU. WE BELIEVE THERE'S A
VARIETY OF INFORMATION OUT THERE
THAT HELPS PEOPLE, DESCRIBE HOW
TO LIFT THE FREEZE, BECAUSE WE
HAVE THINGS IN PLACE WHERE, FOR
EXAMPLE, YOU CAN LIFT THE FREEZE
FOR A PARTICULAR CREDITOR. YOU
COULD LIFT IT FOR A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF TIME, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS INFORMATION ABOUT
FREEZES OF HOW YOU GO ABOUT
PLACING A FREEZE. REMOVING A
FREEZE. YOU HAVE THE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT HAS LOTS OF
BROCHURES ABOUT THIS. SO WE
BELIEVE A BETTER WAY OF
APPROACHING THIS WOULD BE
PROVIDING THAT FOSTER YOUTH
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW TO REMOVE
A FREEZE WHEN THEY WANT TO IN
THE FUTURE, AND FOR THOSE
REASONS, THAT'S WHY WE'RE
OPPOSED CURRENTLY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISH TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION? OKAY. WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
SENATOR, ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS, I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR,
MAYBE FROM THE AUTHOR. WITH
REGARDS TO THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP OF
EXTENDING THE TIMELINE, I WILL
SAY THAT, ASSEMBLYMEMBERS,
MAIENSCHEIN IS THE AUTHOR.
THAT'S RIGHT. SO, I DON'T KNOW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S QUIRK-SILVA IF
YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE TAKING THE
QUESTIONS OR WE CAN THROW IT TO
I. I'LL LET THE. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S PUT IT OUT THERE
AND SEE WHAT WE CAN DO. YES. NO
AND I HAVE SOME QUESTION ANSWERS
HERE. ALL RIGHT. VERY GOOD.
WELL, WE'LL TOSS IT OUT. YEAH.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
AND THROUGH THE CHAIR. SENATOR,
MY NAME IS ED HOWARD. I'M A
SENIOR COUNSEL FOR THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY INSTITUTE AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO
SCHOOL OF LAW. REGRETTABLY, OUR
FOSTER YOUTH ARE IN UTTERLY NO
POSITION WHEN THEY TURN 18 YEARS
OF AGE TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE IN A
COMPLICATED IN ANY KIND OF HUGE
FINANCIAL TRANSACTIONS ON THEIR
OWN. THE STORY THAT YOU HEARD
ABOUT THE YOUNG WOMAN TURNING 18
AND BEING GIVEN A TRASH BAG TO
PUT HER BELONGINGS IN, AND
HAVING TO SLEEP IN HER CAR, I
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT SHE HAS
NEITHER THE SOPHISTICATION NOR
PERSONAL BANDWIDTH TO BE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO REMOVE A
CREDIT FREEZE, AND WHETHER A
CREDIT FREEZE WORKS, AND HOW TO
REMOVE ONE. AND SO REQUIRING THE
FOSTER YOUTH TO THEMSELVES
REMOVE THE CREDIT FREEZE INSTEAD
OF HAVING IT AUTOMATICALLY
EXPIRE WHEN THEY TURN 18. IS
SOMETHING THAT REGRETTABLY JUST
IT WILL NOT HAPPEN. AND SO BY
THE TIME, WHAT WILL END UP
HAPPENING IS THE CREDIT FREEZE
WILL ENDURE LONG PAST THEIR 18TH
BIRTHDAY, LONG AFTER THEY'VE
APPLIED FOR AN APARTMENT AND
BEEN DENIED AND NOT KNOW WHY.
LONG AFTER THEY'VE APPLIED FOR A
JOB AND BEEN DENIED AND NOT KNOW
WHY, THESE CHILDREN, WHAT WE DO
TO THEM AT 18 IS, APPALLING. AND
WE CAN'T ASK THEM WHEN CONSUMERS
YOU KNOW, RIGHT NOW, AS A
CONSUMER, IF I WANT TO PUT A
TIME FRAME BY WHICH MY CREDIT
REPORT WILL EXPIRE OR CREDIT
FREEZE WILL EXPIRE IN THE
FUTURE, ALL THREE BUREAUS PERMIT
ME TO DO THAT. SO BUT THAT'S THE
REASON WHY WE'VE, RESPECTFULLY
DECLINED TO TAKE THAT AMENDMENT.
INTERESTING I GUESS MY. OKAY,
SO. AND I CAN SEE I CAN SEE WHY
THE CONCERN OF NOT HAVING THE
ABILITY OR THE KNOWLEDGE TO BE
ABLE TO, TO, TO DO THAT ON THEIR
BEHALF, I GUESS MY, MY FOLLOW UP
, IF THROUGH THE CHAIR IS WITH
THE OPPOSITION, HOW WOULD THEY.
THAT'S A VALID CONCERN. SO I'M
JUST GOING TO CURIOUS AS TO THE
OPPOSITION AND HOW WOULD THEY
RESPOND TO THE CONCERN EXPRESSED
BY THE OPPOSITION TO ANSWER YES.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THE
ANSWER IS, IS THAT TO REMOVE A
FREEZE, YOU CAN MAKE A PHONE
CALL AND WITHIN AN HOUR THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO REMOVE THAT FREEZE.
IF YOU DO A MAIL, IT'S SUPPOSED
TO BE WITHIN THREE DAYS. THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO REMOVE THAT FREEZE
FROM YOU. IF YOU WOULD JUST
GOOGLE ON YOUR PHONE TODAY ON
LIFTING A FREEZE, YOU WILL SEE A
VARIETY OF WEBSITES THAT COME
UP. MATTER OF FACT, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND SOME OF
THESE SITES ACTUALLY GIVE YOU
THE LETTER. IF YOU WANT TO WRITE
SOMETHING IN OF WHAT YOU
ACTUALLY WRITE. THEY ALSO GIVE
YOU THE NUMBERS FOR ALL THE
CREDIT BUREAUS FOR YOU TO CALL.
SO WE BELIEVE THE INFORMATION IS
OUT THERE. WE UNDERSTAND THE
PREDICAMENT ABOUT THE FOSTER
YOUTH, ESPECIALLY GOING OUT, BUT
WE'RE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
HAVING GOT THEM MAKE THE OPTION
OF IF THEY WANT THE FREEZE
LIFTED, AS OPPOSED TO HAVE IT
AUTOMATICALLY REMOVED. THAT'S
THAT'S ALL WE'RE SAYING. MAY I
MAKE A, I JUST I JUST WANT TO
RESPOND. SO I DID GOOGLE, SO I'M
JUST GOING TO READ HERE IT SAYS
TO LIFT A CREDIT FREEZE. YOU,
YOU CAN CONTACT EACH OF THE
THREE MAJOR CREDIT BUREAUS. SO
YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW THROUGH WITH
ALL THREE ONLINE, BY PHONE OR BY
MAIL. YOU CAN ALSO SET UP AN
ACCOUNT WITH EACH BUREAU TO
FREEZE OR UNFREEZE YOUR CREDIT
TO MANAGE THAT, YOU'LL NEED TO
PROVIDE THE START AND END DATES
FOR A TEMPORARY LIFT, THERE IS
AN 800 NUMBER TO CALL. YOU HAVE
TO ESTABLISH A PIN, SUBMIT A
WRITTEN REQUEST SO I DON'T SEE
ANYTHING IN HERE THAT SAYS 24
HOURS. SO IS THAT. YEAH, IT'S
THE LAW THAT IF YOU WANT TO LIFT
THE FREEZE, IT'S WITHIN AN HOUR
BY A PHONE CALL. IF IT'S BY.
RIGHT. AND IF YOU WANT TO PLACE
IT, IT'S WITHIN A DAY. OH, I SEE
THIS. CREDIT BUREAUS MUST LIFT A
FREEZE WITHIN ONE HOUR, ONLINE
OR BY PHONE AND WITHIN THREE
BUSINESS DAYS BY MAIL. WHEN YOU
LIFT THE FREEZE, YOU CAN ALSO
SPECIFY HOW LONG YOU WANT THE
CREDIT REPORT TO BE AVAILABLE. A
WEEK IS USUALLY ENOUGH TIME FOR
POTENTIAL EMPLOYEE BLAH BLAH
BLAH. OKAY, THAT WAS I, BY THE
WAY. THANK YOU. I KNOW, AND THEN
EACH OF THE CREDIT BUREAUS HAS,
YOU KNOW, PROMINENT HOW TO HOW
TO FREEZE, UNFREEZE THROUGH THE
CHAIR, PLEASE. THE 40% OF THE
CHILDREN ARE HOMELESS. THESE ARE
HOMELESS YOUTH WHO HAVE NEVER
HAD A JOB, IN ALL LIKELIHOOD,
WHO HAVE NO ADULT IN THEIR
LIVES, NO ADULT IN THEIR LIVES
TO ASK FOR ADVICE. THIS IS WHAT
WE DO TO THEM. AND WITH I'VE
KNOWN MR. POLLACK LONGER THAN I
CARE TO ADMIT, BUT IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO IMAGINE ADDING ON
TO THE BURDEN OF AN ABUSED AND
NEGLECTED, TRAUMATIZED CHILD
THAT WE HAVE THROWN TO THE
STREET AT 18 YEARS OLD, TO TRY
AND FIND FOOD, TO TRY AND FIND
SHELTER, TO TRY AND FIND HEALTH
CARE, WHO IS ABSOLUTELY
TERRIFIED EVERY NIGHT TO ADD ON
TO THAT, ANY KIND OF FINANCIAL
TRANSACTION THAT INVOLVES CREDIT
BUREAUS THAT I ASSURE YOU THEY
DO NOT KNOW EXIST, AND THAT IS
RESPECTFULLY WHY, ESPECIALLY
WHEN REGULAR RETAIL CONSUMERS
CAN REQUEST THAT A CREDIT REPORT
BE, EXCUSE ME, A CREDIT FREEZE
BE ENDED BY A DATE CERTAIN.
WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
DATE CERTAIN HERE BEING THE 18TH
BIRTHDAY. THANK YOU. OTHER
QUESTIONS? CONCERNS SO, SO
BASICALLY, YOU FOLKS WANT TO
LIMIT TO 18. THE CREDIT BUREAU
WANTS TO EXTEND IT TO BEYOND
THAT, THAT DATE, YOU WANT TO
AUTOMATICALLY DO IT BY THE, BY
THE 18TH BIRTHDAY. YOU WANT TO
CONTINUE IT TILL WE WOULD JUST
CONTINUE. IF THE YOUTH WANTS IT
LIFTED, THEY SHOULD JUST BE
ASKED, WOULD YOU LIKE US TO LIFT
YOUR CREDIT FREEZE AT 18? BUT
THAT'S ASSUMING THAT THEY KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE A CREDIT. WELL,
WELL, WELL, NO, THEY'RE ALL
GOING TO HAVE A CREDIT FREEZE
BECAUSE IT'S ALREADY FROZEN. SO
THIS IS WHY THEY'RE DOING IT. SO
PARTS OF THIS BILL IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE FILES ARE FROZEN
FOR THOSE IN FOSTER YOUTH. IF
YOU'RE 15 OR 16. SO ALL WE'RE
SAYING IS THAT LET THE FOSTER
YOUTH MAKE THAT DECISION. DO YOU
WANT US TO LIFT THE FREEZE AS
YOU'RE EXITING FOSTER YOUTH, OR
DO YOU WANT TO HAVE IT REMAIN IN
PLACE? WE'RE SAYING INSTEAD OF
AUTOMATICALLY RELEASING IT FOR
EVERYBODY, OKAY. AND IF I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY, THE, THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL
STATE THAT IT'S TOO MUCH THAT
THEY WOULD NOT BE FINANCIALLY
LITERATE TO KNOW THAT THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE A FREEZE, AND
NUMBER TWO, THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO DO IT. IS THAT
IS THAT WHAT I'M UNDERSTANDING?
IF A FRIENDLY AMENDMENT TO THAT
SENATOR, THE FREEZE COULD BE PUT
ON WHEN THEY'RE AN INFANT, THEY
MAY NOT REALLY KNOW. THEY MAY
LIVE THEIR WHOLE LIVES IN FOSTER
CARE, HAPPILY PROTECTED FROM
FURTHER IDENTITY THEFT IF THIS
BILL BECOMES LAW. BUT BY THE
TIME THEY TURN 18, THEY MAY NOT
EVEN HAVE BEEN AWARE THAT THE
FREEZE WAS PUT ON IN THE FIRST
PLACE, AND AGAIN, THE IDEA OF
GIVING THESE CHILDREN ANY MORE
ONE THING TO DO WHEN THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR FOOD AND SHELTER AND
ARE TERRIFIED WHEN WE CAN AND
WHEN THE BUREAUS DO LIFT FREEZES
BY DATE, CERTAIN FOR YOU AND ME,
IF WE HAVE THE SOPHISTICATION TO
ASK FOR THEM, THAT'S THE. OKAY,
SO, MADAM CHAIR, IF I MAY JUST
CLARIFY. YES. SO WE HAVE THE
ENACTED SECURITY OR FROZEN,
REQUIRED BY THE STATE TO DO
THAT. AND THEN, IN YOUR OPINION,
SHOULD END AUTOMATICALLY WITH
THE TIME THEY TURN 18, IT'S BEEN
MY EXPERIENCE IN THE PAST, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS MY FOURTH YEAR
HERE, THAT MANY OF THE BILLS
THAT WE'VE DONE IN ORDER TO
PROTECT OUR FOSTER YOUTH OR HAVE
BEEN EXPANDED UNTIL, PROBABLY
AGE 22, SOME, I THINK SOME 26
ARE SOME OF THE AGE EXPANSIONS
THAT WE'VE DONE EXPANDING SOME
OF THE PROTECTIONS FOR FOSTER
YOUTH. MÐI SO THE ONLY THING I
WOULD SAY TO COUNTER THAT, AND
MAYBE CONSIDER EVEN EXPANDING
IT, WOULD BE THAT IF THE STATE
IS PUTTING IN ALL OF THESE
PROTECTIONS ON THEIR BEHALF,
IT'S ALSO FALLS UPON THE STATE
TO LET THEM KNOW THIS IS, YOU
KNOW, YOU'RE ABOUT TO TURN 18.
THIS IS WHAT YOU YOU HAVE TO DO.
DO WE NOT HAVE ANYTHING IN PLACE
RIGHT NOW THAT ALLOWS. YES WE
HAVE PUBLIC LAW. ONE 1234 WHICH
REQUIRES, THAT AT AGE 16 THEY
RECEIVE A FREE COPY OF ANY
CREDIT REPORT PERTAINING TO
THEIR ANNUAL, TO YOUTH. SO ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS BASIS UNTIL THEY'RE
DISCHARGED. SO IT THERE'S AN
ASSUMPTION THERE THAT THEY
POTENTIALLY HAVE TO, CREDIT
REPORTS. NOW, THE QUESTION IS,
ONCE IT'S PROVIDED TO THEM, ARE
THEY GIVEN THE SUPPORT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT ACTUALLY IS,
BECAUSE THAT WOULD SHOW WHETHER
THERE'S A FREEZE ON THERE AND
THEN WHAT TO DO. OKAY. BUT THE
QUESTION IS THE WHAT TO DO IN
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM, THEIR FOSTER
CARE. WHO'S A PERSON THAT CARES
FOR THEM? THEY'RE NOT THE PARENT
SOCIAL WORKER. THE SOCIAL
WORKER. YEAH. SO CDSS, WE DON'T
HAVE CDSS HERE WITH US, TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE US A OF AN
OVERVIEW, YOU KNOW, I WILL SAY
THIS, THAT SOME LEGISLATION THAT
WE HAVE COMING TO US THIS YEAR
IS AROUND FINANCIAL LITERACY FOR
HIGH SCHOOL AGE. SO I WOULD EVEN
SAY JUST NON FOSTER YOUTH HAVE
ZERO IDEA WHAT A CREDIT REPORT
IS. AND THE IMPACT UNTIL THEY
HAVE TO USE IT FOR SOMETHING.
RIGHT. I THINK THERE'S, THERE'S
REAL EXTREME CASES AND I AND YOU
KNOW, I DO AGREE THAT THERE ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE, YOU KNOW, THEY
TRANSITION AT 18 AND WE EXPECT
THEM TO BE FULL FLEDGED ADULTS.
RIGHT? SO AND YOU AND I HAVE HAD
THESE CONVERSATIONS BEFORE. SO
WE HAVE ABSOLUTELY HAVE. OKAY. I
THINK I'M DONE. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, WELL,
IT IS QUITE INTERESTING AS I'M
NOT THE AUTHOR, BUT I'M HEARING
ALL OF THIS, SO I WOULD JUST
SIMPLY WEIGH IN THAT IT AGAIN
REMINDS ME OF WE EXPECT CERTAIN
THINGS AT CERTAIN MILESTONES,
BUT WE KNOW THAT THERE'S LOTS OF
REASONS THAT PEOPLE DON'T HIT
THOSE. AND I WOULD JUST COMPARE
IT TO VETERANS WHERE THEY LEAVE
WITH THIS MANY THINGS TO DO
RELATED TO EXITING AND ACCESSING
THEIR BENEFITS. AND THEN WE SAY,
WHY DIDN'T THEY DO ALL OF THOSE
THINGS? AND WHY DO WE HAVE
HOMELESS BENEFIT, HOMELESS
VETERANS AND MANY TIMES IT'S SO
MANY THINGS THAT THEY HAVE TO DO
THAT THEY DON'T EVEN DO, YOU
KNOW, ITEMS ONE, TWO AND THREE.
AND I 1,000% AGREE THAT FOSTER
YOUTH LEAVING. THEY SIMPLY DON'T
HAVE THE SUPPORT SYSTEMS THAT
OUR OWN CHILDREN HAVE. THEY
DON'T HAVE A MOM OR DAD AFTER
THEY'RE 18 SAYING, HEY, DID YOU
DO THAT? AND SO FORTH. AND YET
WE CAN'T EVEN ASSUME THAT THEY
HAVE A CELL PHONE OR INTERNET TO
GET ON A COMPUTER TO DO ALL
THESE THINGS. SO ANYTHING WE CAN
DO TO GET THEM OFF ON THE RIGHT
TRACK AFTER THEY TURN 18, I
SUPPORT, AND I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL SUPPORT IT AS WELL. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY.
ARE WE READY TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION, I WILL OKAY. OKAY. I
HEARD SENATOR TROBOK WITH A
MOTION OVER HERE TO THE RIGHT.
OKAY, SO SYSTEM, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OKAY FILE ITEM 24, BILL
NUMBER AB 2935. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS. ALVARADO. GILL. Dð.
PASSWORD IS GOING TO THE FLOOR.
OH. DO PASS THROUGH THE FLOOR.
WOW. OKAY. IT GOES RIGHT AT THE
FLOOR. YEAH, I ALVARADO GILL I
ALVARADO GILL I OCHOA BOGUE I
AKABOGU I SO TWO THAT'S TWO EYES
AND WE'LL LEAVE THAT THAT OPEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. OKAY ALL RIGHT, I
THINK I SAW. OH SOMEBODY. MEMBER
CALDERON. WELCOME WE'LL HAVE YOU
COME FORWARD. JUST MAKE SURE,
20. WE HAVE TWO BILLS TODAY.
ITEM NUMBER 20, ASSEMBLY BILL
2752 AND ITEM NUMBER 21,
ASSEMBLY BILL 3193. WE'LL HAVE
YOU START WITH ITEM NUMBER 20
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. AND
SENATOR, I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING MY STAFF ON THIS BILL.
AB 2752. I WILL BE ACCEPTING ALL
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
ASSEMBLY. ASSEMBLY BILL 2752
WOULD REQUIRE THE JUVENILE COURT
TO SET THE FREQUENCY AND
DURATION OF FAMILY VISITATION AT
THE INITIAL PETITION HEARING.
WHEN A CHILD IS FIRST PLACED IN
THE CALIFORNIA WELFARE SERVICES
SYSTEM AT SUBSEQUENT HEARINGS,
THE BILL REQUIRES A COURT TO
ORDER UNDER SUPERVISED FAMILY
VISITS UNLESS THE COURT FINDS
THAT UNSUPERVISED VISITATION
WILL HARM THE PHYSICAL OR
EMOTIONAL HEALTH OF THE CHILD.
WITH ME, IN SUPPORT OF AB 2752
IS JULIA HANNIGAN, WHO SERVES AS
A POLICY DIRECTOR AND LEAD
ATTORNEY FOR DEPENDENCY LEGAL
SERVICES, AND DAVE SCHUSTER, THE
MENTOR PROGRAM MANAGER FOR
DEPENDENCY ADVOCACY CENTER. A
COPY OF THESE CONFIRM THAT'S
WHAT SHE MEANS. HELLO WELCOME.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS JULIE
HANNIGAN, AND I AM THE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR DEPENDENCY LEGAL
SERVICES. WE REPRESENT PARENTS
AND CHILDREN IN SIX COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST 12
YEARS, I HAVE REPRESENTED
PARENTS AND CHILDREN IN JUVENILE
DEPENDENCY COURT. THROUGHOUT
THESE COUNTIES. DEPENDENCY LEGAL
SERVICES IS PROUD TO CO-SPONSOR
AB 2752 FAMILY SEPARATION
INFLICTS PROFOUND DAMAGE ON
CHILDREN AND PARENTS. CHILDREN
OFTEN EXPERIENCE FEAR, ANXIETY,
SADNESS, ANGER, AND CONFUSION.
VISITATION IS NOT ONLY THE
LINCHPIN OF SUCCESSFUL
REUNIFICATION AND RESTORATION OF
THE FAMILY UNIT, BUT IT IS ALSO
CRITICAL TO MITIGATING THE
TRAUMA OF FAMILY SEPARATION FOR
CHILDREN BY ENSURING THAT
CHILDREN IN CARE CONTINUE TO
HAVE MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO THE
PEOPLE THEY KNOW AND LOVE MOST
THEIR PARENTS, FAMILY TIME
PROMOTES REPAIR AND STABILITY
FOR AND FOSTERS HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS AND ATTACHMENTS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW, THERE IS
ALMOST NO GUIDANCE FOR THE
COURTS REGARDING VISITATION AS A
RESULT, COURTS OFTEN DEFAULT TO
SUPERVISED VISITATION ORDERS,
WHICH ARE OFTEN UNNECESSARILY
RESTRICTIVE, DIFFICULT TO
SCHEDULE, UNCOMFORTABLE AND
UNNATURAL FOR FAMILIES, AND
COSTLY FOR THE DEPARTMENT WITH
THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS, THE
LANGUAGE OF 2752 MIRRORS THE
FEDERAL GUIDELINES PUT OUT BY
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES ADMINISTRATION ON
CHILDREN, YOUTH AND FAMILIES
REGARDING VISIT SUPERVISION. THE
GUIDELINES HIGHLIGHT THAT
CHILDREN WITH MORE FREQUENT
CONTACT WITH FAMILY HAVE
IMPROVED WELL-BEING, FEWER
BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS, HIGHER
REUNIFICATION RATES, AND
EXPEDITED TIME TO PERMANENCY.
THE FEDERAL GUIDANCE ALSO MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE FOR VISITATION IS TO
FACILITATE FAMILY TIME. IT IS
NOT TO ASSESS OR TEST PARENTS.
THAT SAID, THERE IS NOTHING IN
THIS BILL THAT WOULD PROHIBIT
THE DEPARTMENT FROM SCHEDULING
TIME TO OBSERVE AND ASSESS
PARENT CHILD INTERACTION. THERE
IS ALSO NOTHING IN THIS BILL
THAT WOULD PROHIBIT DEPARTMENTS
IN THE APPROPRIATE CASE FOR
RECOMMENDING SERVICES, AS PART
OF THE CASE PLAN, SERVICES
DESIGNED AND PROVEN TO ADDRESS
PARENT AND CHILD INTERACTIONS,
SUCH AS PARENT CHILD INTERACTIVE
THERAPY, FAMILY TIME VISITATION
SHOULD ONLY BE SUPERVISED WHEN
NECESSARY TO PROTECT THE CHILD
IN REUNIFICATION FROM A PRESENT
DANGER OF HARM, WHICH IS THE
STANDARD IN AB 2752. FOR THESE
REASONS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. ROGER. GOOD
AFTERNOON, HONORABLE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
DAVE SCHUSTER. I'M A FORMER
PARENT IN THE DEPENDENCY SYSTEM
AND NOW MANAGE A DEPENDENCY
ADVOCACY CENTERS MENTOR PARENT
PROGRAM. I BROUGHT MY DAUGHTER
WITH ME TODAY, I WOULD LIKE TO
DISCUSS MY PERSONAL OUR PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH VISITATION AND
ITS IMPACT ON MY FAMILY, WHICH
UNDERSCORES WHY VOTING AYE ON AB
2750 52 IS SO IMPORTANT. WHEN MY
DAUGHTER WAS IN THE SYSTEM, WE
WERE TOLD VISITS HAD TO BE
MONITORED AND WERE FOR SEVEN
MONTHS. THIS WAS COMPLETELY
UNWARRANTED AND THE TRAUMA FROM
THIS EXPERIENCE STILL HAUNTS HER
TODAY. OUR VISITS WERE DONE IN
AN OLD OFFICE BUILDING WITH
BROKEN TOYS AND BOOKS WITH PAGES
MISSING. WE FELT WE COULDN'T
COMPLAIN. WE WERE FINALLY ABLE
TO HUG OUR CHILD AND DIDN'T WANT
TO RISK THIS IN ANY WAY. SOME OF
THE OFFICES HAD WINDOWS, AND I'M
NOT SURE IF THIS WAS A GOOD
THING, BECAUSE IT WAS A CONSTANT
REMINDER OF WHAT WE USED TO DO
AS A FAMILY AND FEARED WE WOULD
NEVER DO AGAIN. I WOULD VISIT
WITH MY SEVEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER
TWO TIMES A WEEK, TWO HOURS FOR
EACH VISIT. HER MOTHER THE SAME,
BUT SEPARATELY. DESPITE BEING AN
INTACT COUPLE WITH NO HISTORY OF
DV KEEPING A VERY ACTIVE CHILD
OCCUPIED FOR TWO HOURS FOR EACH
VISIT, ESPECIALLY WITH LIMITED
SPACE AND ACTIVITIES, WAS AN
UNFAIR AND RIDICULOUS TEST OF
PARENTING. OUR DAUGHTER WAS MOST
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE MONITORS
OF THE VISIT. THEY SAT IN THE
DOOR WITH WITH THE COMPUTER,
TYPING EVERY WORD SIT BETWEEN
US. SHE WITHDREW EVEN MORE. SHE
WOULD WHISPER TO ME, DADDY, WHY
ARE THEY HERE? JUST TO BE TOLD
YOU CAN'T WHISPER, SPEAK UP. SO
SHE JUST WOULDN'T TALK. I HAVE
NEVER FELT SO POWERLESS AND
SHAMEFUL AND RIDDLED WITH GUILT,
SINCE THEY'RE SINCE THEY WERE
THERE. WE WERE THERE BECAUSE OF
OUR ACTIONS AND OUR ADDICTION.
UNFORTUNATELY, MY CHILD PAID THE
PRICE FOR THIS DESPITE TESTING
CLEAN AND COMPLYING WITH THEIR
CASE PLAN, SUPERVISED VISITATION
AT THE DEPARTMENT CONTINUED FOR
SEVEN MONTHS. AT ANY POINT, MY
PARENTS, WITH WHOM MY DAUGHTER
WAS PLACED WITH, COULD HAVE
SUPERVISOR VISITS IN THEIR HOME
OR AT A NEARBY PARK. THESE
SUGGESTIONS WERE ALWAYS
DISREGARDED BY THE DEPARTMENT
AND WERE TOLD IT'S NOT YET TIME.
AB 2752 AND ENSURE THAT WHAT
HAPPENED IN MY CASE WOULD NOT
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN TO OTHER
FAMILIES. BUT I ON AB 2752 TO
PROTECT THE CHILD'S RIGHT TO
FAMILY TIME. SHE IS OKAY. DO YOU
WANT HER TO SIT WITH YOU UP
HERE? WOULD YOU LIKE TO SIT WITH
ME? YOU'RE RIGHT OVER THERE.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT, YOU KNOW?
YES. YEAH. VERY GOOD. OKAY. ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR
TODAY'S, ASSEMBLY BILL, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. HI ANNIE THOMAS,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND CORRECTIONS LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT, ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE
HEARD, PLEASE? YEAH.
WELCOME TURN IT OFF. THERE WE
GO. HI. GOOD EVENING, MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS AMANDA
KIRSCH, ON BEHALF OF COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE STILL IN OPPOSITION ON
THE BILL, WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO ESSENTIALLY FIND THE RIGHT
STANDARD TO USE WHEN TRYING TO
MEET SUPERVISED VISITATION
REQUIREMENTS. AND SO WE'VE BEEN
IN ACTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
MISS CALDERON STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS TO TRY AND FIND THE
CORRECT LANGUAGE, WE HAVE A MOCK
UP OF A MOST RECENT ATTEMPT THAT
WE ARE STILL WORKING THROUGH.
AND SO UNTIL WE UNFORTUNATELY
KIND OF LAND ON THAT, WE'RE
GOING TO BE IN OPPOSITION. BUT
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT OUR MAIN
CONCERN IS WHEN WE TALK TO OUR
SOCIAL WORKERS, WHEN WE TALK TO
OUR DIRECTORS, THEY FEEL THAT
THE MOST RECENT, EVEN LANGUAGE
AROUND HAVING A PRESENT DANGER
IS TOO RESTRICTIVE BECAUSE THERE
ARE TIMES WHEN A PARENT MAY HAVE
SO LITTLE SKILLS IN PARENTING
THAT THE SOCIAL WORKER
ESSENTIALLY SUPERVISES, BUT ALSO
GUIDES THEM THROUGH THE
INTERACTIONS, ESPECIALLY FOR
YOUNGER CHILDREN AND INFANTS,
HOW THEY SHOULD BE INTERACTING
WITH THE CHILD, HOW THEY SHOULD
BE CARING WITH THE CHILD. THIS
HELPS CREATE TRUST BETWEEN THE
SOCIAL WORKER AND THE PARENT. IT
HELPS SPONSOR THE RELATIONSHIP
AND EVENTUALLY WE THINK DOES
ACTUALLY LEAD TO BETTER CASE
PLANS AND REUNIFICATION, BECAUSE
YOU'VE SORT OF ESTABLISHED THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AND CAN MOVE THEN
FROM SUPERVISED TO EITHER
OBSERVED OR UNSUPERVISED
THROUGHOUT THE REST OF THE
PROCESS. BUT RIGHT NOW, WITH THE
STANDARD AS IT IS AND IT BEING
SUCH AN EARLY PART IN THE
PROCESS, OUR FOLKS ARE NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH THE STANDARD AS
WRITTEN, AND WOULD LIKE TO SEE
SOMETHING THAT'S A BIT LOWER
THAN THAT. SO WITH THAT, WE ARE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF,
THEY'VE BEEN VERY RESPONSIVE AND
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. BUT
STILL, IN OPPOSITION. OKAY.
GREAT. THANK YOU. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL MOVE THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO COMMITTEE.
I JUST WANTED TO DOUBLE CHECK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON. YOU
SAID SOMETHING ABOUT ACCEPTED
AMENDMENTS, WE'RE CONFUSED OVER
HERE, SO HELP ME. I KNOW SOME
AMENDMENTS WERE IN THE LAST
COMMITTEE, BEFORE I THINK THAT
WAS FROM THE LAST COMMITTEE.
OKAY. SORRY, I MISSPOKE. YEAH.
IT WAS. YEAH. OKAY. THAT'S
RIGHT. WE WERE MOVING PAPERS. WE
DID? YEAH, IN SENATE JUDICIARY.
CHAIR UMBERG OFFERED AMENDMENTS,
AND I ACCEPTED ALL OF THEM. AND
JUDICI. YES. OKAY. ALL RIGHT, SO
THERE IS NO NOTHING CHANGED FROM
JUDICIARY TO US? NO. OKAY.
GREAT. THANK YOU. OKAY. SORRY.
NO, NO, DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
WE'RE WE'RE ALL IN IT TOGETHER,
SO. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS FROM HØI. SENATOR
BLAKESPEAR. HELLO. WELCOME.
THANK YOU. YES THANK YOU, CHAIR,
IT'S OKAY IF I MAKE A COMMENT OR
TWO. OKAY. THANK YOU FOR THIS,
BILL. AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT YOUR YOUR WITNESS WAS HAD
VERY COMPELLING TESTIMONY THAT
WAS VERY MOVING AND REALLY SHOWS
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL. I JUST
TO THE OPPOSITION WITNESS, I
JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THIS IS A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION. SO IF THERE IS AN
INFANT OR SOMEBODY IS UNFAMILIAR
WITH HOW TO BE WITH CHILDREN, OR
THEY HAVE OTHER PROBLEMS, YOU
KNOW, THE DECISION COULD BE MADE
THAT IT WOULD BE SUPERVISED, BUT
THE PRESUMPTION WOULD BE THAT IT
WOULDN'T BE SO TO ME, THAT DOES
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE. BUT I
JUST WANTED TO SEE IF YOU WANTED
TO ADDRESS THAT DIRECTLY,
BECAUSE I THINK THERE ARE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE MAYBE IT
WOULD BE ORDERED TO BE
SUPERVISED, BUT IT DOES. IT'S
JUST NOT NEEDED FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF VISITS. YES. NO.
HAPPY TO, THROUGH THE CHAIR. SO
WE DON'T MIND THE REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION AND HAVING A
PRESUMPTION FOR UNSUPERVISED
VISITATION. A NUMBER OF OUR
COUNTIES ARE ALREADY USING BEST
PRACTICES TO TRY AND MITIGATE
FROM UNSUPERVISED, AND THEN
JUDGE SAFETY AND OTHER CONCERNS.
WHAT OUR CONCERN WITH IS THE
STANDARD FOR GETTING OVER THE
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION, IN OTHER
STATES SUCH AS GEORGIA, WHICH IS
ONE OF THE ONES THAT IS LISTED
IN THE FEDERAL REPORT ON THIS
OUT OF ACF, THE STANDARD IS BEST
INTEREST OF THE CHILD. IF THAT
WAS OUR STANDARD, THEN WE WOULD
HAPPILY REMOVE OUR OUR
OPPOSITION. BUT RIGHT NOW WE
THINK THAT THAT SORT OF PRESENT
DANGER OR SOME SORT OF SAFETY
RISK AROUND A PHYSICAL HARM IS
TOO NARROWING AND IT'S TOO
LIMITING BECAUSE THERE MAY BE
OTHER CONCERNS THAT WE WANT TO
MITIGATE AND THINK THROUGH.
OKAY. THANK YOU. AND WHEN THE
TIME COMES, I WILL MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH. OTHER
QUESTIONS, CONCERNS OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, YES. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'VE
GOT A MOTION FROM SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER. ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FILE ITEM 20 A B 2752.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO GIL A ALVARADO GIL, A
AQUEBOGUE. BLAKE. SPEER, BLAKE.
SPEER, I LIMÓN MENGIBAR I
MENGIBAR I. THE VOTE IS THREE
EYES NO NO'S. WE WILL LEAVE THAT
ON CALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
YOU HAVE ONE MORE WITH US. ITEM
NUMBER 21, ASSEMBLY BILL 3193.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
SENATORS, AB 3193 WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION TO AWARD
CONTRACTS FOR ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY WITHOUT COMPETITION
OR ADVERTISING. IF THE VALUE OF
THE PURCHASE IS LESS THAN
$25,000. ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGIES
CAN FUNDAMENTALLY IMPROVE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR A PERSON
WITH DISABILITIES. THEY CAN
RANGE FROM SOMETHING AS SIMPLE
AS A WHEELCHAIR TO A MORE
COMPLEX TECHNOLOGY, SUCH AS A
SPEECH RECOGNITION SOFTWARE.
THERE IS A LACK OF VENDORS FOR
SEVERAL KINDS OF TECHNOLOGIES.
FURTHERMORE THE STATE HAS
STRUGGLED FOR DECADES TO OBTAIN
SUFFICIENT BIDS FOR A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS TO TAKE
PLACE. THIS HAS RESULTED IN
DELAYED PURCHASES IMPACTING THE
DAILY LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
RELY ON THESE DEVICES. AB 3193
ENSURES THAT ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY, DEVICES AND SERVICES
ARE PROCURED IN A TIMELY MANNER.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
ON THIS BILL AND SHOULD THIS
BILL MOVE FORWARD, I PLAN TO
AMEND THE BILL AND SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
EXPAND THE REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCLUDE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE CONTRACTING
EXEMPTIONS HERE WITH ME TODAY,
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB 3193
ARE PATRICIA LEACH, RETIRED
SUPERVISOR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION AND REGINA
BRINK, THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF THE BLIND.
OKAY. THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING
HERE. AND YOU'LL EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE
READY. OKAY. I'LL START AND GOOD
EVENING. AND THANK YOU, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS PATRICIA LEETZ. AND I
WORKED AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION FOR OVER 20
YEARS. I WAS A VOCATIONAL
COUNSELOR, AND THEN A
SUPERVISOR. AND I HELP PEOPLE
WHO ARE BLIND TO BE EMPLOYED.
AND OVER THAT TIME, THERE WAS
THIS CUMBERSOME PROCUREMENT
PROCESS, AND IT HAD LED TO
DELAYS IN OBTAINING PEOPLE'S
ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL AND TO
WORK, TWO RECENT STORIES I'LL
SHARE WITH YOU. ONE OF THEM WAS
FROM, A VOCATIONAL COUNSELOR WHO
WORKS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION, AND HE TOLD ME
THAT, A MAN ON HIS CASELOAD WAS
GIVEN A POOR JOB PERFORMANCE
REVIEW. AND THIS WAS ALL DUE TO
THE DELAYS IN THE PROCUREMENT
PROCESS. HE HAD NOT RECEIVED HIS
TECHNOLOGY IN ORDER TO PERFORM
ON HIS JOB IN A TIMELY MANNER.
AND THEN ANOTHER WOMAN ON HIS
CASELOAD STATED THAT SHE HAD
GONE THROUGH UNNECESSARY
SUFFERING. AND THIS IS ALL DUE
TO THE DELAYS IN THE PROCUREMENT
PROCESS. SHE DID NOT RECEIVE HER
TECHNOLOGY IN A TIMELY MANNER.
IN ORDER FOR HER TO PERFORM ON
HER JOB AND HER BOSS WAS UPSET,
HER COWORKERS WERE UPSET. THEY
HAD TO TAKE ON MORE WORK IN THE
WORKPLACE, AND THEN SHE MISSED
OUT ON ADVANCEMENT OPPORTUNITIES
IN THAT WORK SETTING. SO WITH
ALL OF THIS, I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL. THE CLIENTS, THEY
DESERVE TO HAVE A SYSTEM THAT'S
DESIGNED TO WORK IN THEIR FAVOR
SO THEY CAN BE EMPLOYED. THANK
YOU. MY TURN. YES. YOU'RE READY.
OKAY. CHAIR ALVARADO GILL AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AS,
PATRICIA STATED, THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF THE BLIND IS BRINGING
FORTH THIS BILL BECAUSE IT HAS
ASKED FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE
THERE'S A CONVOLUTED BIDDING
REQUIREMENTS AND THE PRODUCTS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MAY
HAVE ONLY 1 OR 2 VENDORS THAT
THEY CAN BE OBTAINED FROM THEIR
SPECIFIC TO THE PERSON'S
DISABILITY. SO AS AN EXAMPLE, IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A LOW VISION
AID AND YOU HAVE LOW VISION AND
I HAVE LOW VISION, OUR AIDES MAY
BE DRASTICALLY DIFFERENT BECAUSE
OUR EYE CONDITIONS ARE SO
SPECIFIC AND THERE'S A LOT OF
THEM. AND SO THE PEOPLE THAT
MAKE THESE AREN'T THERE AREN'T
THAT MANY, VENDORS. AND SO BUT
HAVING TO PUT IT OUT FOR BID, IT
, IT, MESSES UP THE TIMELINESS
OF IT, IT ALSO CAUSES ANXIETY ON
BEHALF OF THE WORKER. AND I
ACTUALLY EXPERIENCED THIS WHERE
I DID GET A JOB THROUGH THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION, HELPING ME LOOK
FOR A JOB. AND I WAS FAIRLY
YOUNG. I WAS OUT OF COLLEGE AND
I HAD DONE WORK, STUDY, BUT
NEVER A REAL JOB. AND SO WHEN I
APPLIED, I WAS OVERJOYED. I
CALLED ALL MY FAMILY MEMBERS I
HAD A JOB. I WAS SO HAPPY, AND I
ACTUALLY NEVER, NEVER WAS ABLE
TO BE EMPLOYED BECAUSE THE
EQUIPMENT DID NOT COME. AND THAT
PRIVATE EMPLOYER SAID, WE CAN'T
KEEP YOUR JOB OPEN ANYMORE. AND
CAN YOU IMAGINE FOR SOMEONE
THAT'S JUST FRESH OUT OF
COLLEGE, THAT WAS SO
DISCOURAGING FOR ME. I CAN'T
EXPRESS THAT ENOUGH. SO THIS HAS
REAL LIFE EFFECTS AND EMPLOYMENT
FOR PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES IS
JUST INVALUABLE RIGHT NOW FOR
BLIND PEOPLE. IT'S OVER 70%
UNEMPLOYMENT AND THAT'S PEOPLE
THAT EXPRESS THE DESIRE TO WORK.
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW
ISN'T WORKING. AND I THINK THIS
IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND I URGE YOU TO
PASS AB 3193. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY,
WE'LL OPEN IT UP TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT. PLEASE
COME FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE.
GOOD EVENING, TONY ANDERSON,
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD
TODAY? OKAY. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION? OKAY.
WE'LL BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO COMMITTEE, HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR CHOBOT. QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS? ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION. ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLE FILE ITEM 21 AB 3193.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO GIL A, ALVARADO GIL I
AQUEBOGUE I AKABOGU I BLAKE
SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR I LIMÓN
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR. AYE. FOUR
EYES, NO NOSE. WE'LL LEAVE THAT
ON CALL. I APOLOGIZE I DID NOT
ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE. THAT'S OKAY.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU. I GOT
TO PUT A LITTLE, LITTLE POST-IT
RIGHT HERE. YEAH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY.
ALL RIGHT, I SEE WE HAVE ANOTHER
AUTHOR IN THE ROOM. SOME MEMBERS
OF BR. ARE YOU READY TO PRESENT?
EXCELLENT. WE'LL BE HEARING ITEM
NUMBER 19, ASSEMBLY BILL 20 704.
AUTHOR. GOOD EVENING, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M PROUD
TODAY TO PRESENT AB 2704,
SPONSORED BY UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS, AC LOCAL 3009 30 AND
ASKED ME CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL
WILL HELP STREAMLINE ENTRY INTO
THE IN-HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES,
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS IHS
WORKFORCE. THERE ARE NUMEROUS
BARRIERS TO ENTER THE IHS
WORKFORCE, ONE OF WHICH ARE THE
FEES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
FINGERPRINTING AND CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECK PROCESSES FOR
PROSPECTIVE IHS PROVIDERS. SOME
WORKFORCES, SUCH AS NONPROFIT
HUMAN RESOURCE AGENCIES AND
NONPROFIT YOUTH ORGANIZATIONS,
ARE ABLE TO WAIVE THE COSTS OF
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR
PROSPECTIVE WORKERS, WHILE
OTHERS MAY HAVE BILLING ACCOUNTS
SET UP AS A WAY FOR APPLICANTS
TO COMPLETE THE BACKGROUND CHECK
AND FINGERPRINTING PROCESS AT A
LIVE SCAN SITE. CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES THAT PROSPECTIVE IHS
PROVIDERS NOT ALREADY ON A
REGISTRY TO COMPLETE
FINGERPRINTING, AND A CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECK AS PART OF THE
PROVIDER ENROLLMENT PROCESS. THE
FEES ASSOCIATED WITH
FINGERPRINTING AND BACKGROUND
CHECKS ARE CURRENTLY BORNE BY
THE APPLICANT, RATHER THAN THE
EMPLOYER OR THE COUNTY. THIS IS
AN UNJUST PRACTICE AND A BARRIER
TO PROVIDING NEEDED CARE TO
UNFAIRLY BURDEN WORKERS WHO WILL
BE MAKING JUST OVER MINIMUM
WAGE. WITH THE COST OF THESE
BACKGROUND CHECKS, ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT'S COMMON PRACTICE THAT
THE FEES ARE BORNE BY EMPLOYERS
AND PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIPS, AB 2704
ALLEVIATES THE FINANCIAL BURDEN
ON PROSPECTIVE IHS PROVIDERS BY
SHIFTING THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
COVERING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS FROM THE
PROSPECTIVE ISIS PROVIDER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. THE IHS
PROGRAM IS A VITAL LIFELINE FOR
OVER 74 740,000 CALIFORNIANS,
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL DOMESTIC
LONG TERM CARE SERVICES WHICH
EQUIP LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS TO
REMAIN SAFELY IN THEIR OWN
HOMES, ENSURE THAT THEY RECEIVE
LIFE SAVING CARE, AND EMPOWERS
THEM TO LIVE WITH DIGNITY. BY
2030, THERE WILL BE OVER 1
MILLION INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL
NEED LONG TERM CARE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS, PRIMARILY THROUGH IHS,
REMOVING BARRIERS TO ENTRY INTO
THIS WORKFORCE WOULD BE A
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE, SHOULD
BE A PRIORITY FOR THE STATE, AND
THIS BILL FURTHERS THAT GOAL BY
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS TO
RECRUIT IHS PROVIDERS. PROMOTE
GROWTH. GROWTH IN THIS VITAL
WORKFORCE BY EASING THE BURDENS
ON UNDERGOING THE IHS PROVIDER
ENROLLMENT PROCESS. THIS BILL
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS
NO RECORDED OPPOSITION AND I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME WITH ME TODAY.
ARE MALIK BYNUM, ASSISTANT
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR UW,
ASKED ME LOCAL 3930, AND JANICE
O'MALLEY, LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FOR ACP CALIFORNIA OR
CO-SPONSORS OF THE BILL. AND TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
THANK YOU. WELCOME, BOTH. I'LL
GIVE YOU TWO MINUTES EACH. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S VERNON.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, FOR THE
HEARING TODAY. MY NAME IS MALIK
BYNUM WITH THE UNITED ETHNIC
WORKERS, AFSCME LOCAL 3930,
REPRESENTING OVER 180,000 HOME
CARE AND FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE.
ABSOLUTELY HONORED TO BE HERE.
SPONSORING AB 2704, A BILL THAT
SEEKS TO BUILD UP THE IHS
WORKFORCE BY BREAKING DOWN A
FINANCIAL BARRIER TO ENTRY THAT
IS THE BACKGROUND CHECK FEE FOR
PROSPECTIVE PROVIDERS. IT'S A
SECRET TO NOBODY HERE THAT THE
IHS WORKFORCE HAS LONG BEEN
UNDERSTAFFED, OVERWORKED AND
UNDERSERVED SINCE THE BEGINNING.
THERE'S OVER 760,000 AGENT
DISABLED RECIPIENTS RECEIVING
IHS IN CALIFORNIA, YET THE
PROGRAM JUST HAS ONLY OVER
670,000 HOME CARE WORKERS TO
PROVIDE THIS CARE. OF COURSE,
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES IS
THE NATURE OF PROVIDING HOME
CARE. IT'S TREMENDOUSLY TEDIOUS.
IT'S DIFFICULT. IT'S NOT
ATTRACTIVE BY ANY MEANS, BUT IT
IS A VITAL RESOURCE FOR HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES WHO
RELY ON THIS CARE EACH AND EVERY
DAY FOR THEIR LOVED ONES. IN
ADDITION TO THE DEMANDING NATURE
OF PROVIDING IHS, THIS IS A
WORKFORCE THAT'S MADE UP
PRIMARILY OF WOMEN OF COLOR WHO
ARE MAKING JUST OVER MINIMUM
WAGE. IN MANY CASES, AS WE KNOW,
THERE'S OTHER WORKFORCES WHO
DON'T HAVE DOJ BACKGROUND OR WHO
DO HAVE DOJ BACKGROUND CHECK FEE
WAIVERS IN PLACE. AS THE AUTHOR
STATED, LIKE NONPROFIT EMPLOYEES
AND THOSE AT YOUTH ORGANIZATIONS
, HOWEVER, OUR HOME CARE WORKERS
DO NOT HAVE SUCH LUXURY. THEY
SIMPLY HAVE TO EAT THIS COST AS
A PREREQUISITE TO EMPLOYMENT
CONSIDERATION WHEN THEY
OTHERWISE COULD HAVE USED IT FOR
ESSENTIAL EXPENSES FOR
THEMSELVES OR BETTER YET, THEIR
RECIPIENT. THIS IS A PREEXISTING
ISSUE, AMONGST MANY OTHER
REASONS, WHY WE'RE STRUGGLING TO
RECRUIT IHS WORKERS INTO THE
PROGRAM. HOWEVER, THIS IS ONE
THAT CAN START TO BE ADDRESSED
WITH THE SIMPLE FIX OF REMOVING
THIS FEE. CALIFORNIA HAS A DUTY
TO ITS MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS TO ENSURE THEY'RE
BEING CARED FOR IN THE WAY THAT
THEY NEED TO IN ORDER TO LIVE
COMFORTABLY. BUT IN ORDER TO DO
THAT, OUR STATE NEEDS TO
ADEQUATE PROVIDER WORKFORCE. WE
SEE THE REMOVAL OF THE DOJ
BACKGROUND CHECK FEE AS A MAJOR
FIRST STEP IN PROVIDING
IMPROVING PROVIDER RECRUITMENT
EFFORTS. IN A TIME WHERE WE'RE
SEEING A VAST AMOUNT OF
RECIPIENT GROWTH WITHIN THE
PROGRAM AND WITH FOR THESE
REASONS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING.
CHAIR MEMBERS JANICE O'MALLEY,
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH AFSCME
CALIFORNIA. JUST HERE AS AS
PROUD CO-SPONSORS. TRULY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. AND
THE COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS OF THE
BILL. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE THAT ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. WHITE AND SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. JIM
ROTHSCHILD, CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IHSS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AMANDA COURCHENE WITH
CWA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE
HEARD, MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR CONCERNS. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS DO WE HAVE A MOTION
MOVED BY SENATOR MENGIBAR,
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS SUPPORT. I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU KNOW THIS, BUT I
USED TO BE A HOME CARE PROVIDER
UNDER IHSS. YES. AND I WAS A
LEAD NEGOTIATOR FOR FIVE
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA FOR IHSS
WORKERS. SO I HAVE A VERY SOFT
SPOT THERE. IF YOU DO THE MATH
ON THE COST OF FINGERPRINTING
VERSUS THE HOURLY WAGE IN
CALIFORNIA, YOU HAVE TO WORK AT
LEAST THREE HOURS JUST TO BE
ABLE TO PAY FOR THAT. THAT IS
INSANE. SO, SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FORWARD THIS BILL, AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO IHSS REFORM IN
MY LIFETIME. SO WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR MENGIBAR. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE BEFORE WE TAKE
THE, ROLL? NO, I MEAN, I BECAME
INTERESTED IN IHSS WHEN MY
SISTER WAS WAS ILL WITH ALS AND
REALIZED HOW MUCH WE NEED TO
REFORM THE SYSTEM. AND THIS IS
JUST ONE SMALL STEP THAT WE CAN
TAKE TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE WHO WANT TO PROVIDE
THIS CARE, OFTEN JUST ABOVE
MINIMUM WAGE, DON'T HAVE THE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO ENTER
THIS WORKFORCE. SO THANK YOU. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
EXCELLENT SO, ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM 19 AB 20
704. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO GIL A ALVARADO GIL I
OTTOBOCK. OTTOBOCK I BLAKE.
SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR I LIMÓN.
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I. THAT'S
FOUR EYES AND NO NOSE. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE. YOU BUT IF WE DON'T HAVE
THE. OKAY, ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
CALLING FOR AUTHORS IN ROOM 2200
BECAUSE WE'RE ABOUT TO WRAP THIS
PUPPY UP, SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR PRESENTING
TODAY. ITEM NUMBER 12, ASSEMBLY
BILL 2338, ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
ALL RIGHT. WHEN YOU'RE READY.
OKAY THANK YOU. CHAIR. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS, I PRESENT AB 2338
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JOAN SAWYER, WHICH STRENGTHENS
CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS BY ESTABLISHING A
STATEWIDE HOMELESSNESS
COORDINATOR AS THE LEAD ENTITY
FOR ENDING HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA. DESPITE THE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS INVESTED TO ASSIST
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND SUPPORT
HOUSING PROGRAMS, WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE NATION'S LARGEST
HOMELESS POPULATION. THIS IS IN
PART DUE TO THE STATE'S
SEGMENTED APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS. AB 2338 WILL
ENSURE INTERGOVERNMENTAL
COORDINATION TO END HOMELESSNESS
BY REQUIRING THE GOVERNOR TO
APPOINT A STATEWIDE HOMELESSNESS
COORDINATOR TO SET GOALS TO END
HOMELESSNESS AND OVERSEE THE
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAM. SERVICES,
DATA AND POLICIES THAT TRANSFER
BETWEEN FEDERAL, STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES. THIS BILL PROVIDES THE
COORDINATOR FLEXIBILITY TO
IDENTIFY A LOCAL LEADER AND THE
APPROPRIATE JURISDICTION TO
SERVE AS A LIAISON TO THE STATE
AND IN COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL
LEADERS, THE COORDINATOR WILL
PROVIDE ANNUAL RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR WHILE THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT OVERLAP IN A LOT OF
EXISTING RESOURCES, MANY TIMES
WE SEE INDIVIDUALS GOING TO
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND LOSING
VALUABLE TIME WHEN THEY COULD
HAVE RECEIVED HELP. AB 233,
EIGHT IS ABOUT PUTTING A SINGLE
PERSON IN CHARGE SO THAT
SOMEBODY OWNS THE PROBLEM SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN LOOK TO THIS
PERSON FOR GUIDANCE. AND THIS IS
NOT ABOUT CREATING A NEW
BUREAUCRACY. IN CLOSING, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. ANY
WITNESSES WITH YOU TODAY? ALL
RIGHT. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WANTING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL? 2338 ALL RIGHT. ANY
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
OKAY. NO ONE'S MOVING ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL COME RIGHT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS I HAVE A
QUESTION, MA'AM. OKAY. SENATOR
THANK YOU. AND I'M NOT SURE IF
YOU KNOW, REMINDER, BUT I DID
HAVE A QUESTION. TO THE ACTUAL
AUTHOR, WITH REGARDS, I'M. FIRST
OF ALL, I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERING, PLACING THE
LANGUAGE WITH REGARDS TO, HAVING
IT A CONFIRMED POSITION BY THE
LEGISLATURE. BUT THE OTHER
THOUGHT THAT CAME TO MIND WAS
WHETHER OR NOT. AND THIS ALSO
COMES FROM THE OTHER PREVIOUS
BILLS THAT WE'VE SEEN WITH
CREATING COMMISSIONS AND, YOU
KNOW, OTHER, OTHER ROLES IN
GOVERNMENT. BUT HAS THERE BEEN
DO YOU KNOW, IF THERE HAS BEEN
ANY CONVERSATIONS WITH REGARDS
TO TERM LIMITS OR WHAT WOULD THE
ONGOING ROLE WOULD BE ONCE THEY
ACTUALLY DO THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE BEING ESTABLISHED TO DO?
I COULD NOT ANSWER THE QUESTION
OF TERM LIMITS. I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT HAS BEEN CONSIDERED. I
THINK, YOU KNOW, THE MAIN POINT
IS THAT WE NEED TO HAVE SOMEBODY
WHO OWNS THE PROBLEM OF
HOMELESSNESS TO HAVE THAT
HOMELESSNESS CZAR, TO HAVE A
PERSON WHO IS CLEAR THAT SETS
GOALS. WE CURRENTLY DON'T EVEN
HAVE STATEWIDE HOMELESSNESS
GOALS, SO SOME OF THE REALLY THE
BASIC THINGS ABOUT OWNERSHIP OF
THE PROBLEM, WE DON'T HAVE, WE
WOULD NEED TO ASK THE AUTHOR,
STAFF ABOUT, TERM LIMITS. I'M
NOT SURE IF THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
OR IF ANYBODY IN THE ROOM KNOWS
THE ANSWER TO THAT, BUT, BUT
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION, AND I'M
SURE THEY COULD GET BACK TO YOUR
OFFICE ABOUT IT. I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE, LIKE, A
TIME CAPACITY FOR THEM TO
ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISH WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE ACCOMPLISHED, FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY PURPOSES, AND I
WOULD I WOULD JUST CAUTION YOU
THAT WE DID HAVE DIRECTORS THAT
WERE IN CHARGE OF THE, JUST
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A CZAR, YOU
HAVE SOMEBODY IN CHARGE, THEY
CAN CHANGE ALL THE TIME, AND
THEY, THEY THEY COULD NOT BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE. AT SOME POINT.
WE SAW THAT WITH ED, RIGHT. WITH
THE CONTINUOUS CHANGES IN, IN,
IN DIRECTORS IN THAT DEPARTMENT.
SO, THOUGH I ABSOLUTELY AGREE
WITH YOU THAT IT WOULD BE GREAT
TO HAVE SOMEBODY THAT'S
ACCOUNTABLE SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T
ALWAYS WORK THAT THE WAY THAT
IT'S INTENDED. SO, BUT I AM
GOING TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY, BUT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE KIND OF NICE TO,
TO HEAR FROM IF WE ARE GOING TO
CONSIDER, YOU KNOW, MOVING
FORWARD, WHETHER OR NOT, THERE
WILL BE A TERM LIMIT OR DEFINE
WHAT THE ONGOING PURPOSE WOULD
BE TO, HAVE THIS POSITION OPEN.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. DID WE
HAVE A MOTION? SOME SOME OF
THEM. ALL RIGHT. WE GOT A MOTION
FROM SENATOR OCHOA. BOGH, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES. WELL,
I'M CLEARLY NOT THE AUTHOR, BUT
I DO BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE A
SYSTEM WHERE WHERE THERE IS A
STATEMENT OF, WELL, THAT
ORGANIZATION IS NOT DOING ITS
JOB. I MIGHT BE DOING MY
DISCREET JOB AND THAT OTHER
ORGANIZATION THAT OTHER BRANCH
OF THE GOVERNMENT, THAT OTHER
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT ISN'T DOING
THEIR JOB. AND ULTIMATELY, IF
WE'RE GOING TO BE SERIOUS ABOUT
SOLVING FOR HOMELESSNESS, WE
HAVE TO HAVE A CLEAR OWNERSHIP
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND A DESIRE
TO SOLVE THE ACTUAL PROBLEM, NOT
JUST TO DO THE DISCREET JOB. SO
I THINK THE IDEA BEHIND THIS
BILL IS TO CENTER THAT AND THERE
MAY BE DIFFERENT WAYS TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT. BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE PASS THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT RAISES THE ISSUE AS
BEING VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO SEE SERIOUS
IMPROVEMENT IN THIS AREA. OKAY,
I AM SEEING THAT A SIMILAR BILL
CAME THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR AND WAS HELD, IN THE HOUSE.
SO, IF YOU WERE THE AUTHOR, I
WOULD ASK, YOU KNOW, WHAT HAS
CHANGED, I KNOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN SIMILAR, SIMILAR BILLS PUT
FORWARD THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE
AS WELL THIS YEAR, A LOT OF
APPETITE IN THE ASSEMBLY TO HAVE
A LEAD, HOMELESS COORDINATOR OR
CZAR AS, AS AS THEY'VE BEEN
CALLED. SO, I, I THINK WE'RE
HEADED IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. I
THINK THE QUESTION IS REALLY YOU
KNOW, THE HOW. RIGHT, RIGHT.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT, SO WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR OCHOA BOGH.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BLAKE SPEER,
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FILE ITEM 12 AB 2338. MOTION IS
DUE. PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ALVARADO GIL A
ALVARADO GIL I ECHO BOGUE. I
ECHO BOGUE. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER, I
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE LIMÓN.
MENGIBAR ALL RIGHT. THAT'S THREE
EYES AND NO NO'S. WE'LL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A CALL FOR
AUTHORS TO ROOM 2200 FOR HUMAN
SERVICES. WE'VE GOT JUST A FEW
BILLS. YEAH, JUST A FEW. SO WE
CAN WRAP UP HERE. WHILE WE ARE
WAITING FOR AUTHORS, WE WILL
TAKE A BRIEF RECESS. THANK YOU.
SHE'S JUST GOING TO CALL. I'M
JUST GOING TO DO CONSENT. YEAH.
DO THE CONSENT. THE ONES. YEAH
LET'S DO THAT. OKAY. COOL. OKAY.
ONLY TWO. ALL RIGHT. THAT WAS A
VERY QUICK RECESS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. WE ARE GOING
TO, LIFT THE CALL. BUT BEFORE WE
DO THAT, I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS OUR
CONSENT ITEMS. WE'VE GOT NINE
BILLS PROPOSED FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE. ITEM FOUR,
ASSEMBLY BILL 1913, FILE ITEM
FIVE. ASSEMBLY BILL 1930. FILE
ITEM TEN. ASSEMBLY BILL 2108.
FILE ITEM 13. ASSEMBLY BILL
2360. FILE ITEM 14. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2423. FILE ITEM 17.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2508. FILE ITEM
18. ASSEMBLY BILL 2636. FILE
ITEM 22. ASSEMBLY BILL 2795.
FILE ITEM 27. ASSEMBLY BILL
3291. DO ANY MEMBERS WISH TO
REMOVE ANY OF THESE BILLS FROM
CONSENT? OKAY WELL, DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR?
I'LL MOVE IT. OKAY. MOVED BY
SENATOR BLACKSHEAR, ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ECHO. BOGUE
BLAKE. SPEAR BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE.
LIMÓN MENGIBAR. AYE. MENGIBAR.
AYE THAT'S THREE EYES. WE WILL
LEAVE THAT ON CALL TO ALLOW FOR
OTHER VOTES, LET'S NOW LOOK AT
OUR AGENDA. ITEM NUMBER ONE,
ASSEMBLY BILL 922. WICKS, WHICH
IS FOR VOTE ONLY. NEED A MOTION
FOR THIS ONE. ALL RIGHT. WE NEED
A MOTION. WHICH ONE, ITEM NUMBER
ONE, ASSEMBLY BILL 922. WICKS
MOVED BY SENATOR MENGIBAR. THANK
YOU. OKAY, ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLE FILE ITEM ONE AB
922. DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ALVARADO GILL NOT
VOTING. XIAOBO BLAKE. SPEAR.
BLAKE. SPEAR. I LIMÓN. MENGIBAR.
Ã. MENGIBAR I HAVE TWO EYES. WE
WILL LEAVE THAT ON CALL AND
LET'S GO HEAD THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE FILE. ORDER MOVED BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. FILE ITEM TWO
AB 799. DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. BLAKE
SPEAR, BLAKE SPEAR. AYE. LIMÓN.
CHARLIE KIRK. THAT'S WHO IT'S
FOR. AND WE'RE WAITING FOR LIMÓN
FOR EYES. AND WE'LL LEAVE THAT
ON CALL. MOVED BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR FILE ITEM THREE AB
1907. MOTION IS DUE. PASSED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
BLAKE SPEAR. BLAKE SPEAR I LIMÓN
OKAY. YOU HAVE FOUR EYES, AND
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL. MOVED
BY SENATOR MENGIBAR FILE ITEM
SIX AB 2033. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
BLAKE SPEAR. BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE.
LIMÓN OKAY. FOUR ZERO, WE'LL
LEAVE ON CALL. MOVED BY SENATOR
OCHOA BOGUE, FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB 1961. DO PASS IS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR, BLAKE SPEAR
I LIMÓN SENATOR MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE FOUR EYES AND
THEY'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL.
MOVED BY SENATOR AKABOGU FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB, 1993. DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. BLAKE
SPEAR. BLAKE SPEAR I LIMÓN
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I THAT'S EYES
FOR. WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL.
MOVED BY SENATOR OCHOA BOGH FILE
ITEM NINE AB 2075. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. BLAKE SPEAR, BLAKE SPEAR.
AYE. LIMÓN. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR.
AYE EYES ARE FOR, NO. ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL. WE
NEED WE NEED A MOTION ON THIS
ONE. ALL RIGHT, SO, ASSEMBLY
BILL 2263, WE'RE LOOKING FOR A
MOTION MOVED BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR. THANK YOU. ASSISTANT.
CALL THE ROLE. OKAY. FILE ITEM
11, A B2263. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
ALVARADO. GIL. A ALVARADO GIL I
OCHOA. IS THIS, 11 2263? YOU
DIDN'T WANT TO DO THE MOTION ON
THIS ONE, SO I THINK YOU'RE OFF
OF IT. NOT VOTING. OKAY, BLAKE
SPEAR. BLAKE SPEAR. I LIMÓN
MENGIBAR. I MENGIBAR I THREE,
333 EYES ARE THREE NOES OR ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL. MOVED
BY SENATOR BOGUE, FILE ITEM 12
AB 2338. MOTION IS DUE. PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. LIMÓN MENGIBAR. OKAY, SO
IT'S STILL 3 TO 0. EYES ARE
THREE. WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL.
MOVED BY SENATOR MENGIBAR, FILE
ITEM 15 AB 2452. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. BLAKE SPEAR A BLAKE SPEAR.
AYE. LIMÓN MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR.
AYE FOUR EYES ARE FOUR. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT ON CALL AND THEN
MOVED BY SENATOR OCHOA. BOGH
FILE ITEM 16, AB 2476. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR. VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE LIMÓN. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR AYE. I'LL CALL FOR ON
CALL. EYES FOUR. WE'LL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL. OKAY EVERYTHING
ELSE? OKAY JUST, MOVED BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR, FILE ITEM 19,
AB 2704 Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING AYE
. VICE CHAIR. VOTING AYE. OH
OKAY. STILL, THAT'S STILL FOUR
EYES. WE'LL KEEP THAT ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT. I SEE WE HAVE A, AN
AUTHOR. WELCOME. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. HOOVER ALL RIGHT, WE'LL
HAVE YOU COME FORWARD. DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES WITH YOU
TODAY? NOT TONIGHT. THAT'S ALL
RIGHT. THEY ALL RETIRED FOR THE
EVENING. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. WELL,
WE HOPE TO BE THERE SOON AS
WELL, SO I KNOW LET'S GET YOU
STARTED. ITEM NUMBER 23,
ASSEMBLY BILL 2903. AND WE'LL
HEAR WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
TONIGHT. I KNOW WE'RE ALL
RUNNING AROUND TONIGHT, I'LL TRY
TO KEEP THIS SHORT. WE
INTRODUCED A BIPARTISAN AUDIT OF
HOMELESSNESS SPENDING LAST YEAR,
A NUMBER OF THE FOLKS ON THIS
COMMITTEE, I THINK, ACTUALLY
SUPPORTED THAT EFFORT, THE STATE
AUDITOR CAME BACK IN APRIL OF
THIS YEAR WITH THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS, AND ONE OF THEM
WAS PROPOSING THAT STATE
AGENCIES REPORT THE COSTS AND
OUTCOMES OF STATE FUNDED
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS, IT
FURTHER SUGGESTED THAT THE
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS DEVELOP GUIDANCE TO
ENSURE THAT THE DATA THAT
AGENCIES COLLECT BE UNIFORM IN
NATURE AND TO ANNUALLY COMPILE
THOSE AND REPORT THEM TO THE
PUBLIC. I THINK THIS WAS GIVEN
THE OTHER FINDINGS IN THE AUDIT,
WHICH FOUND THAT WE HAVE SPENT
NEARLY 24 BILLION TAXPAYER
DOLLARS ON HOMELESSNESS WHILE
SEEING A 32% INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS DURING THAT SAME
SPAN. I THINK IT REALLY
UNDERSCORED THE IMPORTANCE OF
INCREASING ACCOUNTABILITY OF
THESE DOLLARS. SO WITH THAT, I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. HAPPY TO TRY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AS WELL.
EXCELLENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
OKAY. ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE
HEARD, MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
COMMITTEE. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER.
YES, I APPRECIATE THE QUICK
ACTION AND SEEING THE AUDIT IN
APRIL AND THEN COMING FORWARD
WITH THIS BILL. AND IT SEEMS
LIKE A REALLY GOOD IDEA. SO I
SUPPORT IT AND WE'LL MOVE IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU, SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER OKAY. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
CONCERNS. ALL RIGHT. IT LOOKS
LIKE WE HAVE A MOTION. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE, JUST WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON IMPLEMENTING THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS, AND. YEAH,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT, ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FILE ITEM 20 3AB 20
903. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ALVARADO GIL, A
ALVARADO. GIL A AKOBO. AKOBO.
AYE BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE LIMÓN. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR
AYE FOR CALL. THANKS SO MUCH.
EYES ARE FOR. AND WE'LL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL, BECAUSE WHEN YOU
WRITE, YOU LEAVE YOUR HAND HERE
AND THEY CAN'T SEE YOU. SO JUST
LIKE, PULL IT BACK AND THEY CAN
SEE IT. SORRY. IF YOU WANT TO
LOOK THE CALL ON 24, BLAKESPEAR.
AND THEN TWO MORE. HAVEN'T VOTED
. ITEM NUMBER 24. THIS SACK
HERE. ARE WE GOING TO KEEP GOING
THROUGH? YEAH, YEAH. YOU GOT
WE'RE GOING TO GET YOU ON. MOVED
BY SENATOR BOGUE, FILE ITEM 24
AB 2935. DO PASS TO THE FLOOR.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE LIMÓN. MENGIBAR AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE FOUR. AND WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THAT ON CALL. OKAY,
SO EYES ARE FOR. AND WE'LL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL, WE HAVE ONE MORE
AUTHOR THAT WE'RE WAITING FOR
HERE. OKAY. CAN WE PUT A CALL IN
FOR OUR AUTHOR? I KNOW HE'S IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE, SO WE WILL GO
TO RECESS UNTIL WE GET OUR FINAL
AUTHOR TO VOTE ON OUR. OH, WE
JUST.
ALL RIGHT. WELCOME BACK. ALL
RIGHT. WE ARE DOING A FINAL CALL
FOR AUTHORS, IN ROOM 2200. FINAL
CALL FOR AUTHORS, WE WILL GO
THROUGH OUR LIFT. THE CALL ON
OUR, ON THE BILLS THAT WE HAVE
IN FRONT OF US. AND THIS WILL BE
THE FINAL CALL FOR AUTHORS. ALL
RIGHT, SO, ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WE WILL START
WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE, MOVED BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. FILE ITEM ONE
AB 922. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
THE CHAIR NOT VOTING. AND THE
VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING. ALVARADO
GILL. ECHO. BOGUE LIMÓN. LIMÓN
AYE. OKAY. THE VOTE IS THREE
EYES NO NO'S. AND THAT BILL
PASSES AND IT'S OUT. MOVED BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR FILE ITEM TWO
AB 799, MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. LEMON
A LEMON. AYE, THE VOTE IS FIVE
AYES AND THAT BILL IS OUT. MOVED
BY SENATOR MENGIBAR FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE, AB 1907. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
LIMÓN LIMÓN. AYE VOTE IS FIVE
EYES AND THAT BILL IS OUT. MOVED
BY SENATOR MENGIBAR FILE ITEM
SIX AB 2033. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. LEMON LEMON I
VOTE IS FIVE AYES, ZERO NOS.
THAT BILL IS OUT. OKAY MOVED BY
SENATOR AQUEBOGUE FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB 1961. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. LIMÓN
LIMÓN. AYE FIVE. THE VOTE IS
FIVE AYES, ZERO. KNOWS THAT BILL
IS OUT MOVED BY SENATOR BOGUE.
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB 1993. MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. LIMÓN LIMÓN AYE.
VOTES ARE FIVE AYES. NO NOS.
THAT BILL IS OUT. OKAY MOVED BY
SENATOR OCHOA. BOGH FILE ITEM
NINE AB 2075. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CHAIR. VOTING AYE.
VICE CHAIR. VOTING AYE. LIMÓN
LIMÓN. AYE. THE VOTE IS FIVE
AYES, NO NO'S. THAT BILL IS OUT.
MOVED BY SENATOR MENGIBAR FILE
ITEM 11 AB 2263. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR
VOTING AYE AND VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING AQUEBOGUE. LIMÓN. LIMÓN
AYE. VOTES ARE FOUR AYES, NO
NO'S THAT BILL IS OUT. MOVED BY
SENATOR JOE BOGUE, FILE ITEM 12
AB 2338. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. LIMÓN LIMÓN. AYE. MENGIBAR
VOTE IS FOR AYES. NO. NOS. THAT
BILL IS OUT. MOVED BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR FILE ITEM 15 AB 2452.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR. VOTING
AYE. SENATOR LIMÓN. SENATOR
LIMÓN AYE. VOTE IS FIVE AYES.
NO. NOS. THAT BILL IS OUT. OKAY.
MOVED BY SENATOR BOGUE. FILE
ITEM 16 AB 2476. MOTION IS DUE.
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR. VOTING
AYE. SENATOR LIMÓN. SENATOR
LIMÓN. AYE AYE. THE VOTE IS FIVE
AYES. NO NOS. THAT BILL IS OUT.
MOVED BY SENATOR MENGIBAR. FILE
ITEM 19, AB 20 704. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CHAIR. VOTING AYE.
VICE CHAIR. VOTING AYE. LIMÓN
Ã. LIMÓN. AYE. OKAY FIVE EYES.
THE VOTE IS FIVE EYES. THAT BILL
IS OUT. MOVED BY SENATOR BLAKE
SPEAR. FILE ITEM 20 AB 2752.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR. VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING
AKABOGU LIMÓN. Ã. LIMÓN. AYE.
THE VOTE IS FOUR AYES, NO NO'S.
THAT BILL IS OUT. MOVED BY
SENATOR BOGUE, FILE ITEM 21 AB
3193. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR. VOTING
AYE. LIMÓN LIMÓN. AYE. THE VOTE
IS FIVE AYES. NO ZERO NOS. THAT
BILL IS OUT. MOVED BY SENATOR
BLAKE SPEAR. FILE ITEM 23 AB 20
903. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. LIMÓN LIMÓN I THOSE
FIVE AYES. THAT BILL IS OUT
MOVED BY SENATOR BOGUE. FILE
ITEM 24 AB 2935. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE FLOOR WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR
VOTING I LIMÓN LIMÓN AYE. VOTE
IS FIVE AYES, ZERO NOS. THAT
BILL IS OUT AND THEN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. HOA BO O AYE HOA AYE.
LIMÓN LIMÓN AYE Ã CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE HAVE FIVE AYES. NO
NO'S. THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT. PERFECT. ALL RIGHT. LOOKS
LIKE WE'VE GOT AN AUTHOR. THANK
YOU, SENATOR MENGIBAR, FOR
TAKING US TO THE FINISH LINE. SO
WE WILL BE HEARING, ITEMS NUMBER
25, AB 30, 49 AND 26, AB 3145.
AND IF YOU HAVE WITNESSES, WE'LL
HAVE YOUR WITNESSES. WE DO. YES.
FOR AB 3049. WELCOME. ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT. GOOD EVENING, FELLOW
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ISAAC BRYAN ON AB
3049, A BILL THAT HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THUS FAR. I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANKING
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL. A RECENT STATEWIDE
SURVEY CONDUCTED BY ADVOCATES
AND THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY REVEAL THAT MANY
FOSTER CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA,
PARTICULARLY THOSE IN RURAL
COUNTIES, DO NOT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH OR
SPEAK WITH THEIR COURT APPOINTED
ATTORNEY BEFORE THEIR HEARINGS.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE. CHILDREN
IN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
DEPEND ON THEIR COURT APPOINTED
COUNSEL TO HELP THEM NAVIGATE AN
OFTEN TRAUMATIC AND CONFUSING
DEPENDENCY PROCESS. THIS BILL
AIMS TO IMPROVE OUR DEPENDENCY
COURT SYSTEM BY EMPOWERING A
JUDGE TO CONTINUE A HEARING IF
THEY FIND THAT A FOSTER YOUTH
HAS NOT HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONSULT WITH THEIR ATTORNEY. THE
BILL ALSO CODIFIES EXISTING
RULES OF COURT, WHICH ESTABLISH
GUIDELINES FOR COURT APPOINTED
DEPENDENCY ATTORNEYS, INCLUDING
REQUIRING THEM TO HAVE
SUFFICIENT CONTACT WITH THEIR
MINOR OR NON MINOR DEPENDENT
CLIENTS. AB 3049 WILL BRING
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE DEPENDENCY
COURT SYSTEM TO ENSURE THAT WHEN
LIFE ALTERING DECISIONS ARE MADE
ABOUT A CHILD, THAT DECISION IS
INFORMED BY THE CHILD'S OWN
OPINIONS AND LIVED EXPERIENCES.
WE, THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER, HAS
WORKED WITH VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS, INCLUDING THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL, TO AND HAVE
TAKEN SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS. MADAM
CHAIR, NOW, I'D LIKE TO TURN
OVER TO THE LEAD WITNESS HERE,
MARGARET COYNE, EXETER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR ADVOCATES. AND I
KNOW CHRISTOPHER HERNANDEZ JUST
HAD TO LEAVE. HE WAS FROM
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION. WAS
THAT OKAY? MISS MARGARET Ã TIME
HE HAD YOU SO MUCH. WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN. MY NAME
IS MARGARET. I'M THE CO-FOUNDER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
ADVOCATES THE, A LEGAL ADVOCACY
NONPROFIT. AND WE OPERATE THE
ONLY FREE TELEPHONE HOTLINE IN
LEGAL SERVICE AND PROVIDE FREE
LEGAL SERVICES TO ANYONE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO'S
CONCERNED ABOUT A CHILD IN
FOSTER CARE. WE MANAGE ABOUT 700
CASES ANNUALLY. CASES THAT
INVOLVE OVER 1000 CHILDREN PER
YEAR. WE'VE BEEN COLLECTING DATA
ON OUR CASES FOR 20 YEARS, AND
WE KNOW WE HAVE AN INCREDIBLY
INTENSE AND ROBUST SET OF DATA
AND A REAL EAR TO THE GROUND
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON AND WHAT
EXPERIENCES ARE BEING HAD BY
FOSTER CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR LEGAL SERVICES
ARE A CRITICAL LIFELINE FOR
CHILD ADVOCATES, INCLUDING
FOSTER AND RELATIVE CAREGIVERS
TRYING TO ADVOCATE FOR A CHILD
IN THEIR CARE. VERY OFTEN
THEY'RE CALLING OUR HOTLINE
BECAUSE A CHILD IS FACING A
TRAUMATIC EVENT, OFTENTIMES AN
ABRUPT, UNPLANNED MOVE, OR THEY
HAVE MEDICAL OR PSYCH NEEDS THAT
ARE NOT BEING MET, AND OUR
CALLERS DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
AND THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
TURN. THE FIRST QUESTION
ADVOCATES, STAFF ATTORNEYS ASK
EVERY HOTLINE CALLER IS, HAVE
YOU TALKED TO THIS CHILD'S
ATTORNEY? BECAUSE WHEN A CHILD
IS FACING A TRAUMATIC EVENT, THE
CHILD'S ATTORNEY HAS QUICK AND
DIRECT ACCESS TO THE JUVENILE
COURT TO SEEK PROTECTION OF THAT
CHILD. TOO OFTEN, THE ANSWER WE
HEAR FROM OUR CALLERS IS NO, I
DIDN'T KNOW THE CHILD HAD AN
ATTORNEY OR I THOUGHT THEY HAD
AN ATTORNEY, BUT I DIDN'T KNOW
WHO. I DON'T KNOW WHO IT IS.
WHAT WE KNOW FROM OUR CAREFULLY
COLLECTED DATA IS THAT IN MANY,
MANY COUNTIES, OFTENTIMES RURAL
COUNTIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA,
ATTORNEYS ARE FAILING TO MEET
THEIR TWO BASIC ETHICAL
OBLIGATIONS ONE, TO INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES AND SHARE THEIR
CONTACT INFORMATION WITH THE
CHILD AND THEIR CAREGIVERS, AND
TO HAVE REGULAR, ONGOING CONTACT
WITH THEIR CLIENT AND AN
ATTORNEY CLIENT RELATIONSHIP.
DESPITE WELFARE AND INSTITUTION
CODE 317, WHICH MANDATES THAT
THE COURT TAKE WHATEVER
APPROPRIATE ACTION IS NECESSARY
TO FULLY PROTECT THE INTERESTS
OF CHILDREN, A CHILD'S RIGHT TO
COMPETENT COUNSEL AND ENGAGED
COUNSEL IN CALIFORNIA IS
CURRENTLY NOT PROTECTED IN ANY
WAY OR ENFORCED IN ANY WAY. ALL
WE HAVE IN PLACE RIGHT NOW IS A
RULE OF COURT, WHICH REQUIRES
EVERY PRESIDING JUDGE TO
ESTABLISH A PROCESS FOR REVIEW
AND RESOLUTION OF COMPLAINTS BY
A PARTY REGARDING THE
PERFORMANCE OF THAT PARTY'S
COURT APPOINTED ATTORNEY, EVEN
IF A CHILDREN AND YOUTH WERE IN
FACT INFORMED OF THEIR RIGHT TO
LODGE A COMPLAINT, AND THEY'RE
NOT, THIS TRULY IS AN INADEQUATE
REMEDY TO PROTECT A CHILD OR
YOUTH. A YOUNG CHILD CANNOT
POSSIBLY LODGE A COMPLAINT IN
WRITING TO THE PRESIDING JUDGE,
AND OLDER YOUTH DO NOT FEEL
EMPOWERED OR SAFE COMPLAINING
ABOUT THEIR ATTORNEY. THIS IS
NOT A CHILD OR YOUTH'S BURDEN THE COURT'S JOB TO
PROTECT THEM. 3049 ALLOWS THE
COURT TO GRANT A CONTINUANCE IF
THE CHILD OR YOUTH HAS NOT HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONSULT WITH
THEIR ATTORNEY. THIS IS ONE
CRITICAL, CRITICAL STEP FORWARD
TOWARDS ENSURING THAT ATTORNEYS
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO ENGAGE IN ANY
COURT PROCEEDINGS ABOUT A CHILD,
CLIENT WITH WHOM THEY HAVE HAD
NO CONTACT. I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB 3049, AND I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GAVE YOU A LITTLE
BIT OF EXTRA TIME BECAUSE I
APPRECIATE THAT TO GO. I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU LETTING ME LEAN
INTO THAT. THAT'S ALL RIGHT, ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC LOVE TO
COME FORWARD? ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. SURE. REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SUPPORT. GREAT.
THANK YOU. SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD? ALL
RIGHT. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THEIR
OPPOSITION. OKAY. WE'LL BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. I'LL BE HAPPY TO MOVE
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. I HEARD
FIRST OVER HERE ON THE LEFT, WE
HAVE A MOTION. FROM SENATOR
LIMÓN. WELCOME, SENATOR LIMÓN,
TO HUMAN SERVICES. WE'RE A FUN
BUNCH. YES, WE'RE A FUN BUNCH.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
SENATOR? AND AGREE, GENTLEMEN?
YES, YES. OH, YEAH. THAT'S RIGHT
. AND OUR SERGEANTS. YES. YOU
URGE AND I, BILL AND I YES, I
WAS TRYING THERE WAS A GOOD
SENTENCE IN HERE IN THE FAQ. I
WAS TRYING TO REPEAT, BUT YES,
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY, GREAT. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, WE WILL CALL THE
ROLL. THANK YOU. FILE ITEM 25 AB
3049. MOTION IS DUE. PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
ALVARADO GIL A, ALVARADO GIL A
AQUEBOGUE CHOBOQ. AYE. BLAKE
SPEAR. LEMON A LEMON. I MENGIBAR
I MENGIBAR I OKAY, SO WE HAVE
FOUR EYES. WE WILL LEAVE THAT ON
CALL. WAIT FOR SENATOR BLAKE
SPEAR. SHE'S NOT. SHE'S NOT
COMING BACK. ALL RIGHT. SORRY,
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR, WE'RE GOING
TO. WE'RE GOING TO CALL THAT
VOTE OUT. SO EYES FOR NO. ZERO.
THAT IS OUT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. OUR FINAL, FINAL BILL OF
THE NIGHT BEFORE THE FINAL BILL
A LITTLE STIR. STIR CRAZY. ALL
RIGHT, MADAM CHAIR. AB 3145,
ONCE AGAIN PRESENTING ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER ISAAC BRYAN IS
A TIMELY AND NECESSARY BILL THAT
BRINGS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT TO COURT. ORDERED
SERVICES FOR PARENTS IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM IN MOST
CASES, WHEN A CHILD IS REMOVED
FROM A PARENT'S CARE, A COURT
ORDERS THE PARENT INTO A VARIETY
OF SERVICES TO ASSIST IN
REHABILITATION BEFORE THE CHILD
CAN BE RETURNED TO THEIR CARE. A
PARENT'S PROGRESS AND COMPLETION
OF THESE SERVICES INFLUENCES A
SOCIAL WORKER MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT A PARENT'S
ABILITY TO SAFELY REUNIFY WITH
THEIR CHILD. JUDGES ALSO HEAVILY
RELY ON THIS INFORMATION WHEN
DECIDING TO ENTER PERMANENTLY.
WHEN DECIDING TO. WHEN DECIDING
TO EITHER PERMANENTLY TERMINATE
A PARENT'S RIGHT TO THEIR CHILD
OR TO REUNIFY WITH THE FAMILY,
THESE SERVICES CAN COST
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS PER COURSE,
MAKING THEM A FINANCIAL BURDEN
FOR COUNTIES WITH ALREADY
STRETCHED FOSTER CARE BUDGETS.
DESPITE THE HEAVY EMPHASIS
PLACED ON THESE SERVICES AND
THEIR COSTLY NATURE, COUNTIES DO
NOT TRACK THE OUTCOMES AND
MERITS OF THEIR SERVICE
PROVIDERS. EARLIER THIS YEAR, LA
TIMES CALLED OUT THE LACK OF
INFORMATION ON THE EFFICACY OF
SERVICES AND SERVICE PROVIDERS.
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM FAILED. THIS
WAS IN RESPONSE TO A DEATH OF
TWO CHILDREN INVOLVED WITH LA
DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES. THE SYSTEM
FAILED THESE TWO CHILDREN BY
FAILING TO PROVIDE THEIR PARENTS
WITH MEANINGFUL QUALITY HELP TO
ADDRESS THE CAUSES AND TRAUMAS
THAT LED TO THEIR INVOLVEMENT
WITH THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM IN
THE FIRST PLACE. I'D LIKE TO.
NOW I'M SORRY, SOME MEMBER
STAFF. I'M GOING TO SKIP THE
REST AND JUST TURN TO THE
WITNESS HERE TO SPEAK MORE ON
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. SO I KNOW
WE HAVE OPPOSITION AS WELL. WHY
DON'T YOU COME ON FORWARD AND
WE'LL HEAR FROM EACH OF YOU,
OKAY. ALL RIGHT, GOOD EVENING,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ED
HOWARD, SENIOR COUNSEL AT THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY INSTITUTE AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO
SCHOOL OF LAW. REGRETTABLY, OUR
POLICE TO SPONSOR THIS MEASURE.
REGRETTABLY OUR WITNESS HAD TO
LEAVE BACK TO LOS ANGELES. SO
WHAT? I'D LIKE TO DO IS QUICKLY
READ THE STATEMENT THAT HE WOULD
HAVE READ TO YOU TODAY. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MY NAME IS
MILES COOLEY. I AM AN ATTORNEY,
PARTNER AT FRIEDMAN, TATELMAN
AND COOLEY, AND A FORMER FOSTER
CHILD. I LIVED AT THE SACRAMENTO
CHILDREN'S HOME HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. I SERVE ON THE BOARD
OF THE LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS, AND I'M PRO BONO
COUNSEL FOR PEACE FOR KIDS, A
FOSTER YOUTH NGO WORKING IN THE
WATTS WILLOWBROOK AREA OF SOUTH
CENTRAL LOS ANGELES. IN THE
PAST, I'VE WORKED TO SECURE
FOSTER CARE REFORM, INCLUDING
WORKING TO ENACT AB 12. TO SAY
THAT I AM ONE OF THE LUCKY ONES
IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT. MY PARENTS
WERE BOTH TEENAGERS. WHEN I WAS
FIVE. I FOUND MY MOTHER DEAD OF
A DRUG OVERDOSE. I ENTERED
FOSTER CARE AT SIX. LIKE TOO
MANY OF OUR FOSTER CHILDREN, I
AM AFRICAN-AMERICAN CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB 3145 IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT FOSTER CARE BILLS
YOU WILL CONSIDER. AND HERE'S
WHY. SPEND A LOT OF TIME IN
DEPENDENCY COURTROOMS AND YOU
WILL HEAR THE WORD SERVICES
BANDIED ABOUT A LOT. THAT'S
BECAUSE SUCH SERVICES PLAY.
MAYBE THE MOST IMPORTANT ROLE IN
DETERMINING WHETHER A CHILD
INVOLVED WITH CHILD WELFARE WILL
BE REUNITED WITH THEIR PARENTS,
OR HAVE THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEIR PARENTS FOREVER SEVERED
AND PLACED IN FOSTER CARE.
PARENTS ARE OFFERED SERVICES TO
FIX WHATEVER THE PROBLEM WAS
THAT CAUSED CHILD WELFARE TO GET
INVOLVED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
DRUG ADDICTION PARENT IS OFFERED
DRUG COUNSELING, DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE, ANGER MANAGEMENT,
NEGLECT, PARENTING CLASSES. THIS
IS US SPENDING OUR TAX DOLLARS
TO TRY AND KEEP FAMILIES INTACT.
HERE'S THE CRITICAL PIECE. IF
THE SERVICE PROVIDER SAYS A
PARENT HAS SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETED THE SERVICES, A JUDGE
USUALLY RULES THAT IT IS SAFE TO
RETURN THE CHILD TO THEIR
PARENTS. BUT IF A SERVICE
PROVIDER SAYS THE OPPOSITE, THEN
THE PARENT'S RIGHTS WILL USUALLY
BE TERMINATED AND THE CHILD WILL
ENTER, FOSTER CARE FAMILIES LIVE
OR DIE BASED ON THESE SERVICES.
SO IT CAME AS A COMPLETE SHOCK
TO ME TO READ THE FOLLOWING IN
THE LOS ANGELES TIMES. QUOTE.
THE STATE DOES NOT ENSURE THAT
PARENT EDUCATION PROGRAMS MEET
ANY SORT OF STANDARDS. ALLOWS
PARENTS FACING ABUSE ALLEGATIONS
TO TAKE CLASSES THAT EXPERTS
HAVE DEEMED LOW QUALITY AS THE
TIME ALSO CORRECTLY REPORTS,
QUOTE, THE LACK OF SCRUTINY CAN
PUT SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN AT RISK OF
MORE ABUSE. BUT CHAIR AND
MEMBERS IF NOBODY IS PROBING THE
QUALITY OF THE SERVICES, THIS
ALSO MEANS THAT FAMILIES MAY BE
FOREVER TORN APART WITHOUT A
SOUND BASIS FOR DOING SO. THE
BILL BEFORE YOU IN THE MAIN,
SIMPLY REQUIRES COUNTIES TO DO
THE KIND OF DUE DILIGENCE WE
WOULD DO IN CHOOSING A
CONTRACTOR FOR HOME FOR HOME
IMPROVEMENT. ASK ABOUT
INDIVIDUAL OUTCOMES AND IN LIGHT
OF THE TIMES INVESTIGATION, IT
ESTABLISHES A MORE PROBING
MEASURE TO DETECT SYSTEM WIDE
PROBLEMS. I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO DO RIGHT BY OUR PARENTS,
CHILDREN, AND TAXPAYERS AND VOTE
AYE ON THIS MEASURE. THE WELFARE
OF CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER KIDS
DEPENDS UPON IT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
OKAY. WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM OUR
LEAD OPPOSITION. WELCOME BACK.
HI. GOOD EVENING, AMANDA
KIRCHNER AGAIN FOR COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION,
WE ARE REGRETTABLY STILL IN
OPPOSITION, ALTHOUGH WE HAD
GREAT CONVERSATIONS AT THE END
OF LAST WEEK, AND WE THINK WE'RE
MOVING CLOSER ON LANGUAGE THAT
WE CAN AGREE TO, I WILL SAY THAT
PART OF OUR CONCERN RIGHT NOW
WITH THE LANGUAGE AS IS IN PRINT
IS THAT CHILD WELFARE SERVICES
THAT ARE OFFERED ARE CONTRACTED
THROUGHOUT NUMEROUS DIFFERENT
PARTS OF OUR COUNTY. SO I WAS
TALKING TO A COUNTY TODAY. THEY
BRAID TOGETHER SOME CALWORKS
FUNDING FOR HOME VISITING. THEY
USE MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING. THEY
USE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FUNDING
AND THE TITLE FOR BE FUNDING
THAT THEY GET FOR CHILD WELFARE.
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IF
WE'RE GOING TO CREATE STANDARDS
FOR OUR SERVICE PROVIDERS, THAT
THOSE STANDARDS ARE THINGS THAT
WE CAN SORT OF BROADLY MAKE
SURE. AND WE'RE NOT, ESSENTIALLY
HAVING TO DOUBLE CONTRACT FOR.
SO THAT'S PART OF THE CONCERNS
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS, AND
MORE, MORE BROADLY, JUST AS FAR
AS PARENTING SERVICES, WE THINK
A WORK GROUP APPROACH MIGHT BE
NEEDED HERE WITH SOME STATE
LEADERSHIP AROUND WHAT SHOULD
THESE SERVICES LOOK LIKE SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT JUST A KITCHEN SINK
APPROACH AND THAT THEY'RE WELL
TAILORED TO THE CASE PLAN FOR
THE PARENTS. AND I THINK THAT
REQUIRES A MUCH BROADER
CONVERSATION, AS WELL AS
INCLUDING OUR JUDICIARY,
PARTNERS. AND OF COURSE,
COUNTIES AND OUR SOCIAL WORKERS
AND PARENTS AND ADVOCATES AND
THEIR ATTORNEYS, SO WE WOULD NOT
BE OPPOSED TO SEEING THIS TAKE
MORE OF A WORKING GROUP APPROACH
, TO TRY AND DEAL WITH THAT
LARGER PROBLEM. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY ALL RIGHT.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC LIKE
TO EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION? ALL
RIGHT. LET'S BRING QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SO I'M READY. SENATOR CHOBOQ.
YEAH YOU GOT THIS. ALL RIGHT. SO
I'M JUST GOING TO CURIOUS AS TO
THE CONCERNS FROM THE OPPOSITION
, ARE YOU AT ALL FAMILIAR, AWARE
WHETHER OR NOT THE AUTHOR IS
CURRENTLY WORKING TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS? ABSOLUTELY. YOU
HEARD FROM QUDAH THAT THEY'VE
BEEN WORKING REALLY CLOSELY WITH
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER, AND THEY
JUST WEREN'T ABLE TO GET ON THE
SAME PAGE BEFORE THIS HEARING.
BUT BOTH. BUT THE AUTHOR HAS
COMMITTED TO THE OPPOSITION AND
WORKING THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER ON
GETTING CLOSER TO A COMPROMISE.
AND I THINK QUDAH WOULD SAY THAT
IS CORRECT. YES. THAT'S CORRECT.
WE'VE BEEN EXCHANGING POTENTIAL
AMENDMENTS OVER THE LAST FEW
DAYS. OKAY, WONDERFUL. SO
THERE'S SO WE'RE OPTIMISTIC THAT
IT WILL WORK TOWARDS THE IDEAL.
ONE THING THE AUTHOR WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE THOUGH, I KNOW THE CDA
HAS TALKED, HAS REQUESTED A MORE
OF A WORKING GROUP. I MEAN, THE
AUTHOR WOULD LIKE THE COMMITTEE
TO NOTE THAT, YOU KNOW, THE LA
TIMES ARTICLE WAS REALLY DIRE.
IT SAID CHILDREN ARE DYING NOW
IN A WORKING GROUP, BUT REALLY
JUST PROLONG THE PROCESS. IF YOU
LOOK AT THIS BILL, IT'S ABOUT
COLLECTING OUTCOMES. YOU CAN
LOOK AT THAT AS A STUDY
APPROACH, RIGHT? IT'S NOT ASKING
FOR CHANGES OR ANYTHING. IT'S
JUST ASKING FOR AN OUTCOME. SO
THEN WE CAN COME BACK AND LOOK
AT POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE OUTCOMES WE COLLECT. OKAY.
AND THEN, THE LAST QUESTION I
HAD IS FOR THE FOR THE CHAIR,
MADAM CHAIR, IS THIS MOVING
FORWARD STRAIGHT TO THE SENATE
FLOOR OR WILL THIS BE GOING
THROUGH ANOTHER COMMITTEE? I
APPROPS SO THERE IS TIME FOR,
CONTINUED, CONVERSATIONS AND
WORK ON THAT. OKAY. I WILL BE
HAPPY TO, TO MAKE A MOTION FOR
THE BILL. AND IT WILL LOOK TO
SEE THE LANGUAGE AND RESERVE MY
RIGHT TO CHANGE MY VOTE ONCE IT
COMES BACK TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
HIS STAFF HAS NOTED ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, YOU KNOW,
WITH WITH ALL BILLS THAT, YOU
KNOW, REALLY ENCOMPASS CHILDREN
ACROSS CALIFORNIA FOR ME, I'M
LOOKING FOR THAT RURAL ELEMENT
AND I'M LOOKING FOR THAT,
ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES AND APPROACHES IN URBAN
SETTINGS DON'T ALWAYS WORK IN
OUR RURAL CALIFORNIA SETTINGS.
SO I WANT US TO BE SENSITIVE TO
THAT, ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO
COMB THROUGH THIS LEGISLATION
AND SEE WHERE WE CAN ENSURE THAT
ALL OF CALIFORNIA IS ONE, NOT
UNDER POLICY, BUT UNDER
RECOGNITION THAT, YOU KNOW,
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES HAVE
DIFFERENT APPROACHES, SO I WANT
TO JUST MAKE SURE I PUT THAT ON
RECORD, AND JUST LOOKING FORWARD
TO THIS, CONVERSATIONS
CONTINUING WITH OPPOSITION TO
GET TO THAT MEANINGFUL MIDDLE.
OKAY. GREAT. THANK YOU. SO WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR BORG.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, JUST TO
RESPOND TO YOU, MADAM CHAIR, THE
AUTHOR RECOGNIZES, THAT THERE
HAS BEEN SOME CONCERNS COMING
FROM THE FROM THE OPPOSITION
THAT ECHO YOUR SAME SENTIMENT,
AND IT'S NOT THE INTENT OF THE
AUTHOR TO HAVE ADVERSE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS ON THE RURAL COUNTIES
AND IS COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION ON ADDRESSING
THAT POINT. WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL CALL THE
ROLL FILE ITEM 26 AB 3145.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO GIL A ALVARADO GIL A
AQUEBOGUE AKABOGU AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER, LIMÓN. AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR AYE. OKAY,
THAT'S FOUR ZERO. AND THAT BILL
IS OUT. ALL RIGHT. ARE WE CLOSED
? EVERYTHING WE GOT EVERYTHING.
ALL OF THEM DONE. ALL RIGHT, SO
I HAD A LONG SOLILOQUY. I WAS
GOING TO SAY TO KEEP YOU ALL
HERE, BUT NO, WE'RE GOING TO
WRAP THIS UP. SO GREAT WORK TO
OUR STAFF, THANK YOU, SERGEANTS,
FOR KEEPING US HERE AND ON
TRACK. THANK YOU, MEMBERS, FOR
BEING PRESENT AND ENGAGING AND
GETTING US THROUGH THIS VERY
LONG AGENDA. WE ARE OUT AND YOU
KNOW.